Scholastic Audio presents Wings of Fire
Book 3, The Hidden Kingdom, by 2 E T
Sutherland, read by Shannon McManus.
The Dragonette Prophecy.
When the war has lasted 20 years, the
dragonettes will come, when the land is
soaked in blood and tears, the
dragonettes will come.
Find the sea wing egg of deepest blue
wings of night shall come to you.
The largest egg in mountain high will
give to you the wings of sky.
For wings of earth, search through the
mud, for an egg the color of dragon blood
and hidden alone from the rival queens.
The sand wing egg awaits unseen.
Of 3 queens who blister and blaze and
burn.
Two shall die, and one shall learn, If
she bows to a fate that is stronger and
higher, Shall have the power of wings of
fire.
Five eggs to hatch on brightest night
five dragons born to end the fight.
Darkness will rise to bring the light.
The dragonettes are coming.
Prologue.
The five Dragonettes were fighting.
Again, bright scales in green and red and
gold caught the rising sun as the young
dragons darted between the rocks, claws
and teeth flashing.
Five forked tongues hissed with fury.
Beyond them, below the cliff, the sea
crashed against the sand with a muffled
rushing sound, as if it didn't want to
compete with the shouts of the dragons.
It was embarrassing, was what it was.
Nautilus glanced up uneasily at the
massive black dragon beside him.
The dragonettes were so busy yelling at
one another that they hadn't even noticed
him yet.
Nautilus wished he could read Morrow
Seer's mind, the way Morrow Seer was
undoubtedly reading his.
He also wished there were more talons of
peace around, but when word spread that
the night wing was coming, most of them
suddenly found urgent missions
elsewhere.
The peace movements hideout in the
seaside cliffs, was virtually deserted
this morning.
Occasionally a dragon snout would emerge
from one of the caves, spot Morosier, and
instantly vanish again.
The 5 dragonettes were the only ones on
top of the cliffs, although there were
several other young dragons living with
the talents of peace, they'd all been
whisked out of sight.
But apparently no one had seen fit to
warn the objects of Morrow Seers' scrutiny
that he was coming, or that they were
going to be inspected.
Well, Maro Seer said.
They are.
Energetic.
They were just a backup plan.
Nautilus said defensively.
Nobody thought we'd need them, especially
not all of them.
We thought maybe one or two if something
went wrong with the originals.
We haven't spent a lot of time training
them.
I can see that.
Moro Seer's dark eyes narrowed as Viper.
The sand wing fell into a crevice, and
the mud wing promptly tripped and landed
on top of her.
With a hiss, Viper whipped around and bit
Ocher's tail, setting off a yowling
whine.
Excuse me, Nautilus said.
He could see where this was going.
He stepped forward, cuffed Viper's ears
and snatched Squid, the little green sea
wing out of the way before the others
could set his tail on fire.
Stop this. he hissed.
You are being watched.
Flame, the red Sky Wing Dragonette
snapped his mouth shut and whipped his
head around, scanning the twisted rocks
of the sea cliff.
Maro Seer stepped into the light of the
sunrise. and look down his snout
majestically.
I knew it, crowed the little Nightwing
Dragonette.
Fate speaker leaped off a stone pillar
flapping her wings proudly.
I knew a nightwing was coming to see us.
Didn't I tell you guys this would
happen?
Did you?
Ogre scratched his large brown head.
No, said Viper.
Don't think so, piped up Squid from
behind Nautilus's back.
Even if you did, you also predicted an
earthquake, a new talent of peace and
that we'd have something besides seagulls
for breakfast this week, said Flame.
And since none of those things have
happened, you can see why we might have
stopped listening.
Well, I knew, fate speaker said
blithely.
I thought with my powers, and I foresee
that he brought us something great for
breakfast, didn't you?
She beamed up at Maro Seer.
He blinked slowly.
Hmm.
Nautilus.
A word, please.
Can I come too?
The black dragonette asked, bouncing
closer tomorrow's seer.
I've never met another night wing
before.
Although, of course, I feel a very strong
psychic connection with our whole tribe.
Stay here.
Marosi pressed one claw into her chest
and moved her back to the other
dragonettes.
She sat down and curled her tail around
her talons with a huffing snort.
Morosier stepped down the rocks, out of
earshot.
When he turned, he found Nautilus right
behind him.
The clinging to his tail was the sea wing
dragonette.
Maro seer gazed at Squid disapprovingly.
I can't leave him alone with them
Nautilus said apologetically.
Whenever I'm not watching, one of them
bites him.
Or, they all do, sniffed the small green
dragon.
Maro Seer flicked his tongue out and in
considering.
It is clear to me, said the enormous
night wing after a moment.
That leaving the dragonettes of the
prophecy and the care of the talons of
peace was a mistake.
Both the real ones and the false ones.
Who?
asked the dragonette.
Hush, said Nautilus, covering the
dragonette's snout with one talent.
He saw the look on Maru Seer's face and
added hastily, You remember, Squid, we
taught you about the prophecy?
You know the war that all the dragon
tribes are fighting?
The one you want to stop, Squid said.
Because we're the good guys.
We want peace.
Right, said Nautilus.
Basically, right.
So the prophecy says that 5 dragonettes
were hatched about 6 years ago, a sea
wing, a sky wing, a mud wing, a sand wing
and a night wing, who are going to end
the war.
They get to choose which sister should be
the new sandwing queen.
Burn, blister, or blaze.
Oh, said Squid.
Hey, I hatched about 6 years ago.
Really?
said Morrow Seer.
You're barely in the size of a 3 year old
dragonette.
I have a big personality, Squid informed
him, as if he had been told this enough
times that he was certain everyone knew
it.
And your friends are about 6 years old
too.
Nautilus said quickly.
They're not my friends.
Squid grumbled.
They're all bullies, except for Fate
Speaker, who is plain crazy.
Maro Sierr glanced back at fate speaker
the Nightwing Dragonette.
She was sitting on top of a twisted stone
column, leaning so far toward them that
she looked in imminent danger of
overbalancing and toppling off.
Well, squid, Nautilus said.
What if you were one of the dragonettes
in the prophecy?
What would you think about that?
The Sea Wing gave Marosir a canny look?
Would I get treasure?
You'd get fame, and power, said Morris
Seer.
If you did what you were told, that is.
How about treasure?
Squid insisted.
Maru Seer gave Nautilus an incredulous
look.
Is this dragonette?
Bargaining with me?
I like treasure, Squid pointed out.
A talented peace are so lame because none
of them have any treasure.
We gave up worldly things to fight for a
higher cause, Nautilus said.
Peace is more important than jewels or
gold.
Nah, said Squid.
I'd rather have gold.
Would you be willing to choose whichever
sandwing queen we told you to, Marosir
asked.
If so, we could perhaps talk about gold.
All right, Squid said, with a gleam in
his eye.
But I don't want Flame to be part of it.
He has to stay here.
Why?
What's wrong with your Sky Wing?
Maro Sierr asked Nautilus.
Nothing.
Nautilus said.
They are just having a fight today.
And every day, Squid said, because he's
mean.
The Sky Wing is non-negotiable, said Maro
Seer.
You're non-negotiable, Squid said.
Squid, be polite, said Nautilus tiredly.
I foresee that I am going to regret this
said Maru Seer, frowning down at the sea
wings.
But I will be taking over the training of
the prophecy dragonette.
They have been mishandled for too long.
Obviously they need clearer guidance.
What does that mean?
Nautilus asked.
A sense of dread was starting to creep
across his scales.
He glanced at Squid.
Perhaps they should have chosen a
different sea wing to be the fake
dragonette of the prophecy.
If Maru seer hurts squid.
If anything happens to him, his mother is
going to kill me, Nautilus thought.
It means they're coming with me.
Maro Seer said, with a flick of his
tail.
Where?
Squid demanded.
You'll find out when we get there, said
Marusir.
And if you know what's good for you
you'll stop asking nosy questions and do
what you're told.
I can do that, Squid said, but good luck
with Flame and Viper.
He thought for a moment.
And fate speaker. for that matter.
Wait, no, said Nautilus.
He tried to fill his mind with noise, so
the Nightwing couldn't read his
thoughts.
You can't take them, except for fate
speaker who came from you.
All their parents are talents.
That's how we got their eggs in the 1st
place.
They won't want them to leave.
Except ogre, Squid offered.
His mom won't care.
It's a mud wing thing.
Shut up.
Said Morrow Seer.
He studied Nautilus with narrow black
eyes.
Don't think it.
Nautilus repeated to himself.
Three moons, Maro Seer said with
disgust.
This dragonet, is your son?
Nautilus stared down at his claws, and it
seems like a good idea when the talons
1st decided to have backup dragonettes.
Squid hatched around the right time, if
not exactly on the brightest night, and
it meant that everyone in the movement
treated the dragonette like the precious
creature Nautilus knew he was.
Of course I am. said Squid.
Isn't that a funny coincidence?
Wow.
I'm the son of the leader of the talons
of peace, and a dragonette of destiny.
He puffed out his chest.
I'm even more important than I thought I
was.
He strutted off toward the other
Dragonettes, having forgotten. as he
often did that none of them liked hearing
about how important he was, and that he
would almost certainly end up with a
singed snout before long.
Nautilus watched him go, wondering how
everything had gone so wrong.
Why had the talons agreed to work with
Maru Seer?
Why had they decided to get involved with
a prophecy in the 1st place?
And how had they lost the real
Dragonettes?
That was the question that drove him
crazy.
Kestrel Dune and Webbs should have been
able to keep a handle on 5 dragonettes
especially when they were conveniently
trapped in a secret cave.
Instead, the 5 had escaped.
Then possibly killed Queen Scarlet of the
Sky Wings, thrown the Sky Kingdom into
upheaval, turned Queen Coral against her
allies, wrecked the Sea Wing Palace, and
disappeared once more into the wild
Zapira.
Worse yet, there was no one to punish.
Kestrel and June were dead, while Webbs
had wriggled away from the talons and
vanished, and who knew where the
dragonets were, or when they'd turn up
again with their spectacular talent for
trouble and chaos.
Quite a coincidence.
Maro Seer echoed Squid's remark, sounding
rather unimpressed.
Well, said Nautilus.
I thought why not?
Of course, none of these 5 actually
hatched on the brightest night, or else
they'd be the real dragonets of the
prophecy, wouldn't they?
But they are about the right age, and
nobody has to know the rest.
Except anyone who was at their hatching.
Marosia mused.
It would be tidier if we could kill any
witnesses.
Nautilus blanched.
Do their parents count as witnesses?
He wondered, before he could squelch the
thought.
We'll cross that bridge when we come to
it, Marosier said briskly.
Since we can't be sure yet which of these
we'll use and which we'll discard.
He frowned at fate speaker, who was
eagerly interrogating squid.
Nautilus felt properly faint now.
Discard?
He echoed.
Moro Seer snorted.
Very well.
I'll try to bring yours back in one
piece.
He wrinkled his snout, looking as close
to amused as Nautilus had ever seen him.
But isn't peace, the most important thing
Seawing?
Don't you tell your talons all the time
that any sacrifice must be made to end
this war.
Yes, but the alternate dragonets were
your idea in the 1st place.
A good idea, as it turns out, since the
real ones have proven to be so
unsatisfactory.
Marasir hissed softly.
So we get rid of the most dangerous
ones.
I train their replacements myself.
He smiled in a way that made Nautilus
feel queasy. right down to his claws.
And then, We make sure the prophecy is
fulfilled.
The way it was supposed to be.
Chapter one.
It had been raining for 5 days.
Glory officially hated it.
She also was not enjoying the comments
from the other dragonettes about how as a
rain wing.
She should love this weather.
She most certainly did not love this
weather.
In the caves under the mountain.
The dragoness had never, ever been rained
on.
This downpour felt unnatural and
unstoppable and horribly, unpleasantly
wet.
I don't care if a real rain wing is
supposed to like this, she thought, as
droplets rolled off her snout, seeped
through her scales, and soaked her wings
until they dragged heavily behind her.
If they do, there's something wrong with
them.
No sensible dragon should enjoy weather
that makes it so hard to fly.
Three moons.
Please let them be sensible dragons.
Let them be nothing like the stories.
Everyone said rain wings were useless and
lazy.
But the tribe lived off by themselves in
the rainforest, where no one ever saw
them.
So everyone might be wrong.
Glory was really hoping they were wrong.
She shook her whole body and glared at
the fog shrouded sky.
What she wanted was more sun.
She'd missed the sun her whole life and
had known it until it hit her scales the
day they left the caves.
More long sunny days would be fine by
her.
Instead, there was this.
Rain, mud, more rain, more mud, plus one
moaning, groaning, dripping, slow poke of
a wounded sea wing.
Can we stop?
Webbs gasped.
I need to rest.
He floundered through the mud to a
slightly drier spot under a tree.
Glory narrowed her eyes at him as the
blue green dragon flopped to the ground.
The other dragonettes stopped too
exchanging glances.
They were walking today instead of flying
because Webbs said it was easier on his
injury, and yet he still asked to stop
nearly every 10 steps.
Glory was starting to suspect he didn't
really want them to get to the
rainforest.
But why?
She wondered.
Is he hiding something?
Does it have to do with my parents?
As the guardian who had stolen her from
the rain wing tribe in the 1st place
Webbs should have been a helpful fount of
knowledge about where she came from.
Instead, he got all mumbly and forgetful
whenever they asked about the rainforest
dragons.
Clay paced over to Webbs and peered down
at his wound.
They'd wrapped it with seaweed soaked in
ocean water for as long as they could, but
now they were too far inland to get any
more.
The poisoned scratch near Webb's tail had
become an ugly gash, surrounded by
blackened scales, and the black seemed to
spread a bit more each day.
None of them had any idea what to do to
combat sandwing poison.
Not to mention, we have no idea why
blister wanted webs dead so badly.
I mean, I think he's awful, but she
doesn't even know him.
Glory glanced at Starflight, the Black
Knight Wing, who was the smartest
dragonette she knew, and probably still
would be, even if she knew more than 4
dragons.
She wondered if he had any theories about
blister and webs.
Clay swept his tail through the mud
looking worried.
I hope the rain wings can help him, he
said.
This isn't exactly like their venom.
But maybe they'll have more ideas than we
do.
Glory shook out her wings and looked
away.
She didn't care.
The other Dragonettes felt some kind of
misguided loyalty to their old guardian
as if it was their responsibility to save
him.
She was the only one who seemed to
remember how he'd been willing to stand
by and let someone kill her.
Stealing her egg had been his idea too.
The prophecy called for a sky wing, but
when the talons lost their sky wing egg
before it hatched, Webbs had decided to
replace it with a rain wing.
It was his fault Glory had been forced to
grow up under the mountain, far from her
home and family, learning about a
prophecy that didn't even have a place
for her in it.
It was easy for the others.
There was no question about their
destiny.
But glory.
If she was meant to help save the world
then why hadn't the prophecy called for a
rain wing?
And if she wasn't necessary for this big
grand destiny, then what was the point of
her life at all?
Maybe it was all one big mistake?
But when she thought like that, she ended
up having violent dreams about ripping
webs apart.
So, better not to think about it.
Destiny would have to sort itself out.
Right now, she was going home.
The branch above glory suddenly dipped
and dumped a lake's worth of water onto
her head, she leaped back with a hiss and
glared up into the tree.
Shh, tsunami said from above.
She dropped down to the ground and peered
around at the gloomy swamp.
There's a pair of mud wings headed this
way, but they'll never see us in this
weather.
Rolls of thick gray fog hung over the mud
wreathing the stunted trees like smoke
around a dragon's horns, it was hard to
tell what time of day it was.
The sky was gray in every direction. and
the rain drizzled down unrelentingly.
Glory agreed with tsunami.
A dragon could barely see her own
wingtips in this, let alone another
dragon.
We should still hide, Starflight said
anxiously.
We're only a day's flight from Queen
Warren's palace right now.
If we get caught, more prison, Clay said
with a sigh, every queen they'd met so
far seemed determined to keep the
dragonettes trapped under her claws.
They'd escaped Queen Scarlet's prison in
the Sky Kingdom only because of Glory's
venom, a secret weapon even she had known
about until she'd needed it.
She touched her forked tongue to her
fangs. and glanced at the sky.
They still had no idea if Queen Scarlet
had survived Glory's attack.
Given their luck, Glory was pretty sure
Scarlet was alive and planning some
horrible revenge.
After that escape, they'd gone looking
for safety with Tsunami's mother, Queen
Coral of the Sea Wings.
Of course, Coral had decided to lock them
up as well.
Glory hadn't been surprised.
Not even family could be trusted when it
came to the prophecy.
Everyone had their own plans for how this
war should end.
So if Queen Mohen of the Mudwings found
them in her territory, She probably
wasn't going to give them tea and send
them on their way.
The mudwing queen held court beside a
large lake on the southern edge of the
mud kingdom.
Glory remembered the map of Pyria, and a
shiver of realization ran down her
spine.
If Starflight was right, and they were
only a day's flight from there.
Then they must be only a day's flight
from the rainforest as well.
From the rainforest.
And Glory's tribe.
And then, I'll belong somewhere.
The rain wings won't care that I'm not in
some prophecy.
Glory, tsunami scolded.
Bright yellow scales are the one thing
they might see.
Go back to camouflage.
Glory glanced down and saw the star
bursts of gold that had appeared all
across her scales.
Those meant happiness or excitement, as
far as she knew, since she'd seen them
pretty rarely in her life, it drove her
crazy when her scales changed color
without her telling them to, they did
that way too often.
She had to squash every big emotion
before it splashed all over her.
She concentrated on the steady drip drip
of the swamp around them, staring down at
the thick brown mud oozing through her
claws.
She imagined the fog winding around her
wings, slipping into the cracks in her
scales and spreading like gray clouds
rolling across the sky.
And she's gone, Tsunami said.
She's still there?
Sonny piped up.
She edged closer to glory and bumped into
one of her wings.
See, right there.
She stretched out a talent, but glory
moved out of reach.
Sonny felt around in the air for a moment
and then gave up.
The little sand wing had been unusually
quiet for the last few days.
Glory guest Sonny hated the rain too.
The desert dragons were designed for
steering heat, blazing sun, and endless
clear sky days.
Even an odd looking sandwing like Sonny
still had the instincts of her tribe.
Really, Clay was the only one happy about
the weather.
Only a mud wing could appreciate the
squishing and squashing under their claws
as they traveled through the swamp.
Starflight swiveled his head suddenly.
I think I smell someone coming, he
whispered.
He shuddered from horns to claws.
Don't panic, tsunami whispered back.
Clay, you hide me in Sonny.
Starflight, find a shadow and do your
invisible petrified night wing thing.
Glory, you can shield webs.
No, thanks.
Glory said immediately.
She wasn't going anywhere near Webbs
certainly not to save his life.
I'll take Sonny.
She didn't like touching other dragons
but Sonny was better than webs.
But tsunami started, stamping her foot.
Glory ignored her.
She lifted one wing and tugged the little
gold dragon in close to her side.
When she lowered her wing again, Sonny
was hidden by Glory's gray brown
camouflage.
Yikes, Clay said.
That was so weird.
Like Sonny just got eaten by the fog.
His stomach grumbled woefully at the word
eaten, and the mud wing shuffled his big
feet in embarrassment.
Starflight peered at the spot where Sonny
had just been twisting his claws in the
mud.
She's fine, Glory said.
They'll follow orders like a good
dragonette, or tsunami might fling you to
the eels.
Tsunami frowned in her direction, but
Starflight slunk away and found a dark
tree hollow where his black scales melted
into the shadows.
Now Glory could hear it too.
The tramp squelch, tramp squelch, of
enormous claws, marching through the
swamp toward them.
The heat from Sunny's scales was
uncomfortably warm against her side.
Webbs hadn't moved while they talked.
He lay curled against the tree roots
snout resting on his tail, looking
miserable.
Clay shepherded tsunami up next to webs
and spread his mud colored wings to hide
them both.
It wasn't a perfect solution, a blue tail
stuck out on one side, the edge of blue
green wings on the other, but in this fog
they looked mostly like a blobby mound of
mud, which should be good enough.
Tramp squelch, tramp, squelch.
I don't like this patrol.
A deep voice grumbled.
Glory nearly jumped.
It sounded like it was coming from 2
trees away.
Too close to that creepy rainforest if
you ask me.
It's not really haunted, said a 2nd
voice.
You know, the only things that live there
are birds and lazy rain wings.
Years of learning self-control kept glory
from glinching.
She'd heard lazy rain wings thrown around
often enough by the guardians under the
mountain, but it felt like an extra stab
in the eye to hear it from a total
stranger.
If that were true, said the 1st voice
then her majesty would let us hunt in
there, but she knows it's not safe, and
you've heard the noises at night.
Are you telling me it's the rain wings
screaming like that?
Screaming.
Under Glory's wing, Sunny turned her head
a little, as if she were trying to hear
better.
Not to mention the dead bodies.
The 1st voice muttered.
That's not some kind of rainforest
monster, said the 2nd guard, but there
was a tilt in her tone that sounded
unsure.
That's the war.
Some kind of gorilla attacks to scare
us.
All the way down here.
Why would the sea wings or the ice wings
come all this way to kill one or 2 mud
wings here and there?
There are bigger battles going on
everywhere else.
Let's go a bit faster, said the 2nd voice
uneasily.
They should really let us patrol in
threes or 4s instead of in pairs.
Tell me about it.
Tramp, squelch, tramp, squelch.
So what do you think about the Sky Wing
situation?
Are you for Ruby, or do you think?
Glory strained her ears, but their voices
faded into the mist as the 2 mud winged
soldiers splashed away.
She badly wanted to know what the sky
wing situation was.
Maybe her friends wouldn't notice if she
slipped away for a moment.
Be right back, she whispered to Sonny
lifting her wing and stepping away.
Sonny caught her tail, wide eyed.
Don't go.
She whispered.
It's not safe.
You heard what they said.
About rainforest monsters?
Glory rolled her eyes.
Can't say I'm terribly worried about
that.
I won't go far.
She shook Sonny off and slipped after the
soldiers.
Carefully stepping only on the dry
patches so her claws wouldn't splash in
the mud.
It was weirdly quiet in the swamp
especially with the fog muffling most
sounds.
She tried to follow the distant rumble of
voices, and what she thought might be the
sound of marching mud wing talons.
But after a few moments, even those
became impossible to hear.
She stopped, listening.
The trees dripped.
Rain drizzled moodily through the
branches.
Small gurgles burbled out of the mud here
and there, as if the swamp were
hiccuping.
And then a scream tore through the air.
Glory's rough flared in fear, and pale
green stripes zigzagged through her
scales.
She fought back her terror, focusing her
colors back to gray and brown.
Glory!
Sonny yelled, behind her somewhere.
Shut up.
Glory thought furiously.
Don't draw attention.
Don't let anything know we're here.
The other dragonettes must have had the
same thought and stopped her, because
Sonny didn't call out again.
Unless it was one of them who screamed.
But it couldn't have been.
The scream had come from somewhere up
ahead.
Glory checked her scales again to make
sure she was well hidden and then sped up
hurrying through the trees toward the
screen.
The fog was so dense.
She nearly missed the 2 dark lumps that
looked like fallen logs, but her claws
came down on something that was decidedly
a dragon tail, and she leaped back.
Two brown dragons were sprawled in the
mud, surrounded by pools of blood that
were already being washed away by the
rain.
Their throats had been ripped out so
viciously that their heads were nearly
severed from their bodies.
Glory stared into the rolling gray fog.
But nothing moved out there, except the
rain.
The mud winged soldiers were dead, and
there was no sign of what had killed
them.
Chapter 2.
Remind me why we're walking toward the
place where the monster and the screaming
and the something that kills dragons, Clay
asked.
We could go somewhere else, Starflight
said.
Maybe to the ice wings?
Ice wings, yes.
Clay said.
That sounds like a great plan.
Let's do that.
No mysterious dragon killing things in
the ice kingdom, right?
What are those animals they have up
there?
Penguins?
I bet I could beat a penguin or 2 in
battle?
couldn't I?
How big are they?
Maybe just one penguin.
So we can freeze to death instead?
Glory said.
A rumor, and a couple of dead soldiers
were not going to scare her away from her
home when she was finally this close.
Fantastic plans, Starflight.
Not to mention that Ice Kingdom is half a
continent away, while the rainforest is
right here.
Besides, webs will never make it all the
way to the ice kingdom.
Sunny chimed in.
She glanced nervously up at the trees
which seemed to be getting taller and
taller as they walked.
It was also warmer the farther they went
and up in the vines overhead.
Glory could see flashes of color.
The bright summer yellows and purples and
blues might have been birds or flowers
but they were definitely not typical of
the brown, brown, brown, mud kingdom.
Glory wasn't sure, but she guessed the
dragonettes were in the rainforest for
real now.
The gnarled claw shapes of the marsh
trees were half a day behind them, and so
were the mud wing bodies.
Tsunami had wanted to stop and search the
area for clues.
But she'd been outvoted by the other
dragonettes when Starflight pointed out
that now they'd really be in trouble, if
they were caught right next to a double
murder.
Not to mention whatever had killed the
soldiers couldn't have gone far.
That was enough to get everyone, even
Webbs, to fly through the night.
And they'd circle down to walk again only
once the sun was up, and they were
looking for food.
See, Gloria said to Clay and Starflight.
Even Sonny is acting braver than you
scaredy scavengers.
Even sunny?
The Sandwing flared.
What's that supposed to mean?
I'm brave.
I'm brave all the time.
She lashed her tail and ducked away when
clay reached to patter on the head.
Warm bursts of sunlight, nudged through
the leafy canopy, making all their scales
glow.
Glory letter scales turn whatever color
they wanted.
A shimmery beetle green spread all over
her, touched here and there with curls of
amber.
She liked the feeling of matching the
trees and sunbeams.
We'll be there soon, she thought, with a
shiver of anticipation.
But I mustn't get my hopes up.
Maybe it won't be what I imagined.
It just has to be better than life under
the mountain, trapped in a cave by
guardians who hate me.
I'm not setting the bar too high here, I
think.
Something crackled off to their left, but
when Glory whipped around, all she saw
was a shaggy gray sloth, hanging from a
tree and blinking sleepily at her.
Have I mentioned this place makes me
nervous?
Clay asked.
Only about a 1000 times, Glory said.
I wish we knew what the mudwings were
talking about, Sunny said.
How can they live right next to the
rainforest and not know why it's
dangerous?
How can the rain wings live in the
rainforest if it's all that dangerous?
Glory countered.
Webbs sniffed faintly.
The 1st sound he'd made in a while, he
muttered, Because they're rain wings.
They probably haven't even noticed.
Glory glared at him.
Maybe you'd like a matching venomous
wound on your other side, she snarled.
Tsunami whirled and grabbed Webb's
snout.
The bigger Sea Wing snorted with surprise
and tried to jerk back, but she held him
firmly so she could glare into his face.
All right, enough.
What do you know about this?
She demanded.
You're the only one who's been to the
rainforest.
Does it have some kind of monster?
She shook his snout, none too gently.
Stop drooping like a wet fern and tell us
what you know.
Nothing, Webbs mumbled through tsunami's
grip.
Stand on his tail, Glory suggested, or
poke that scratch.
That'll get him talking.
Don't be horrible, Sonny said.
She nudged their guardian's shoulder with
her snout.
Webbs, please warn us if you know
something.
It's not safe for you either.
Webb's side, and tsunami let go of him.
I swear, I don't know anything about a
monster.
He said.
I didn't see anything dangerous when I
snuck in to steal Glory's egg.
Honestly, it was really easy.
It was the night before the brightest
night, so you could tell which eggs were
about to hatch, and I just took one and
flew back to the mountains.
I didn't even run into any rain wings, let
alone a monster.
My parents weren't guarding their nest.
Glory asked.
Webbs looked down at his talons and shook
his head.
That doesn't mean anything.
Glory thought.
But she remembered the mudwing village
and Clay's mother, who had sold one of
her eggs to the talons of peace for a
couple of cows.
She hadn't missed clay at all, and she
certainly didn't want him back.
Glory hoped her parents wouldn't be like
that.
Both Clay and tsunami had been
disappointed.
Maybe parent dragons were always
disappointing. especially when you'd
spent years dreaming about what they
might be like.
Well, Glory didn't particularly care
whether her parents were the most amazing
dragons in the world.
She just wanted to meet other rain wings
and show her friends that they weren't
all lazy fruit eaters, like the other
tribes thought.
With their camouflage scales and secret
venom, surely they had to be tougher and
stronger than anyone suspected.
Maybe it's a new monster, Clay
suggested.
Something that's come to the rainforest
since you were here 6 years ago.
Maybe, Webb said.
The talons never sent anyone down this
way.
I can't tell you much about this place
either.
Starflet said, wearing at one of his
claws.
There were almost no scrolls about the
rainforest or the dragons who live here.
Glory knew that.
She'd memorized every reference she could
find anywhere to the rain wings, and all
put together, they told her essentially
nothing.
There had been one scroll called Dangers
of the Rainforest, so she knew a fair
amount about quicksand, poisonous snakes
and deadly bugs, but even that one barely
mentioned the rain wings themselves, and
certainly nothing about creatures big
enough to massacre the mud winged
soldiers.
Something chattered loudly in the
branches overhead, and they all jumped.
It was just a monkey, Glory said fiercely
clamping down on her nerves, so her
scales wouldn't change color.
Or a, a toucan or something.
Can we eat toucans?
Clay asked hopefully.
Only if we can catch them.
Tsunami said.
She flexed her wings and glanced up the
branches and vines overhead.
Glory wasn't hungry anymore.
Now that the sun had finally come out.
Each touch of sunlight felt as if it
filled her up better than any cow.
With a twinge of guilt, she remembered
the Skywing Palace, and the sculptured
tree Queen Scarlet had set up to display
glory on, like a piece of treasure.
There had been so much sun there.
Nothing like she'd ever had in her whole
life under the mountain.
Queen Scarlet would roll glory into the
sunlight and let her change colors
however she wanted all day long.
She didn't try to talk to her.
She never touched her or yelled at her, or
insulted her, or compared her to anyone.
Scarlet's only wish had been for glory to
sleep and be beautiful.
But I didn't love it.
Glory told her self fiercely.
It was just new and different.
A new, different way to be a prisoner and
have my life chosen for me.
I more than a lump of treasure.
I guess Scarlet found that out the hard
way.
Caw, caw.
Tsunami leaped into battle pose, her
teeth bared, with Clay a step behind
her.
The others stopped as she glared around
looking for the source of the noise.
I'm telling you, Glory said.
It's only 2 cans.
There's nothing to be scared of.
You're just jumpy.
Now, why would we be jumpy?
Tsunami said.
Oh, right, the dead bodies.
At least I told you about them, Glory
said, her rough flaring.
You saw a dead body of someone we knew on
day one in the kingdom of the sea and
decided not to tell us.
Guys, Starflight said.
That was different.
That was Kestrel, tsunami cried.
I had to find a way to tell you
properly.
Super job you did there, Lori said.
Guys!
Starfight yelled.
They stopped and looked back at him.
He was turning in frantic circles, staring
out at the trees.
It took Lori a moment, but she realized
what he was looking for right before he
said, we're Sunny.
They all fell silent.
Sonny had vanished into thin air.
Chapter 3.
Sonny!
Clay bellowed at the top of his lungs.
She was mad.
Starflight fretted.
Maybe she ran off because she was mad at
us.
She was?
Clay asked.
Why was she mad?
Glory couldn't remember either.
Run off into a strange rainforest on her
own?
Tsunami said.
That's not like her.
Glory closed her eyes and ransacked her
brain.
Poisonous snakes, deadly swarms of ants.
What were the other dangers of the
rainforest?
Quicksand?
She opened her eyes and peered the ground
around them, but it was all plain dirt
tree debris, and tangled roots.
Nothing looked like quicksand.
Sunny.
Clay yelled again.
Tsunami growled.
We made it through the sky kingdom and
the kingdom of the sea without losing
anyone, and now we're 2 minutes into the
rainforest and one of us is gone.
She's not gone, Starflight said.
His voice vibrating with panic.
She can't be.
She has to be here somewhere.
I was looking at her only a few moments
ago.
Glory turned her gaze up to the trees.
Another gray sloth hung from a nearby
branch, yawning.
It looked like perhaps the least
threatening creature she'd ever seen.
She frowned at it.
Webbs, what do you think happened?
Tsunami demanded, following Glory's
gaze.
There was no response.
They all turned around.
Webbs was gone too.
No way, Clay said, flaring his wings.
He was just here.
I saw his face when we realized Sonny was
gone.
Maybe 10 seconds ago.
He couldn't have disappeared in 10
seconds.
But he did.
Starfly cried.
He did, and Sonny did, into thin air.
Ouch, tsunami said.
Clapping a talon to her neck.
Something just stung me.
Clay jumped and clawed at his neck as
well.
Starflight's eyes went wide, and then he
threw himself to the ground and rolled
under the nearest low hanging bush with
his wings over his head.
What in the world are you?
Glory started.
Ducking to look at him?
She heard a soft buzz as something
whizzed by her ear, followed by a tiny
thunk, as it hit the tree behind her.
She spun around, and saw Clay literally
disappear right in front of her.
It was as if the forest reached out leafy
arms, quietly wrapped him up, and bundled
him away.
One moment he was there, blinking dizzily
and then he was gone.
A heartbeat later, so was tsunami.
Aha.
Glory thought.
She planted herself next to Starfly's
hiding spot, and flared her rough.
She could sense the waves of pale orange
and dark red rippling across her scales
but she didn't try to hide them.
She didn't care if her audience knew she
was angry.
That's enough, she called.
Come out here right now.
There was a pause, and then the air
seemed to shimmer for a moment, and
suddenly a drag in the color of
raspberries stood in front of her
grinning.
Glory had never seen anyone else use
camouflage scales like hers.
It was startling, and unsettling, and
kind of the coolest thing she'd ever
seen.
Holy moons, she thought.
That is awesome.
We do that.
Rain wings, like me.
Another dragon, dark blue dappled with
gold appeared beside the first.
She was grinning too.
Wrestling overhead made glory look up.
Suddenly, the trees were full of
dragons.
Rain wings curled around the trunks or
hung from the branches by their tails.
Several of them were colors she'd never
even imagined.
She saw deep shades of violet, iridescent
peach, pale jade, and a yellow so
bright.
It was like being stabbed in the eyes
with the sun.
We are beautiful.
Aw, look, said the raspberry dragon.
She's happy to see us.
He beamed at her, and Glory realized that
small bubbles of rose pink were rising up
from her talons to her wings.
Poor little dragonette, murmured the dark
blue rain wing.
Why are her scales so dull?
Glory blinked.
Is she talking about me?
Shh, don't be rude, said the 1st rain
wing.
Hello, tiny one.
I'm John Boo, and this is Liana.
What's your name?
And why don't we know you already?
Glory.
And they easily terrified black one is
Starflight, she said.
She glanced behind her and saw Starflight
peering out from under the bush.
Where are my friends?
The dark blue dragon, Liana, tilted one
of her wings up at the trees.
Amid the dragons clustered overhead were
4 hanging nets woven of vines, sunny, webs
clay, and tsunami were inside.
They all had their eyes closed and hung
limply like sacks of fish.
Are they okay?
Starfly cried.
Sleeping darts, said the raspberry dragon
producing a tiny blowgun from a pouch
around his neck.
Let's just say we have some tree frogs
around here, you wouldn't want to lick.
Your friends will wake up fine in a few
hours.
It's easier to meet new dragons this way
said Liana.
We've had a couple of grumpy brown ones
stumble in here, and for some reason they
start biting us before we can even say
hello.
This way we get to chat first.
Well, they're still a bit groggy.
Plus, it's more fun, said John Boo.
Practicing dart shooting on ourselves
isn't the same.
They probably won't think it's so fun
Gloria said, especially the blue one.
She can be a little cranky, just to warn
you.
So, are we your prisoners now?
Starflight asked glumly.
The Dark Blue Dragon burst into gales of
laughter, and amused noise is swept
through all the dragons in the trees.
Rain wings don't take prisoners.
Funny little black dragon, Liana said
when she could speak again.
Whatever would we do with them?
Interrogate them for information?
Glory suggested.
Trade them for hostages or weaponry?
Contain them to minimize any threats.
The rain wings blinked at her, as if
she'd suddenly started speaking toucan.
Just a few ideas, she said with a shrug.
If we're not prisoners, Starflight said
then what are you going to do with us?
Well, said the raspberry dragon, glancing
up at the position of the sun over the
canopy.
Was anyone hungry?
And then the trees began to scream.
Chapter 4.
Starflight nearly leaped out of his
scales.
Glory felt her talons dig into the leafy
dirt as she tried not to bolt into the
jungle.
The screams faded, and she realized that
all the rain wings were staring at her
quizzically.
Are you all right?
John Boo asked.
Wow, that's a spooked color.
You weren't freak like that by us.
We clearly need to work on our
scariness.
I'm not spooked, Glory said.
Gritting her teeth and regaining control
of her scales.
I am, Starflight stammered.
What, what was that noise?
Oh, Liana said.
The screamer monkeys.
She pointed up, and Glory spotted a pair
of large brown monkeys lounging on a
branch overhead.
They started doing that a few years ago.
It startled us at 1st too.
John Boo said sympathetically.
They used to make these deeper grunty
noises, but now it's all shrieking and
gibbering like dragons being murdered.
You get used to it.
Do you?
Gloria asked.
On the one talon, that explained what the
mudwing patrols were hearing from the
rainforest.
On the other, it definitely did not
explain the dead soldiers, and on the 3rd
talon, why would monkeys suddenly start
making different noises than they had
before?
And on the 4th, why didn't the rain wings
think that was weird?
Come on back to our village.
John Boo said.
We could knock you out for the flight
there if you want.
You might be more comfortable.
There are a lot of branches in the way.
No, thank you, Starflight said.
Absolutely not, Glory said at the same
time.
Jambu shrugged.
All right, then follow us.
He leaped gracefully into the air and
spiraled up toward the treetops.
The rest of the dragons did the same.
It looked a bit like a rainbow exploding
and spattering color all over the trees.
Glory and Starflight followed them into
the canopy, high above the forest floor
where they were surrounded by sunlit
emerald green, and the whirring whisper
of tiny wings.
Birds darted and hopped all around them
as brightly colored as the rain wings.
Whenever glory paused for more than a
moment, purple and gold butterflies
landed on her talons or head.
Perhaps they thought she was a flower.
They stayed away from Starflight's darker
scales.
The rain wings moved through the treetops
with a weird grace, using their tails or
spreading their wings to glide between
the trees.
It looked more like swimming in the air
than flying.
Glory wasn't sure she'd ever get the hang
of it.
But it made sense, since straight flying
between the densely packed trees would be
difficult for creatures the size of
dragons.
Starflight kept smacking into vines as he
tried to keep up with them.
Glory wondered if he was wishing he'd
accepted the offer to be knocked out in a
net like the others.
She saw Sonny's net soar past them, handed
smoothly from talon to talon, from rain
wing to rain wing.
With a quick glance to make sure no one
was watching her, Glory tried wrapping
her tail around a branch and swinging in
a full circle, like the other rain wings
did.
Almost there, Jambu said, landing beside
her.
His weight on the branch threw off her
swing, and she ended up hanging upside
down by her tail for an awkward moment.
With a grin, he reached down and helped
haul her back upright.
Her back talons gripped the rough bark of
the branch.
It felt like ancient dragon scales under
her claws.
You really aren't from around here, he
said.
No, Glory said, a Starflight thudded down
clumsily on the branch as well.
My egg was stolen from the rain wings 6
years ago.
Well, I can take you out tree gliding
anytime you want to practice, he said.
I bet you'll figure it out pretty
quickly.
He spread his wings and leaped off
again.
Glory frowned at his departing pink
tail.
Yeah, that was weird, Starflight said
answering her unspoken thought. wasn't
it?
As if he didn't care at all, Glory said.
He didn't ask who stole me, or where I
was raised, or even act like he
remembered an egg getting stolen, as if
eggs just vanish all the time, no big
deal.
She scratched her rough thoughtfully.
Well, whatever.
Maybe they do.
Maybe there is a rainforest monster, and
the dragons are used to losing eggs to
it.
That is really, really not comforting.
Starflight said.
He wrapped his black wings closer to
himself, peering down at the forest floor
as if he expected something toothy to pop
up and try to grab him.
Comforting.
Glory couldn't think of any particularly
comforting explanations for John Boo's
lack of interest in her abduction.
Perhaps he's just a weird dragon, who
doesn't pay attention to dragonets or
eggs.
Surely the rest of my tribal care.
Come on, let's keep up, she said to
Starflight.
A few swings and glides later.
Suddenly all the rain wings around them
veered up, spiraling even higher into the
treetops.
Starflight made an anxious noise as the
nets whooshed by with their unconscious
friends in them.
And then the dragons started to land, and
glory began to see the home of the rain
wings.
Oh, she breathed.
She stopped to hover in the air so she
could look at everything.
The iridescent colors of the dragons
brought the hidden world forward.
Otherwise, the village was camouflaged as
well as any rain wing.
Wide vine walkways, shimmering with talon
sized orange orchids hung between leafy
platforms.
A few of the tree houses had low walls or
woven ceilings.
Others were open to the sky, and carpeted
with soft white flowers, like fallen
clouds.
Glory spotted a few of the sleepy gray
sloths, ambling or swinging between the
walkways.
She wondered if they weren't smart enough
to know they were surrounded by dragons
who could eat them at any moment.
This is the coolest place I've ever
seen.
Glory thought triumphantly.
And it's my place.
Visitors, Liana called.
She had one corner of Clay's net and her
claws, carefully she and the other rain
wings lowered him onto a platform wide
enough for 20 dragons.
Glory swept up to land beside him, and
watched her tribe gently set down her
other friends.
Dragon heads popped up all around the
village.
Glory realized that most of them were in
hanging contraptions like hammocks.
She studied the closest one.
It was strung between 2 trees, sturdily
woven of vines and lined with violet
feathers and blue petals.
The dragon inside was impossible to see
until he poked his head out.
His scales match the green and purple
around him perfectly.
Clever, Starflight said, tilting his head
at the hammock, he glanced to the ground
miles below them and shivered.
I certainly wouldn't want to sleep up
this high without something like that.
Look at that hammock design.
You can't fall out, and with rain wing
camouflage, enemies aren't likely to spot
you either.
Glory glanced down at her scales, and saw
a color rolling through them that she'd
never seen on herself before, a vibrant
blue purple she guessed meant pride.
She was proud of her tribe.
She'd barely met them, and already they
were as impressive as she'd hoped.
So their guardians.
She thought.
All those years of making me sleep on
uncomfortable rock ledges in the dark, and
who are the backward dragons exactly?
I know.
Isn't it pretty?
We quite like our village too, Leanna
said, practically in glory's ear.
Glory jumped back, flicking her tail.
All right, there was one thing that made
her uncomfortable.
The way the other rain wings looked at
her as if they expected to understand
every thought she had, just by reading
her scales.
She clamped down on her emotions, turning
our scales back to a treetop green that
matched the background.
Liana didn't seem ruffled by Glory's
reaction.
The rain wing scanned the leaves overhead
then smiled as 5 small dragons in shades
of sky blue and copper dropped through
the canopy toward them.
Hope you're hungry, Leanna said. as the
dragons opened their talons.
Strange shapes bounced and rolled across
the platform, bumping against Glory's
sleeping friends.
Glory picked up the one closest tour.
Lime green and star shaped.
It smelled like pineapple and basil.
She poked it with one claw, wondering if
she had to peel it.
Under the mountain, the dragonettes had
almost never eaten fruit.
She knew more from reading about it in
scrolls than from the few berries Webbs
had sometimes brought back.
Queen Scarlet was the one who'd given her
pineapple.
Don't think about Queen Scarlet.
Starflight scanned the platform with a
disappointed expression.
Is all of this fruit?
he asked.
Isn't there any meat?
Liana wrinkled her nose.
You can hunt if you want. she said, but
really, it's a waste of energy.
She glanced up at the sky again, and it's
almost our suntime, so if you must, then
do it quietly.
Suntime?
Glory asked.
Oh, sweetheart, Liana shook her head.
Is that what's wrong with you?
I was not aware that anything was wrong
with me, Glory said, firmly keeping her
scales from changing color.
Not from a rain wing point of view
anyway.
It's just your scales, Liana said.
They're so... mousey.
Glory stared at her.
Mousey?
You know, Liana said apologetically, a
little dull, not like ours.
She stretched out one wing, and let a
waterfall of rainbows ripple through it.
Is she saying I'm not as beautiful as
other rain wings?
Certainly, they were all very bright and
shiny.
Maybe her own skills weren't quite as
vibrant.
Glory wasn't sure what to think of that.
In fact, she was pretty sure she didn't
care.
She'd always been the pretty one, and it
had never gotten her anywhere, other than
chained to a decorative tree in the
Skywing Palace.
So tell me about suntime.
She said with a shrug.
A few streaks of orange and emerald
flashed through Liana's scales, and then
vanished into dark blue again.
Orange and emerald.
If their scales worked the same way, then
that meant Liana was feeling a little
surprised and a little irritated, as if
she'd hoped to prod more of a reaction
out of glory.
This scale reading business can go both
ways, my new friends.
Sometime, Liana said smoothly, as if her
scales hadn't changed at all.
It's the hours when the sun is highest, so
we climb up as close to it as we can and
sleep.
Oh, Starflight interjected in his
figuring things out voice, glory.
It's like those naps you always take
after lunch, I knew that must be a rain
wing thing, but I could never figure out
the point.
Why sleep in the middle of the day?
Don't you all have anything more
important to do?
Glory flicked her tail and narrowed her
eyes at him.
But Leana didn't seem offended.
The sun recharges our scales while we
sleep, she explained.
It makes us prettier, better at
camouflage, smarter, and happier.
What could be more important than that?
Oh, Starflight said again.
He studied glory like a scroll that
finally made sense.
Oh, happier?
Like, less grouchy?
Shut up, Glory said, giving him a shove.
She'd already put some of these pieces
together in her own mind.
She knew that what the guardians had done
keeping her trapped underground, away
from the sun her whole life, had probably
made her into a grumpier, less powerful
dragon than she could have been.
But she didn't need the others figuring
that out, because she didn't need their
pity.
And who knew what she would have been
like otherwise?
Being prickly was kind of an essential
part of being glory, if you asked her.
The truth was, in the Sky Kingdom, where
Queen Scarlet left her in the sun all day
glory had never felt happier or more at
peace, or less like herself.
She knew it was the effect of the sun and
nothing else.
She knew that what she'd experienced was
like finally getting to eat as much as
she needed after a lifetime of
starvation.
She knew that Queen Scarlet was evil, and
that glory was only another sparkly piece
of treasure to her.
Part of her had hated it, hated the weird
sleepiness, and the unmotivated
contentment that made her feel like a
puddle of slugs.
And yet, there was a part of her that
could have stayed that way forever.
She shook herself fiercely.
So go sleep, she said to Liana.
We're not going anywhere.
The other rain wings who'd carried the
nets, had already flown off to higher
platforms in the treetops, some were
sprawled out in open patches of sun, while
others were stretched inside the clever
hammocks, snoring.
True, said Liana, we'll wake up before
your friends do.
Don't you want to ask all your questions
first?
Starflight said to Glory.
Don't you want to find your family and
there's no rush, Lori said, cutting him
off.
They're asleep now anyway.
The answers will be the same in a few
hours.
She knew she was good at looking like she
didn't care.
She particularly wanted Liana to think
she didn't care.
It was lucky that questions couldn't
parade across her scales, like her
emotions, or she'd have been covered in
them, but she wasn't about to look
desperate in her 1st moments with her new
tribe.
They certainly didn't seem to have a
1000000 questions for her.
So fine.
She could act like this reunion was no
big deal to her either.
Maybe acting cool and unconcerned was a
natural rain wing thing.
Starflight scratched his head.
Can you at least ask about the monster?
Monster?
Liana laughed.
There's no such thing as monsters.
Really?
Starflight asked.
Then what's killing mudwing soldiers on
your borders?
Oh, Leanna said.
That monster.
Starflight's wings flared, and his eyes
went wide as the moon's.
Liana burst out laughing.
Your face.
She cried.
That was so worth it.
I'm just kidding little black dragon.
I don't know anything about any dead mud
wings, but I do know we don't have any
monsters here.
Just relax, Starflight.
Glory said.
Think about libraries or something.
Little Dragon!
Jambu called from a perch high above
glory's head, she squinted up at him
dazzled by the bright light reflecting
off his magenta scales.
Are you joining us for suntime?
Want a hammock?
he offered.
Or a platform?
Glory blinked at her friends.
Clay was snoring louder than all the rain
wings combined.
Tsunami frowned even in her sleep, her
claws twitching, as if she dreamed about
fighting.
Sonny was curled up in a peaceful ball
like a snoozing chinchilla, and Webbs
with his shallow breathing, looked and
sounded halfway dead.
If they weren't going to wake up soon
anyway.
Go ahead, Starflight said, it's okay.
I'll watch them.
He shook his wings and puffed out his
chest imposingly, which came across a bit
like a tree frog trying to look
menacing.
Wake me if you need to, Glory said.
If I hear someone shrieking like a tiny
scavenger, I'll assume it's you.
Starflight huffed an outrage as Glory
scooped up a couple of mysterious fruits
and flew to Jamboo's branch.
I'll take a platform.
She said, landing beside the pink rain
wing.
You sure?
He asked.
Usually dragonettes stick to the
hammocks.
In case they roll off in their sleep.
You'd wake up before hitting the ground
but you'd probably hit a few other things
first.
So, you know, we're not talking death or
anything, but some serious ouch.
I'll be fine, Glory said.
She'd never fallen off the ghastly rock
ledge where she'd been forced to sleep
for 6 years, and even in her Sky Kingdom
sun overdose almost coma, she'd always
stayed perfectly balanced on the marble
tree.
A calm sleeper, huh?
said Jambu.
Clear conscience, peaceful dreams.
Sure.
Glory said.
As if I would tell my dreams to a dragon
I just met, or my crimes, for that
matter.
Then you can join ours, he said.
Hopping from the branch to a platform
covered in overlapping leaves, laid out
to look like one gigantic leaf.
The other 2 dragons on it nodded sleepily
at her.
Glory turned in a circle and lay down
with her wings spread wide, to catch as
much sunshine as possible.
Warmth flooded through her, as if she
were rolling in molten gold.
This, she thought, as her eyes closed, and
all her muscles relaxed.
I could have slept in the sun like this
every day of my life.
Forget this stupid prophecy.
This is the destiny I was supposed to
have.
Chapter 5.
Glory woke up refreshed and relaxed.
But as she lay there with her eyes closed
she felt a wave of strange anger at
herself.
All right, sure.
I'm not in the great magnificent wondrous
dragonette prophecy.
Maybe no one would ever write a prophecy
about a rain wing.
Maybe no dragon Empire expects any of us
to have any important destiny or do
anything worthwhile.
But this, sleeping all day in a patch of
sun?
Is that all I'm good for?
All any rain wing is good for?
There must be more to us than this.
There must be more to me.
She wanted to kick herself.
Falling asleep almost the moment she
found her home.
This was exactly what she didn't want her
friends to think about her or her tribe.
She'd have to show them that there was a
good reason for rain wings to have
suntime.
It must make them smarter, and fiercer, or
something.
She shifted her wings, and froze.
Something was curled in the gap between
her shoulder and her wing.
Some part of it was also draped across
her neck.
It was warm, warmer than the sunbeams, and
it was breathing deeply and evenly.
She inched her head around, and peered
sideways at it.
There was a sloth, sleeping on her.
It had crept into the curve of her
shoulder, and fitted itself there
perfectly, slipping one arm over her neck
to pillow its head.
Long, silvery gray fur draped over her
green scales.
Its eyes were shut, and it had a peaceful
smile on its sleeping face.
What ridiculous creatures?
Fearless?
Or stupid.
Or maybe this is a diabolically clever
plan.
After all, she couldn't eat it now.
She couldn't possibly eat something that
smiled like that.
It reminded her a bit of Sonny, who
probably would also have no trouble
falling asleep on something big enough to
eat her.
She twisted her head up, moving as little
as possible so she wouldn't disturb the
sloth.
The other rain wings on her platform were
still asleep.
The sun had drifted down the sky, but she
guessed there were several hours yet
until nightfall.
A soft breeze tossed homeless leaves
across the canopy, and 2 fat blue frogs
on a nearby branch, were having a drowsy
rivety conversation.
The sloth chirruped.
It opened its enormous dark eyes, looked
into hers, and yawned a wide, oddly
elegant yawn.
I'm awake, Glory said.
So you should probably flee in terror
now?
Rumble, rumble.
The sloth said agreeably.
It snuggled closer to her scales and
yawned again.
I'm not like these other dragons.
I have things to do.
Glory told it.
You can't keep sleeping there.
Mmm, um, boom, boom.
The sloth concurred, closing its eyes.
The platform vibrated underneath her as
John Boo chuckled.
He rolled over and nodded at the sloth.
You've been chosen, he said.
That happened fast.
No, thank you.
Glory said.
I don't want to be chosen, especially by
a sloth.
She pushed herself up to sitting, but the
sloth somehow got both arms around her
neck and hung on, nestling against her
wing.
She likes you, Jambu said.
Now you have to pick a name for her.
The queen calls hers Shaggy.
First of all, what?
and no.
It is seriously undignified for a dragon
queen to have a sloth.
Also, this sloth is much too pretty for a
dopey name like Shaggy, Glory said, then
caught herself.
And I'm not naming her because I'm not
keeping her.
She'll wander away if I ignore her long
enough.
John Boo snorted with amusement.
Or maybe I'll eat her.
Glory said.
Why don't you eat them?
She shot a glance at the sloth, who
looked serenely unconcerned.
He shrugged.
Because they're cute, and too hairy.
They're all fur.
You'd have indigestion for days.
Glory reached up and poked the sloth with
her claw.
It did seem to be mostly fur.
The sloth wriggled, as if it was being
tickled.
I'm not playing with you, Glory said.
You have to go away.
I have important things to do, like
finding my parents.
Jambu tilted his head at her.
His raspberry pink scales had drifts of
light pink whorls in them.
Glory was pretty sure she'd never been
that color, and she had no idea if it
meant anything.
Sometimes pink popped into her scales
when she was happy, but Jambu was pink
from head to toe.
Nobody could be that happy.
Finding your parents?
he echoed.
How?
You tell me, Glory said.
I can tell you when I was stolen, and one
of those sea wings down there can tell
you from where.
Isn't that enough?
Jambu laughed, as if he genuinely thought
she was joking.
Then smothered his giggles when he
realized she wasn't.
What are you talking about?
Rain wings don't do parents.
Glory tried to ignore the twist of
disappointment in her stomach.
You knew that might happen.
Remember the mudwings?
Maybe the rain wings are the same.
Raised by their siblings instead.
So she started, why would you want to
find them anyway?
Jambu asked.
Glory stamped down her temper, so it
wouldn't show up in her scales.
Two reasons, she said.
One, I want to know where I came from and
what I've missed.
And two, I want my family to know I'm
right.
They must have worried a lot when my egg
went missing.
She studied him for reaction.
Jambu pulled on his snout and looked
confused.
But they wouldn't know, he said.
I guess you don't.
I mean.
He stopped and glanced around at the
sleeping dragons everywhere.
A few were up and moving through the
village already, but most were still
snoozing.
I'll just show you, he said, spreading
his wings.
Glory spread hers as well.
Time to get off, Sloth, she said, unless
you're prepared for some flying.
The sloth wrapped its arms more firmly
around her neck.
Do they understand us?
Glory asked.
Doubtful, John Boo said.
They're just reading our body language
and responding.
He shook off a winding vine and dove off
the platform.
Glory checked the sloth again.
She was pretty sure it was smiling at
her.
Maybe her sloth could understand her.
Maybe it was smarter than all the other
sloths in the rainforest.
She followed Jambu, gliding carefully
between the trees and hanging vines.
She tried not to care about the furry
creature clinging to her, but she found
herself lying more slowly than usual, and
avoiding things that might knock it off.
You ridiculous dragon.
It's only prey.
No matter how cute.
Wherever Jamboo was leading her.
It was some distance from the center of
the village.
They passed more platforms, covered with
sleeping dragons, and something like a
trampoline of enormous interwoven leaves
stretched between 4 trees, where a few
little dragonettes were bouncing and
flapping their wings furiously as they
learned to fly.
Everyone looked happy.
There were none of the horrible war
wounds and scars glory had seen in the
other kingdoms.
Nobody seemed tense or terrified.
Nobody was being forced to fight to the
death or punished for failing at guard
duty.
No fighting, no worrying about the war, no
starving, or bowing to an insane queen.
Well, as far as I know anyway.
Who needs a prophecy when they could have
a home like this?
Jambu angled down toward a structure
shaped like a gigantic green egg.
Holes all over the roof allowed sunlight
through the overlapping leaves, but the
bottom was reinforced with tightly woven
vines and branches, so it looked sturdier
than anything else glory had seen so
far.
She wondered for a moment if this was the
palace, but surely it wasn't big enough
for that.
She hadn't seen anything large or regal
enough to be the Rainwing Queen's palace
yet.
They landed on a branch next to one of
the window holes, and John Boo gestured
for her to look inside.
Pale eggs lined the entire floor, packed
closely together.
In the sunlight from above, shimmering
colors glowed under the thin shells as
the unhatched dragonettes wriggled and
squirmed.
Glory guessed that the eggs around the
outer edges were the closest to hatching
since she could see more movement inside
them.
A few even had tiny cracks along the top
already.
So, she said, so you have a hatchery.
All the queens do, I mean, sure, this is
a lot of eggs for one queen, but, Wait.
Are you saying this is the hatchery I was
stolen from?
Am I the daughter of a queen too?
Not that it made much difference to her
but it would be pretty funny to see the
look on tsunami's face if that was true.
I have no idea, Jambu said.
There are 3 hatcheries, so it could have
been any of them, but you're missing the
point.
These eggs aren't all from one queen or
any one dragon.
We keep all our eggs together like this.
Glory blinked at the array of smooth
white shapes in front of her.
So these are a 3rd of the eggs in the
village right now, all stuffed in
together.
Exactly, said Jambu.
They keep each other warm and hatch
whenever they need to.
We stop by every couple of days to check
for newly hatched dragonettes.
Otherwise, we don't have to worry about
our eggs.
They're all safe in here.
Except for mine, Glory pointed out, which
was stolen.
She paused, realization dawning.
It felt as though the wind had just been
sucked out from under her, and she was
falling with useless wings.
And nobody noticed.
She said slowly.
That's what you're telling me.
You had no idea my egg was missing at
all.
Jambu shrugged.
He didn't even look embarrassed.
Why would we?
he said.
As you can see, we have plenty of eggs.
New ones rolling every week.
So why go to the trouble of counting
them?
Because I wasn't just an egg rolling in
and out of your hatchery.
Glory said, flaring her rough.
There was a real live dragon in there, a
dragonette who had to grow up for 6 years
with no family, no rainforest, and no
sun.
The sloth said sympathetically, hugging
her neck.
Glory had forgotten it was there.
A cloudy blue gray began to march up
Jamboo's scales from his talons.
He made an almost comically sad face at
her.
No son?
he said.
Hey, I survived just fine.
Glory said.
She stepped away from Jambu's wing as he
reached for her.
This isn't a tragic pity me situation.
I'm just saying, maybe you should care a
little more about your eggs and the
dragons inside them.
When we do care, he said.
Dark green distress flickering in his
rough.
We take very good care of our
dragonettes.
We just don't worry about the edge
because we've never lost any before.
How do you know?
she cried.
If I was stolen so easily, you might have
lost others too.
He opened and closed his mouth a few
times, looking so stupid that she wanted
to punch him in his snout.
This went beyond parents who didn't love
their eggs.
Nobody had missed her.
She had no family wondering what had
happened to her.
Nobody had cared that she was gone.
Webbs must have known their rain wings
were like this.
That's why he came to the rainforest to
steal an egg.
That was what he hadn't wanted to admit
to her on the way here.
The rain wings weren't a secretly
wonderful, perfect tribe.
It was worse than she'd feared.
Her tribe was too lazy to even count
their own eggs.
Oh, now you're mad, John Boo said
woefully.
Glory couldn't stop the dark red streaks
appearing along her wings.
She scowled at him.
So how do you know which dragonette
belonged to which parents?
she asked.
We don't, he said.
We raised them all together, the whole
village.
Everybody helps.
I teach tree gliding.
He said proudly.
The blue grave of scales was already
fading back into pink again.
But then, Glory said slowly.
Doesn't that mean you don't even know who
you're related to?
Oh, I know what you're thinking, John Boo
said.
Don't worry, we have a way to tell.
Before 2 dragons decide to have eggs
together.
They do the venom test.
He pivoted in a circle and plucked a
floppy oval leaf from one of the trees
then laid it on the branch between them.
Watch.
He opened his mouth wide, nearly
unhinging his lower jaw, and spat a small
amount of black venom on the leaf.
Glory had imagined herself looking cool
and menacing when she shot her venom.
But the other rain wing mostly looked
creepy, like a mentally unbalanced
snake.
The leaf immediately began to sizzle and
melt.
Now you shoot your venom at it, he said
just a little.
Try to hit the same spot.
Glory hadn't exactly ever practiced
aiming her venom, or controlling how much
she shot out.
She bared her fangs of the leaf and ended
up nearly drenching it in black poison.
The branch below and around the leaf
started smoking and fizzing as well, but
strangely, where glory's venom hit
jamboos, those spots stopped melting
instantly.
Whoa, Jambu said.
He sprayed a little more of his venom
carefully on the rest of the leaf and the
branch where glories had splashed.
All of the smoking and sizzling stopped.
The leaf sat peacefully in a puddle of
what appeared to be harmless black goop.
Glory blinked at it.
Hmm, she said.
Unexpected.
John Booth whacked one of her wings with
his, radiating delight in every pink
scale.
Don't you see what just happened?
Your venom counteracted mine.
Isn't that awesome?
That's so awesome.
Is it?
Glory asked.
That means we're related.
Jambu cried.
You're my little sister.
Gloria flexed her claus and thought about
that.
She'd come to the rainforest looking for
some family after all, but it figured
that she'd find out Jambu was her brother
right after deciding he was the dizziest
most useless dragon she'd ever met.
And what good was a family who'd never
been there for you, who'd never known or
cared you were alive, and lost, and in
danger?
Oh, she said.
Wow.
Related.
She reached up and scratched the sloth's
chin.
It snuggled in closer to her with another
burbling sound.
That's how we know, Jambu said, waving a
talon at the half melted leaf.
If your venom made it melt faster, then
we'd know we're not related, so we could
have eggs together.
But when your venom cancels out the other
dragons, you come from the same family.
Can you believe her brother and sister?
Well, okay, we're probably only half
brother and sister, but still, it's
pretty cool.
You're definitely not my dad though, Glory
said, right?
Jumbo let out a shot of laughter.
I'm only 9 years old, he said.
I promise I haven't fathered any eggs yet
and I especially didn't have any when I
was three.
Well, that's a relief, Glory thought.
That must be how the tribe cures dragons
who've been hit by Venom too, right?
She said.
Find a family member to stop the spread
of the poison?
Her newfound brother looked horrified.
We don't use our venom on other dragons.
He said.
Bright green flaring across is rough.
Who would do that?
Um, no one, Glory said.
Maybe not in your perfect world, but talk
to me again when you're held prisoner by
a queen who's forcing your friends to
fight to the death.
I meant if someone hit someone else by
accident, that's not impossible, right?
Our Venom Trainers would never let that
happen.
Jambu protested.
He glanced down at the mess she'd made on
the branch.
I bet you could get a few sessions with
one of them if you want.
We only ever use it for this kind of test
and very rarely, for prey if we need it
or, you know, things that attack us
hypothetically.
Things that attack you?
Gloria asked, perking up her ears.
Like mysterious rainforest monsters?
She wondered.
We should get back to your friends, he
said.
They'll be waking up any minute, and we
can tell them our good news about being
related.
So awesome.
All right, she said.
I've seen enough here.
And I'm pretty sure I've gotten all the
answers about my family that I'm ever
going to get.
A long lost sister, Jambu yammered
curling his tail around the branch.
So cool.
I can teach you tree gliding and show you
all the different fruits in the
rainforest, and how to take care of your
sloth, and He swung around the branch and
glided off, still talking.
Glory took one more look at the village
hatchery and followed him.
She couldn't help but notice that he had
no questions for her.
He didn't care where she'd been or who'd
stolen her or why.
He didn't ask about the world beyond the
rainforest.
He had lots of ideas for what he could
show her, but didn't seem interested in
what she might be able to teach him.
She shook her head and navigated around a
mossy tree trunk.
Who cares anyway?
Even if it's all true, everything the
guardians said about rain wings, even if
they are all useless and don't care about
the right things, I'm still me.
And I am not going to be like them.
Not ever, no way.
Chapter 6.
Glory was not surprised to find tsunami
twitching violently in her sleep when she
and Jambu landed.
The sea wing would probably be ready to
fight someone the moment her eyes
opened.
What was surprising, though, was
discovering what Starfly got up to when
he was bored.
Hey, glory, he called the moment he
spotted her.
Watch this.
The Nightwing rolled one of the larger
pieces of fruit, around light pinkish
melon looking thing, in front of Clay's
nose, and jumped back.
Although he was still knocked out, Clay's
nose started twitching.
His snout trembled and sniffed, and
inched closer and closer to the melon.
His stomach growled loudly.
His tongue flicked in and out.
Starflight took the melon away again, and
Clay stopped moving with a long, tragic
sigh.
Isn't that hilarious?
Starflight asked Glory.
She gave him an amused look.
I've always figured torturing our
sleeping friends would be funny.
He sat back and flung his tail over his
talons, frowning.
I didn't have anything else to do.
It's been unbearably quiet with everyone
sleeping.
His eyes flicked to Jambu.
Have you asked him about your, Yep, glory
interjected, dead end.
We're brother and sister, Jambu announced
gleefully.
Starflight tilted his head slowly to one
side. and gave Glory Ann, is he joking?
Look.
You don't seem... much alike.
He politely understated.
She shrugged, and the sloth on her back
said, squirrible.
Starflight's eyes nearly popped out of
his head.
Glory, he said, there's a sloth on you.
You've got sloth, a sloth.
It's sitting right on your neck.
I know.
Glory said.
Apparently they're like pets to the rain
wings.
This one likes me, even though I've
explained to it that I'm pretty
disagreeable.
Oh.
Fascinating, Starflight said.
His talons twitched as if he were dying
for a scroll to check or somewhere to
write notes.
If I remember right, pets don't tend to
do well in dragon communities.
They usually get eaten by forgetful
relatives, or sometimes by the owner
herself.
Scavengers, on the other talent
apparently keep all kinds of odd prey
animals as pets, like cows and goats and
fish.
That's according to a longitudinal study
of peculiar scavenger behavior, anyway.
Glory remembered that scroll, but she
hadn't taken it very seriously.
Some of the things scavengers supposedly
did were too absurd to be real.
We would never eat our pets, Jambu
interjected.
Why bother?
There's enough fruit in the rainforest to
be sure no rain wing will ever go hungry
and the sun gives us more than half the
energy we need to survive anyway.
So you really don't eat meat?
Starflight asked, given Gloria a sideways
glance, you're all vegetarians, vegetarian
dragons.
Jambu waved his front talons airily.
We're not strict about it.
We eat what we feel like eating.
Bananas are easier to catch and peel than
monkeys are.
That's all.
Lazy fruit eaters.
Glory thought, just like everyone says
they are.
But they also have tranquilizer blow guns
and a cleverly designed hidden village.
She reminded herself, It didn't help.
They didn't even notice my egg was gone.
Ouch, said a small voice behind them.
I think something.
Bit me.
What?
Where are we?
Starflight bounded over to Sonny's side.
Are you all right?
he asked, helping her stand up.
The little sand wing blinked several
times and stared around at the rain wing
village.
How did we get here?
She shook out her wings and peeked over
the edge.
Oh my gosh, that's a long way down.
Glory, you have a cute furry thing.
Can I hold it?
Please, please?
Why not?
Glory said, disentangling the sloth from
around her neck.
Just don't eat it.
She passed it over to Sonny, who cradled
it gently between her front talons.
The soft poked Sonny's snout in a curious
exploratory way, then climbed up it onto
her head and sat down with a yawn.
It's not afraid of dragons at all
Starflight mused.
Fascinating.
Webbs moaned.
He clutched his head with his eyes still
closed.
Everything hurts.
Sonny crawled over to him and checked his
wound, even from where she was, Glory
could tell that it looked worse.
The blackness was spreading, and the
scratch looked angrily twisted and raw.
Nothing's going to get me. tsunami yelled
leaping to her feet.
I'll fight off any poisonous bugs.
Where are we?
She wobbled on her talons and tipped over
with a thud.
Don't move too fast.
Jeambu suggested helpfully.
The tranquilizer takes a little while to
completely wear off.
Tranquilizer?
Tsunami shouted.
How dare you?
Tsunami, stop yelling, Glory said, or
I'll ask him to knock you out again.
I'd like to see him try.
Tsunami cried.
Please do, Glory said to Jambu.
Do you have any darts that last for, say
days?
We don't do multiple darts in one day.
Jambu explained, taking glory seriously
just to be safe.
Tsunami flared her wings and glowered
fiercely at Jambu and the other rain
wings, who were beginning to gather on
the platform around them.
Suddenly, Glory thought the bright
purples, deep oranges, turquoise blues
and lemon yellows, looked somehow too
shiny and too vivid now.
She'd guessed that they were showing off
for her friends, except she got the
feeling all rain wings woke up every day
and spent hours trying to look more
colorful than everyone else.
Clay?
Sunny said.
She nudged the slumbering mud wing.
Clay, wake up.
Are you all right?
Is he all right?
He should be fine. said Liana, swooping
up behind Jambu.
His dose wasn't any different than the
rest of yours.
I'm awake.
Clay muttered.
He buried his head under his talons.
I'm just waiting until glory and tsunami
stopped fighting.
I was dreaming about sheep, and buffalo
and bears.
They were all on the table in front of
me.
And I had to decide which to eat first.
Oh, and they all smelled like melons.
That part was kind of weird.
Sunny, tsunami cried, making the sand
wing jump.
Stay very still.
There's a sloth on your head.
If I hit it just right, we can share it
for dinner.
She stepped forward, flexing her talons.
There was a murmur of disapproval from
the watching rain wings.
Oh no, you don't, Lori said.
She brushed past tsunami and snatched the
sloth away from Sonny.
It cheerfully wrapped its arms around her
neck and reburied its nose in her ruff.
It's mine, Glory said to tsunami.
Yours?
Tsunami echoed.
Yours as in, you're saving it for a
midnight snack?
Mine as in don't touch, Glory answered
and don't make snide comments either.
Me?
Tsunami said.
You're telling me not to make snide
comments?
Clay?
Come on, Sonny said, tugging on his
ears.
Make them stop so somebody will help
webs.
Glory had more or less forgotten they'd
come to find a cure for the poisoned
sandwing scratch near Webb's tail.
She glanced around at the watching rain
wings.
Their eyes were wide as full moons, and
their scales glowed with pink and blue
bubbles of curiosity and enthrallment.
They looked as entertained by Glory's
spat with tsunami as the Skywings were by
actual Gladiator Arena battles.
Maybe they resolve all their arguments by
taking naps.
She thought grouchily.
Clay heaved himself upright and stretched
his muscles rippling.
A few of the younger rain wings went, ooh
and tried to change their scales to match
his, muddy brown with undertones of
glowing amber in the sunlight.
That's right.
Starflight said to Sonny.
We should focus on webs.
Of course you're right.
I'll take care of this.
He turned to Jambu and Liana.
We urgently request an audience with
Queen Dazzling.
The 2 rain wings wrinkled their snouts
thoughtfully.
Queen Dazzling?
Liana said.
You don't mean that.
I do, Starflight insisted.
It's of the utmost importance.
We must see her at once.
Dazzling, Jambu said to Liana, it's not
her month, is it?
I don't think so, Yana agreed.
I guess they could see her anyway.
We must, Starflight said firmly.
Take us to her at once.
Wait, Glory jumped in.
What do you mean not her month?
Well, Jambu said.
Wouldn't you rather see the current
queen?
If it's so important?
Starflight's pompous attitude fizzled out
like someone had dumped a pile of snow on
it.
But, he said, But the Nightwing guide to
the tribes said, I'm sure it said Queen
Dazzling.
It also said we have no natural weapons
Lori pointed out.
So perhaps it's not the most reliable
source, at least about rain wings.
Who's the current queen?
She asked Liana.
I'm pretty sure it's magnificent right
now, Liana said.
Unless she handed it over to grandeur a
bit early.
Oh no, Glory thought.
Don't say it.
You take turns, being queen.
Tsunami burst out.
Are you serious?
Only the ones who want to, Liana said.
Most of us find it way too much work, you
know?
Yeah, so boring.
Dragons bother you all day long.
Jambu agreed.
Makes me glad I can't be queen.
So who can, Gloria asked. anyone?
Or only the royal family.
Royal family.
Jambu echoed with great amusement.
Oh, right, Glory said.
Rain wings don't do families.
She informed her friends.
Sonny tilted her head, but luckily the
rain wings kept talking before she could
say anything sympathetic.
Pretty much any female in the tribe can
be queen if she wants to, said Liana.
Really?
Tsunami said curiously.
How about me?
Can I be queen?
I'm originally a princess, you know, and
I'm really good at telling dragons what
to do.
Liana and Jambu looked at her dubiously.
Tsunami shifted her sea blue wings, raised
her snout in a queenly way, and flashed
the royal glowing patterns in her
scales.
Well, Jambu said, I guess you could ask.
Absolutely not, Glory said.
Have a little tribe dignity for Moon's
sake.
You cannot have a sea wing as queen of
the rain wings.
Tsunami, quit that.
When you say it like that, it does sound
weird, Ayana agreed, scratching her ruff
with one talon.
Glory didn't want to know what tsunami
was thinking right then, something about
what a useless, ridiculous tribe this was
probably.
So fine.
Take us to Queen Magnificent, she said.
How far is the palace?
Most of the rain wings politely tried to
muffle their laughter.
We don't really do palaces, Liana said.
Come on, follow me.
Jambu and the other rain wings stayed
behind, waving, like a bowl full of
butterflies, as Glory settled the salt on
her shoulder again, and she and her
friends followed Liana up into the
treetops.
The tree house she led them to was not
much different from all the others
although it was a bit higher and closer
to the sun, with an open roof and 5 giant
open windows in the curved outside walls
a short hanging walkway, glowing with
fuchsia flowers shaped like dragon
tongues, led from the doorway to another
large platform.
Seven dragons were standing in a line on
the platform.
Most of them looked bored or sleepy
although one or 2 had angry red flickers
sparking through their scales.
Here you are, Liana said, landing and
nodding at the end of the line.
Magnificent we'll get to eventually.
She squinted up at the sky.
Probably before dark, depending on what
these others you hear to complain about.
We have to wait?
Tsunami barked.
In a line?
Shouldn't visitors to the rainforest
automatically go to the front?
The waiting rain wings all shimmered
green with displeasure, and shot tsunami
unfriendly looks.
We can wait, Glory said.
No big deal.
The sloth flopped out on her back, and
made a snoozy sound.
It's a big deal to Webbs, Sonny pointed
out.
Look how much pain he's in.
Webbs contrived to look even more
pathetic than he had a moment earlier.
He flopped down on the platform and
groaned softly.
Sorry, Liana said.
This is how we do it, to be fair.
Nobody gets to go ahead of anyone else.
Tsunami drew herself up as tall as she
could, and glared at her.
Didn't I mention that I'm the royal
daughter of the queen of the sea wings?
That sounds lovely for you, Liana said.
I am on a gathering patrol now, but I'll
come back to check on you all afterward.
She took a step back, made a cheeky
little bow to tsunami, and flew away.
Well, I never.
Tsunami sputtered.
Maybe we should tell them who we really
are.
Glory hissed at her.
We agree to stop doing that.
You don't think Queen Magnificent would
lock us up, do you?
said Sonny.
Doubtful.
Starflight agreed.
I bet these dragons haven't even heard of
our prophecy.
I'm not sure they'd particularly care.
True, said Glory.
They don't care about much.
Better safe than sorry, don't you think?
Clay said.
I vote we keep it quiet.
I mean, you never know how dragons will
react, right?
Sorry, tsunami.
No, you're right, she grumbled.
She stretched her wings and neck.
I just can't believe they knocked us out
and now they're making us wait around to
see the queen.
Yeah.
Glory said.
It would make so much more sense if
they'd chain you all up in a cave and
starve you and ignore you for a day or 2
and then throw you in prison after you
save one of their princesses.
Oh no, wait.
That's what your mom did.
At least there's food here, Clay said
over tsunamis sputtering.
He had scooped up a pile of the fruit
from the 1st platform and brought it with
him. looking pleased with himself.
He started arranging the choices in front
of him.
What do you think these are?
He poked a branch covered in what looked
like bright yellow sundrops.
The dragonette shared the fruit, even
webs perked up enough to eat, but glory
wasn't hungry.
She passed a small orange fruit up to the
sloth, but didn't eat anything herself.
Like Jambu had said, the sun had filled
her up more than any food ever had, which
was weird, and she didn't want to think
about it, or about what it meant that
she'd been kept away from something so
important for practically all her
Dragonette years.
Instead, she wandered toward the walkway
and back, trying to peek across to the
queen's tree house.
Through the windows, she could see
rainbow scales, bright blue and
shimmering yellow and emerald green.
She also spotted garlands of white
flowers, with petals like dragonfly
wings.
The rain wings seem to use flowers for
decoration, the way the other tribes used
jewels and precious stones.
Glory glanced at tsunami.
The sea wing was still wearing the
strands of pearls her mother had given
her in the kingdom of the sea.
She acted like she'd forgotten they were
there, but occasionally Glory saw her
running them through her claws.
But her mother was a little bit crazy and
a smidgen evil.
Glory thought to herself.
Wouldn't I rather have no mother than one
like Queen Coral?
Even if she did come with pearls?
What are you seeing the queen about?
She asked the 1st dragon in line.
He jumped, startled to be spoken to.
Oh, oh, he said slowly.
I'm just wondering if I can get my
assignment changed.
Like, right now I teach Dragonettes about
fruit gathering, but I really think I'd
be better at, like, advanced napping
techniques.
Glory only barely managed not to laugh
out loud.
He was clearly not joking, was advanced
napping techniques an actual subject.
She decided it would be rude to ask.
What about you?
she asked, turning to the next dragon in
line.
This one was tall and pale orange, and a
small gray blue dragonette sat in the
curl of her tail, frowning grumpily.
I'm bringing this dragonette in for
punishment, said the tall dragon.
He seems to think it's funny to stuff
berries up the noses of sleeping dragons
during suntime.
The little gray blue dragon huffed a
noise that was somewhere between amused
and outraged and made a gruesome vase of
glory.
She made one right back, and he gaped in
surprise.
I'll tell you why I'm here.
Snarled the 3rd dragon in line.
He was one of the 2 with the furious red
flickers along his ruff.
The other was at the back of the line.
Glory thought they might be the only
angry rain wings she'd seen so far.
Uh-oh, said the napping techniques dragon
with a sleepy smile.
Mangrove is complaining about something
again.
The tall orange dragon chuckled
appreciatively.
Complaining about something.
Mangrove yelped.
I'll say.
Something we should all be complaining
about.
My orchid isn't the only one who's
missing, you know.
Glory tilted her head.
Your orchid?
she asked.
Was this another weird rain wing thing
where it would turn out they were
bizarrely attached to their flowers?
My pardner, Mangrove growled.
Orchid.
She's been missing for 3 weeks.
I've asked the queen every day since then
to send out a search party.
Sometimes dragons need a break, said the
1st dragon with a shrug.
Maybe she's taking a really long nap
somewhere, agreed the tall orange
dragon.
Three weeks.
Mangrove hissed.
And other dragons are missing too?
Glory asked Mangrove.
At least 12 in the last year, including
Orchid, he said grimly.
A chill crawl down glory's spine.
So the mudwing soldiers weren't the only
ones encountering something malevolent in
the rainforest.
There was something out there. lurking
behind the colorful birds and exuberant
flowers and tall whispering trees
something that could take out 2 mud wings
at once, and also make 12 rain wings
disappear without a trace.
Chapter 7.
Next. boomed a voice from the Queen's
Treehouse.
The 1st dragon ambled across the bridge
yawning, and slid through the curtain of
silvery yellow flowers that hung in the
doorway.
Can I come in for your audience?
Glory asked Mangrove.
She wanted to know how Queen Magnificent
would handle the problem of missing rain
wings.
Why?
Mangrove asked suspiciously.
I'm not letting you have my turn.
I'll just listen, Lori promised.
Hmm, he said.
All right, I suppose.
She turned to the last rain wing in line
and took a guess.
Are you here about a missing dragon too?
A dragonette.
The rain wing answered.
The scarlet flickers in her ruff were
reflected in the dark burgundy of her
scales.
Everyone thinks I lost her while we were
venom training, but I know it wasn't my
fault.
She stamped her talons on the wood
platform and hissed the skeptical look on
the nearest dragon's face.
So what happened to her?
Glory asked.
The burgundy dragon flung her wings up.
I don't know.
Maybe she ran off.
She's a terrible student and a pain in
the tail.
I just want to be cleared so I can have
my assignment back.
Poor Bromeliad.
If you have no assignment, that means
last choice of suntime spots, and only
leftovers at feeding time.
The pale orange dragon explained to
Glory.
It's not a lot of fun.
You must also want to find her, Glory
said to Bermeliad.
Aren't you worried?
She'll show up eventually, said Brumeliad
flipping her burgundy tail back and
forth.
Assuming she's still alive.
Glory thought.
If you're both here about missing dragons
she said, wouldn't it make sense to see
the queen together?
Brameliad and mangrove blinked at each
other, considering.
Next, called the voice again.
The 1st dragon emerged and flew away, and
the orange dragon hauled her dragonette
across the bridge into the tree house.
There could be totally different
explanations.
Mangrove said.
I'm sure something terrible happened to
Orchid.
And I'm pretty sure Kingaju ran off
despite me, said Bromeliad.
Still, Glory said.
I mean, it makes no difference to me, but
maybe she'd listen to 2 dragons more than
she'd listen to one.
Promiliad glanced to the 3 dragons in the
line between her and Mangrove.
One was fast asleep, and the other 2
seemed to be half listening, half
watching butterflies.
Next.
Come on, Mangrove said, reaching back and
hauling Bromeliad up with him.
And you too, he said to Glory.
Wait here, Glory called to her friends.
Clay looked up with melons stuffed in
each cheek as she hurried over the
walkway after the rain wings.
Glory heard tsunami starting to protest
and then the voices of Starflight and
Sonny hushing her.
The hanging vines of yellow flowers
smelled like honey and vanilla.
They swished against Glory's snout as she
pushed through into the sunlit room
beyond.
To her surprise, there were no guards.
No soldiers protecting the queen, no
heralds announcing each arrival.
The only dragon in the room was Queen
Magnificent herself, curled on a sort of
nest, made from lacy scarlet flowers and
scraps of russet monkey fur.
The queen was as large as coral, but
personally, Glory thought she was a lot
more impressive.
Instead of gaudy ropes of pearls
magnificent wore only a few garlands of
the white dragonfly wing flowers, which
set off the iridescent brightness of her
shifting scales.
Settled under one of her wings, was a
silvery gray sloth, much like the one on
glory's back.
It made a welcoming yurp, noise, and
glorious sloth burbled in response.
The queen flicked the point of her tail
and leaned forward to sniff at glory.
Her green eyes were friendly, and a
little sleepy looking.
You're new, she said cheerfully.
Aren't you?
How exciting.
I like new things.
It's my turn.
Mangrove insisted.
This dragonette just wanted to watch.
All right, said Queen Magnificent, as if
she wasn't that curious anyway.
She turned to mangrove and Bromeliad, and
wrinkled her snout to look like she was
listening.
Go ahead.
You know why I'm here. said Mangrove.
Orchid is still missing.
It's been 3 weeks.
We have to go looking for her.
Orchid, said the queen.
Tapping her chin thoughtfully.
Of course, still missing.
Or kid.
I come to about this every day.
Mangrove said.
Remember, we were fruit gathering and she
disappeared.
Mm-hmm, said the queen.
What about you?
From Iliad shook out her wings.
My student, Kingaju, ran off during a
venom training session, and hasn't come
back.
I want the blame lifted from me so I can
go back to my regular life.
How long ago was this?
The queen asked.
About 18 days, said Bromeliad.
She's no one's favorite dragonette.
I might add.
All right then, said the queen.
You may start training again.
Thank you. said Bromeliad with a bow
backing toward the door.
Hang on, Glory said.
Not that it means anything to me, but
isn't anyone worried that 2 dragons
disappeared within a few days of each
other?
Did they?
Said the queen.
She curled her front talons around her
sloth and stroked its head.
They'll probably turn up.
Dragons usually do.
Not lately, Mangrove said.
We have 12 dragons missing from our
village right now, including Orchid and
Kinkachu.
12. murmured the queen.
Someone's been counting.
Who has that kind of energy?
She yawned and looked at her claws.
There was an awkward pause.
Familiad shuffled a few steps closer to
the door.
Mangrove coiled his tail tightly around
his talons and glared at the queen.
Um, Glory said, look, again, this is none
of my business, but maybe someone should
investigate.
Like, find out if they all disappeared
from the same general area, or if they
have anything in common, or if they left
any clues behind?
All right, the queen said genially.
Sounds tiring.
Who wants to do that?
Glory looked at mangrove, but he was
already pointing at her.
She should do it.
He said.
She seems like she has useful questions.
Splendid, said the Queen.
Let's do that.
Problem solved.
Next.
Wait, Gloria said.
I don't do stuff like this, and I'm kind
of busy with other things.
Well, I guess that depends.
Saving the world and stopping the war is
what the dragonettes and the prophecy are
supposed to do and I'm not actually in
the prophecy.
But I guess if I accept my regular rain
wing destiny, then there's absolutely
nothing I have to do.
Tag along on someone else's destiny, or
settle for a future as a snoozing
dingbat.
Fantastic choices you've left me with
talons of peace.
Mangrove and Bromeliad had already swept
out the door.
Glory started to follow them, and then
jumped back as tsunami burst in, followed
by the other dragonettes.
Clay and Starflight had their shoulders
under Webb's wings, and their guardian
was staggering, like his tail was about
to fall off.
Ooh, said the queen perking up.
You're all new.
What about?
Glory glanced out of the waiting platform
and saw that the other 3 dragons were
gone.
We convinced them that our situation was
an emergency.
Starflight said.
Well, Sonny did.
Sunny beamed.
Greetings, queen of the rain wings.
Starflight said grandly.
He swept his wings out and bowed low.
Ooh.
The queen said again.
We have come to you despite great peril
in a time of crisis, to throw ourselves
upon your merciful, we need your help
Tsunami said.
Magnificent wings drooped a little.
Oh dear, she said, do I have to do
something?
This is Webbs, Sonny said, tugging on his
talon to lead him forward.
She pointed to the venomous gash near his
tail, and Queen Magnificent made a
disapproving tisk noise.
That is very ugly.
The queen observed.
It sure is, said Glory.
Also, it's killing him.
Minor detail.
Your dragons know about poison, tsunami
said.
We need someone who can help us cure
him.
That doesn't look like something one of
us did, said the queen.
We never use our venom on other dragons.
All of the dragonette shot sideways looks
at glory.
She narrowed her eyes back at them.
I dare you to tell her what I've done to
save your stupid scales.
It's not rain wing venom, Starflight said
hastily.
He was scratched by a sand wings tail
barb.
Oh, said the queen.
I don't know anything about those.
She took a deep breath to yell.
Next.
But Sonny interrupted before she could.
Oh, please, you must have healers, she
pleaded.
Someone who could look at it?
Please?
We don't want him to die.
Well, some of us don't, Glory muttered.
Queen Magnificent tapped her claws on the
tree house floor.
Her sloth seized one of her talons and
tried to gnaw on it.
We do have healers, said the queen.
Rolling her sloth playfully onto its
back.
I guess you could talk to them.
There are about 12 tree lodges down from
here.
In the one with the red berries growing
on the balcony.
She pointed out one of the windows.
They might not be able to do anything, but
you may ask.
Thank you, Sunny said, backing toward the
door.
And don't forget to report back to me on
that investigation.
Magnificent said to Glory.
It'll be nice to have something to make
mangrove go away.
What's your name, anyhow?
Glory, she answered.
I was stolen from the rain wings by this
dragon 6 years ago, when I was still an
egg.
Glory pointed at Webbs.
Oh my, said the queen.
That is rude.
Well, I'm glad he finally brought you
back, dear.
He did nothing of the sort.
Glory flared.
I brought myself back.
He was going to let me die.
Glory?
Tsunami interrupted with a frown.
What are you doing?
I don't know.
Glory thought.
Maybe I just want someone to be punished
for everything I've been through.
And the fact that nobody here even
noticed I was gone.
She took a deep breath, and forced all
the dark, rolling red and billowing
orange out of her scales until she was a
calm white, like the blossoms around the
queen's neck.
Nothing, she said to tsunami.
Whatever.
I just figured Magnificent would want to
know what happened to me, but she doesn't
and who really cares anyway?
Glory bowed to the queen and stepped over
to the door.
You all go see the healers.
I'm going to start looking for the
missing dragons.
She pushed through the yellow flower
curtain.
Because someone should care when a dragon
disappears.
Chapter 8.
Halfway across the bridge, Glory heard
Clay's voice behind her.
Wait, he called.
His heavy talons thumped on the walkway
making it shake and jump underneath her.
What missing dragons?
Some big scary thing is prowling the
rainforest, Glory said, she resettled her
wings, or at least something is making
rain wings disappear, probably the same
something that killed those mud wings.
I'll figure out what.
No big deal.
I'll catch up with you all afterward.
We don't all have to escort webs
everywhere, Clay said with a smile.
I'll come with you, and we'll bring
Starfight too.
Maybe we can help.
Starflight, he called.
The night wing poked his nose out through
the hanging flowers.
Let tsunami and Sonny take webs.
You come with us.
Glory shrugged, but her wing tips turned
rose pink against her will.
At least there were a couple of dragons
who cared if she existed.
After all, the only reason she was still
alive was because Clay had been willing
to risk his life in the underground river
to save her.
The golden sunlight was slanting sideways
through the tall green trees.
As glory, clay, and starflight glided
between the branches, small whirlwinds of
orange and blue butterflies lifted off
and landed again behind them.
Funny faced little monkeys with long
tails chattered indignantly when the
dragons swooped by.
They found mangrove on a small platform
by himself, sorting fruit.
Glory landed lightly in the middle, while
clay perched on the edge, and tried to
keep his feet and tail from squashing any
of the berries.
Starflight found a nearby branch, and
studied the fruit as if he were trying to
match it with pictures from the scrolls
he'd memorized.
The red streaks in mangroves rough had
been replaced by whorls of dark purple.
He looked up and nodded brusquely at
glory.
You got me into this, Glory said, so I'm
starting with you.
Since you might be the only dragon who
even knows about all the missing rain
wings.
Who was the 1st to disappear?
Mangrove put down a banana and looked up
at the sky, thinking, It must have been
splendor, he said.
She'd just finished her turn as queen, and
passed it to dazzling.
Whoa, Clay said.
There's a queen missing?
Well, she wasn't queen that month.
Mangrove pointed out.
And when she didn't come back, they just
started skipping her turn.
If she wanted it, they figured she'd show
up for it.
Was anyone with her when she went
missing?
Gloria asked.
She felt the sloth circle and settle
around her neck again.
She kept forgetting it was there.
It felt like a warm, floppy necklace when
it wasn't moving.
Mangrove shook his head.
Not as far as I know.
I noticed she was gone only when her turn
came back around.
And she wasn't there.
But I can guess when she went missing
because her sloth found someone else to
live with right around then.
Glory tapped her claws on a platform, and
thought about the sea wing court, where
politics and intrigue and betrayal all
simmered below the surface.
Not to mention the sand wings, where 3
sisters were tearing apart the entire
dragon world in their fight for power.
Maybe one of the other queens took her
out, she suggested.
Maybe dazzling or someone wanted a longer
turn, or less competition.
Starflight nodded, as if he'd had the
same thought.
Mangrove's ears popped faintly yellow, and
then back to purple again.
Nothing like that changed, he said.
The turns are the same length, one month
each.
And there were only 6 dragons in the
tribe willing to be queen in any case.
Now five.
So none of them have to wait very long in
between.
Besides, nobody enjoys being queen.
Can I eat this?
Clay asked, poking a rubbery red sphere
near his claws.
If you must, said Mangrove.
Clay scooped it into his mouth and
started chewing with a startled
expression.
Who disappeared after splendor?
Gloria asked.
Two dragons who were out venom training
said Mangrove.
One of them was having trouble aiming his
venom properly, so the other took him
away from the village to practice, and
neither of them came back.
Kinkaju was working on her venom too, Lori
said.
Is there a particular spot where rain
wings go to do that?
Mangrove shook his head.
Wherever the Venom Trainers choose.
Clay mumbled around the fruit in his
jaws.
Yes, those fruits are, said mangrove.
It'll probably take you an hour to
swallow it, and then several days to pick
the bits out of your teeth.
Ah, Starflight said.
Let's take a few back for tsunami.
Glory hit our smile, trying to look
responsible and investigative.
What else can you tell me about the
missing dragons?
she asked Mangrove.
How many females?
How many dragonettes?
Stuff like that.
Mangrove counted on his claws.
Seven females, 5 males, 4 dragonettes
under the age of seven.
Kinkaju is 3, so she'd be the youngest
and Taper is the oldest.
He's around 110.
Do any of them have enemies in the
tribe?
Glory asked.
Anyone who'd wish them harm?
Mangrove drew himself up, and bolts of
orange flashed along the underside of his
wings.
Rain wings don't ever fight each other, he
said.
There's no such thing as enemies within
the tribe.
Haven't you noticed how peaceful and
harmonious everyone is?
Well, sure, Glory said.
Everyone but you.
You seem a little grumpy.
So apparently it's at least possible to
be a grumpy rain wing.
He stared at her for a moment with his
mouth open.
Whoops, Glory thought.
I hope I didn't just lose my best source
of information.
I mean, she added, there's nothing wrong
with that.
I'm pretty grumpy most of the time.
Most of the time. said Starflight.
Moom voomph.
Clay Mumble agreed.
Some things just deserve being grumpy at
Glory said, frowning at her friends.
Mangrove let out a bark of laughter.
All right.
You're right.
I guess I've been neglecting my sun time
since Orchid went missing, he said.
I used to be as cheerful as everyone else
but I'm worried about her.
He rubbed one talon over his roughened
ears.
Trust me, Orchid was perfection in every
scale.
No one could possibly want to hurt her.
That's what I was afraid of.
Glory thought.
If another rain wing wasn't behind the
abductions, then it had to be something
more mysterious, and more dangerous.
She couldn't help thinking of the dead
mud wing soldiers.
But what was dangerous, and strong enough
to kill dragons, and why didn't anyone
know it was out there?
She glanced at Starflight, but he looked
as puzzled as she was.
I don't really want to talk about this
anymore right now. said Mangrove, hunching
his shoulders.
Then do something else for us, Glory
said.
Take me to the last place you saw
Orchid.
Mangrove bowed his head, shoveled the
unsorted fruit into a lopsided pile, and
spread his wings.
Glory and the others followed him over
the edge, and rapidly down in giant loops
toward the rainforest floor.
It grew darker the farther down they
went.
With the sunlight caught in the treetops
far above their heads.
Glory watched the forest for signs they
could use to follow the trail back, a top
old banana tree here.
A spider web as large as one of her wings
there.
She caught glimpses of other creatures in
the undergrowth.
A large furry ant eater had its nose
buried in a hole, rummaging around.
A pair of long legged, lavender colored
birds paused in their stroll through the
forest to shoot suspicious looks at the
dragons whisking by.
Glory was surprised at how far they flew
from the village.
Isn't there a fruit to gather closer to
home?
She called.
Mangrove nodded, and twisted his head
around to glance back at her.
Or get and I like to search farther out
in case we find something new.
The rainforest is full of surprises.
We find a new kind of fruit at least once
a year.
He landed beside a giant fallen tree
overgrown with moss and vines.
The undergrowth around his talons erupted
as lizards and insects scurried busily
away.
Several bug eyed, sky blue frogs peeked
out from the branches of the fallen tree
flicking their tongues in and out, just
like dragons.
Don't eat any of those, Mangrove warned
clay, sing the mud wings gaze following
the frogs.
Zoom, zoom, voom.
Clay mumbled, pointing to his jaws, where
the red fruit appeared to be stuck.
Are they poisonous?
Starflight asked.
He poked the branches, but the frogs
stared at him like, oh yeah?
Bring it, you big lizard.
No, Mangrove said, but they will give you
the weirdest hallucinations about insects
for about a week.
Really not worth it.
So Orchid disappeared around here, Gloria
asked.
Do you know if Kinkaju was in this area
as well?
Mangrove shrugged.
Possibly.
Romeliad likes as much privacy as
possible for training her more difficult
pupils, so no one else will see her
yelling at them.
Glory turned slowly.
Studying the forest around them.
She could hear monkeys, and birds
chittering in the trees overhead.
Wings flapped.
Twigs snapped, and claws rustled in the
bushes.
The air smelled like mangoes and wet
leaves, as if there were a pond or
waterfall nearby.
And there was another scent too, a
horrible one underneath the others.
Starflight?
she said.
What do you smell?
She'd noticed that his nose seemed
stronger than the other dragonettes.
He'd been the 1st to smell fire when the
Sky Wings attacked the Sea Wing Summer
Palace?
Maybe it was a night wing skill.
The black dragon inhaled slowly. then
wrinkled its snout.
Something decaying. he said, like a dying
animal.
Mangrove blanched from horns to tail
turning a pale, sickly green.
Don't panic, Glory said quickly.
I'm sure it's not her.
It's not a dragon, right, Starflight?
I'm not sure, he said, lifting a snout
and sniffing again.
She stamped on his foot, and he jumped
with a yowl of pain.
What?
I can't tell.
We'll go find it, Glory said to Mangrove
you stay here.
The rain wing leaned against the fallen
tree with a stricken expression.
Couldn't you be a little reassuring?
Glory hissed at Starflight once they were
out of earshot.
Didn't you see his scales?
Since when do you care how other dragons
feel?
He asked.
I care better than you do.
She countered.
Maybe if you had actual nightwing powers
and could read minds, you'd notice what's
going on around you.
Womph.
Wom, wom, wom.
Clay ordered from behind them.
Starflight folded his wings close to his
body and glared at her.
Well, glory demanded.
Can you follow the smell or not?
He turned and stamped off through the
trees.
Moom, moom, moom.
Clay said to Glory sternly.
Ah, your lectures are even cuter when I
can't understand a word of them, she
teased.
He gave her shoulder a playful shove that
nearly sent her through the nearest
tree.
When they caught up to Starflight, the
night wing was standing next to a small
waterfall, as high as Clay's shoulder
that splashed into a tiny pond.
A stream no wider than a dragon tail
burbled at the top of the waterfall and
away from the pond at the bottom.
Thick brownish weeds choked the slimy
surface of the pond, and a dead fish
floated in the shallows.
The top of the waterfall was flanked by a
pair of tall, dark trees, as fat around
as the columns where sky wing prisoners
were kept.
Their trunks were so brown that they were
nearly black, and their branches began
far overhead, so they looked more like
black pillars than trees.
The closest one had a boulder leaning up
against it, that was twice the size of
Marosir.
On the same side of the waterfall, at the
base, halfway into the pond lay a furry
wheezing sloth.
Although it took glory a moment to figure
out what it was through the cloud of
flies around it.
The terrible smell was thick in the air.
Said Glory Sloth, leaning around her neck
to peer at the one on the ground.
Glory lifted her wing to block the
gruesome site from her new pet.
What's wrong with it?
Gloria asked.
She inched toward the gasping sloth, and
realized that it had a serious bite on
one leg.
The wound was black and crawling with
insects.
It looked even worse than Webb's injury.
I'm not entirely sure, said Starflight.
I mean, that bite shouldn't have been
enough to kill it.
But it's clearly dying.
Could it be Rainwing Venom?
Glory asked.
It looks about the size of a dragon
bite.
Her sloth started chirruping in a tragic
distressed way.
She slid it off her neck and held it to
her chest, facing away from the sloth on
the ground.
It was comforting to feel its silky fur
under her talons.
Maybe, Starflight said doubtfully, but it
looks like something slower acting to
me.
I guess it's been dying for several
days.
It does smell awful, Glory said.
Poor thing.
Clay crouched beside the sloth and lifted
its leg carefully in his talons
inspecting it as if he were hoping to
find a way to fix it.
The flies zipped angrily around his snout
with loud buzzes of outrage.
The dying sloth whimpered softly.
Glory stepped around them and ventured up
the slope to the pillar tree.
Something about the boulder looked weird
to her.
It leaned almost too casually against the
tree, as if it had been set there on
purpose.
She circled around to the other side and
stopped. staring.
There was a hole in the boulder.
More than a hole, a doorway.
Chapter 9.
Glory wasn't quite sure how she knew this
was not an ordinary hole in a rock.
It looked like a hole, dark, with smooth
stone edges, and just big enough for a
full grown dragon to pass through.
A moss curtain partly covered it in a way
that didn't look quite accidental
enough.
But looking into it, made her head spin
as if she were standing on the edge of a
cliff and high winds.
A faint sound whistled out of the hole
like a storm howling on the far side of
the world.
She could sense that this hole opened
into a tunnel, and that tunnel went
somewhere.
It was impossible She could walk all the
way around the boulder. and there was
nowhere for a tunnel to go, but she was
sure of it.
Starflight, she said, as calmly as she
could.
What do you think of this?
The night wing climbed up beside her
heard around the boulder, and jumped back
when he saw the hole.
A tremor shivered through his wings.
I think it's horrible, he said.
Can't you feel it?
There's something horribly wrong with
it.
Like someone ripped a hole where there
shouldn't be one.
Don't go near it.
I think I have to go into it, Glory
said.
You say that like you're not terrified
Starfight said.
But I can see your scales turning the
same pale green that mangroves just
were.
That means frightened, doesn't it?
Don't try to read my scales, Glory
snapped.
She deliberately turned herself as black
as he was.
It's not a coincidence that this hole is
here.
Close to where at least one dragon
disappeared.
Maybe Orchid went through.
Or maybe something came out and got her.
Um, exactly, Starflight said, and she was
never seen again.
I'm pretty sure you just made my point
for me.
I promised I'd figure this out, Gloria
insisted.
Not run and hide the moment we found a
clue.
Clay joined them, his wings drooping.
His jaws were finally free of the rubbery
red fruit.
There was nothing I could do for the
sloth.
He said.
It was too far gone.
Said Glorious Sloth mournfully.
Glory looked over Clay's shoulder at the
still, silvery gray figure flopped on the
ground.
Is it dead?
She whispered.
He nodded.
I didn't want to leave it in pain like
that.
But you're not going to eat it?
She tilted her head at him.
Seems a little heartless, you know?
he said.
And from the smell of it, it would
probably make you sick.
Starflight pointed out.
I wonder what bit it, and whether it has
any connection to this hole.
Clay noticed the hole for the 1st time
and flared his wings in surprise.
Creepy.
He yelped.
Why is it so creepy?
Glory wants to go in there, Starflight
said, rolling his eyes.
Clay stalked up to the hole, sniffed it
and nodded thoughtfully.
Yeah, we probably have to.
No, we don't?
Starfly cried.
He curled his wings in toward his body.
That's insane.
There could be anything lurking in
there.
Including the answer to what is attacking
the rain wings, Glory said.
I'm going in.
You 2 wait here.
Clay pounced on her tail and sat on it.
Ow!
Glory yelped, trying to wriggle free.
Get off, you giant lump.
We might be doing this, but we're doing
it sensibly.
Clay said, as in tomorrow morning.
When it's not almost dark, with backup
and a rope and a plan.
Tomorrow morning?
Glory shoved him as hard as she could, but
he didn't budge.
I want answers now.
Sounds like something tsunami would say
Starflight said, with a smug face that
meant he knew she wouldn't like that
comparison.
You are so asking to get bitten.
Glory growled.
She stared at the boulder for a moment
thinking.
Rushing in was the tsunami thing to do.
Glory could be sensible and patient
instead.
All right.
We can wait until morning, but I'm
staying right here to watch this hole.
I don't think it's going anywhere.
Starflight said patronizingly.
Yeah, but maybe I'll see something go
into it, Glory said, or come out.
Starflight backed away from the hole in a
hurry, his wings twitching nervously.
I'll stay with you, Clay said.
Starflight, bring the others back here in
the morning. along with the longest
strongest vines you can find.
And tell Mangrove will be here all night
so he can go home, Glory said.
Try to be a little sympathetic if you can
muster that.
Like, please point out that we haven't
found orchids dead body or anything.
All right.
Starflight said, taking several more
steps back.
Don't do anything stupid while I'm gone.
We'll try to contain ourselves said
Glory.
He flew off into the trees, and as the
shadows quickly swallowed him up, She
noticed how dark it was already
especially down at the bottom of the
forest.
There was probably still a bit of
sunshine up in the treetops, but night
was coming on fast.
She realized she was a bit relieved that
Clay had stopped her from going into the
hole.
She needed to be able to see in the dark
like tsunami, or breathe fire like the
others, if she wanted to explore with no
light.
You can get off my tail now, she said to
Clay.
Let's find a place to hide, he suggested
standing up.
Ooh, and maybe something to eat.
Are you hungry?
I'm hungry.
Shocking, Gloria said with a laugh.
You know there's still enough of that
fruit left stuck to your teeth to make a
whole other meal.
I know, Clay said ruefully.
He ran his tongue across the gummy red
bits stuck between his white teeth.
But I kind of wish I had a sheep or a cow
instead.
Sorry, Glory said.
You probably won't find any of those
here.
She spread her wings and leaped into the
low branches of a fat gray tree.
Vines covered in purple blossoms hung in
long loops all over the tree, and another
skinnier tree seemed to be growing up
around the fat one, winding its trunk
around and around it like a monkey's
tail.
They found a spot where the branches wove
together thickly enough that they could
both lie down without worrying about
falling off.
Through the vines, glory could watch the
hole in the boulder, although it too was
rapidly disappearing into the growing
shadows.
Clay curled up close to her, but not
touching her, which she appreciated.
She wondered if other rain wings
preferred not to be touched or if that
was a special thing of her own, picked up
from living with 3 guardians who hit her
almost as often as they looked at her.
Let's be fair, she thought to herself.
Webbs never hurt me himself.
He just let the other 2 do whatever they
wanted.
So whenever Kestrel or Dune felt
frustrated, whenever the war was going
badly, or someone screwed up in battle
training.
Or there wasn't enough dinner for
everyone.
Or they just remembered they had a rain
wing instead of the sky wing who was
supposed to be in the prophecy.
Glory was an easy target for an angry
claw swipe, or vicious tail thump.
Well, whatever, she thought.
I'm free now, and Kestrel and Dune are
both dead.
She reached up and stroked the sloth
curled around her neck.
It snuggled into a talon with a soft
warble.
How does it feel to be home?
Clay whispered after a while.
His shape was just a blacker outline in
the dark beside her.
Glory coiled her tail around the branch.
She'd been avoiding thinking about this
ever since visiting the hatchery.
I did exactly what I told myself not to.
Got my hopes up, so they could be smacked
down.
It doesn't really feel like I am home, she
said slowly.
The suntime was great, and I like all the
fruit, but the other dragons?
I don't know.
It's weird.
I thought they'd be more like me.
They're nothing like me at all.
Clay's wings rustled.
I thought the same thing, he said.
I thought the guardians and the scrolls
must be wrong about rain wings, because
you're never lazy or boring.
But I guess you're just different from
the others.
Maybe I'm not really, Glory said.
Maybe more suntime would make me as lazy
as they are.
She remembered the sky kingdom again, and
the warm, hypnotizing feeling of sleeping
in the sun all day long.
I doubt that, Clay said.
Not all rain wings are the same.
You'd be different no matter where you
grew up.
I wonder, Glory thought.
And even if I am, what good does that do
me?
Not different enough to be part of a
prophecy, she said.
I'm still not a sky wing.
We don't want a sky wing, Clay said
firmly.
Have you thought about what to do next?
Like, if we all go look for Blaze.
You don't want to stay here, do you?
With your tribe?
I have no idea.
Glory said suddenly.
Listen.
They both fell silent.
The rainforest was full of strange noises
at night.
Hidden birds hooted and squawked.
The branches shook and rustled, as if
animals made of wind were rushing through
them.
A chorus of burps and gurgles came from
the stream.
Which glory guessed was a gathering of
frogs.
Now there was something else.
Something stamping slowly on enormous
feet.
Stamp, slither.
The sloth had a stranglehold on Glory's
neck.
She could feel it shaking.
She was sure her own scales were turning
green with fear, and she had to force all
her energy into staying black.
The something made a sniffing, snorting
sound.
Slither, slither.
It was near the pond now.
It stopped moving for a long moment.
Glory wasn't sure whether she was
imagining the great hulking shape she
thought she could see, like shadows
within shadows.
Crunch, crunch, slurp.
Slurp, crunch.
Gulping and smacking sounds followed, and
then abruptly stopped again.
Stamp, slither, stamp, slither.
And as suddenly as it had arrived, the
creature vanished again.
Glory strained her ears, but she couldn't
hear any footsteps retreating into the
forest or the crackling of branches
underfoot.
Whatever it was, had disappeared very
close by.
As if it had gone back into its hole.
Neither she nor Clay said anything for a
long time.
She wasn't sure enough that the
slithering thing was gone to risk making
any noise.
She held as still as she could, even when
her legs started to cramp.
After what seemed like hours, she heard
soft snoring coming from Clay's perch.
She adjusted her wings and tried to sleep
too.
But every noise made her heart thump
fiercely, and all she could do was swim
in and out of a drowsy haze for the rest
of the night.
It was a relief when the sun finally
started to drift down through the leaves
again.
She sat up, rubbed her tired eyes, and
glanced toward the pond in the boulder.
The dead sloth was gone.
All that remained were a few tufts of
gray fur and some blood spattered leaves
soaking into the wet, wet ground.
Chapter 10.
By the time the other dragonettes arrived
Glory had wiped out any trace of green
fear from her scales.
She waited by the boulder, her wings
speckled gray like the stone, as they
swooped down to join her.
Sunny jumped up to hug Clay's neck as
soon as she saw him.
Hal's webs, Clay asked.
Tsunami snorted.
I don't think these healers have seen
anything worse than a sprained wing or a
stubbed claw before, she said.
They're doing a lot of peering at the
scratch and muttering.
But I'm sure he'll be fine, Sonny said.
The rain wings are trying their best.
She turned and caught tsunami rolling her
eyes behind her back.
Sonny frowned.
They are.
Sonny, you think everyone's always trying
their best.
Tsunami pointed out.
Little Sandwing huffed a small snort of
flame.
So, everyone is.
Why wouldn't they be?
Yes, dear, tsunami said, not unkindly.
Hello, a voice interrupted.
A pink comet streaked through the trees
and thudded down beside the dragonettes.
Glory jumped back and flared her rough at
Jambu as he bowed to all of them
grinning.
What are you doing here?
she asked.
I heard what you were up to.
And it sounded like fun, he said
brightly.
So I took the day off to see if I could
help.
Brother and sister working as a team.
Awesome, right?
He craned his neck to see the hole in the
boulder behind her.
Oh, freaky thing.
No wonder it feels so weird in this part
of the forest.
Most of the rain wings avoid coming
anywhere near this pond, but no one's
ever reported a mystery hole before.
I don't think.
So what's the plan?
The plan is I go in.
Glory said, and everyone else waits
here.
Well, nobody liked that plan.
Tsunami wanted to go first.
Clay wanted to go together.
Starflight was still in favor of not
going in at all.
Even Jambu started whining about not
wanting to be left behind.
Glory folded her tail over her talons and
waited for them to shut up.
Sonny sidled up to her.
Maybe we could compromise.
Sonny suggested quietly, Maybe you could
take someone with you.
Someone with fire, maybe?
Who could help you with a darkness in
there?
Unfortunately, that was a good point.
Glory didn't love the idea of blundering
into total darkness alone, and if she was
right, and it was a tunnel, there was no
way to know how long it was, or how lost
she could get.
Like maybe Sonny started to say.
All right, Glory shouted, silencing the
others.
All right, fine.
Different plan.
Clay and I go in 1st and see what's in
there.
Sonny looked disappointed.
Glory wasn't sure why.
She was doing exactly what the Sandwang
had suggested.
What about me?
Tsunami said, bristling.
You hold the other end of the vines, Clay
said.
If we yank on them 3 times.
It means we're in trouble.
So either pull us out, or if you can't
come in and get us.
Glory didn't love the idea of having a
vine tied around your shoulders, but she
was outvoted.
As Starflight tightened the knots, she
untangled her sloth and passed it to
Sonny.
Here, she said.
Watch silver for me while I'm gone?
Aw, Sonny said, brightening.
Pretty name.
Glory hadn't meant to say it out loud.
She didn't want the others to notice that
she was starting to like the weird little
mammal.
Well, you can call it whatever you want
she said.
The soft disagreed.
But it flopped across Sonny's back with a
blissful expression.
It must like the sand wing warmth of her
scales.
Glory realized.
What if it doesn't want to come back to
me?
She shook out her wings.
Then it'll be Sonny's problem, I guess.
Let's go catch a monster, she said to
Clay.
Remember, 3 togs.
Clay said to tsunami.
He squared his shoulders and marched up
to the boulder alongside Glory.
She knew he must be remembering the awful
noises and dark creature from the night
before too.
She was glad he'd followed her lead of
not telling the others about it.
Starflight didn't need another reason to
try to stop her from going into the
hole.
Let me go in first.
Clay whispered, so I can light the way.
Glory nodded reluctantly, and he stepped
forward into the darkness.
She followed right away, nearly stepping
on his tail.
He breathed out a plume of flame, and
they saw a stone tunnel stretching ahead
of them, then turning abruptly to the
right.
That's impossible, Clay whispered.
This tunnel is much longer than the
boulder, and it's not going down into the
ground.
Some kind of magic.
Glory guessed.
Maybe animus magic.
Glory couldn't think of anything else
that could have made a tunnel like this.
Unless there were mystery creatures with
powers similar to animus dragons.
When she was 4 years old, she'd gone
through a phase of reading all the animus
dragon stories and hoping she was one, so
that she could enchant Dune's dinner to
eat him.
Of course, no powers had ever manifested
and it was probably lucky they hadn't.
Given what they'd learned about that kind
of magic from tsunami's sister anemone in
the kingdom of the sea.
On the one talon, the ability to
manipulate and enchant any physical
object, Glory thought.
On the other, say goodbye to your soul.
She squeezed past clay and set off down
the tunnel.
He stayed close enough to brush her wings
with his snout.
I thought the scroll said, there hasn't
been an animus dragon in generations, Clay
said, scratching his head.
But between Queen Coral's daughters, and
this being here?
I guess I remembered wrong.
No, that is what the scrolls said.
Remember?
That was in the histories written by
Nightwings, Glory said.
Nightwings can't stand animus dragons
because animus power is much cooler than
what they can do.
And Nightwings would rather be the only
magically powerful dragons out there.
So maybe they lied.
Or they didn't know that it runs in the
sea wing royal family, Clay said.
Or perhaps any dragons who do have animus
power.
Make sure to keep it hidden, so they
won't be forced to use it, like, for the
war or something.
He breathed out another spurt of fire, and
they saw the turn a few steps ahead of
them.
This tunnel might not be an animus thing
either, Glory said.
Maybe there's some other kind of creature
who can do this type of magic.
Clay didn't answer, but she felt the
shiver that ran through his wings.
At the turn.
Glory leaned forward to glance around the
corner.
Even before Clay could use his fire.
She saw light.
Enough light to realize, the tunnel
turned again to the left, and that was
where the light was coming from.
They crept to the next corner and peered
around it.
Another long tunnel stretched ahead of
them, and at the end of it waited an
outline of bright sunlight, much too
bright for the floor of the rainforest.
Clay and glory exchanged glances.
Did we miss something?
she whispered.
I thought this tunnel would be much
longer.
Also that it would have, you know, a
monster in it.
It must have come from out there, Clay
said, nodding at the circle of sunshine.
They slid along the tunnel. keeping an
eye out for hidden entrances, but as far
as glory could tell, there were none.
There were only the long, smooth stone
walls leading to that brightness, which
got more and more blinding the closer
they came.
She paused the doorway. blinking, and
realized that sand was piled up outside
as high as her shoulders, nearly blocking
the exit.
She dug into it, shoving sand aside until
there was a hole big enough to crawl
through, then poked her head out.
The sun beat down on her scales, but not
in the same way that it did in the
rainforest treetops or in the claws of
the clouds mountains.
Here the heat was dry as ancient bones
sucking all the moisture out of her
scales, and there was no breeze that she
could feel.
Grains of sand trickled between her
talons.
As her eyes adjusted, she realized that
the sand stretched, endless and pale to
the horizon ahead of her.
There were no trees.
The sky was aggressively blue and
cloudless.
A sickly stench of death hung faintly in
the air.
There was nothing but desert as far as
the eye could see.
Clay squished himself up beside her, and
stuck his nose out into the blazing
heat.
Yowch, he said.
Glory's ears twitched.
Out in the sky, a pair of tiny dark
shapes appeared, approaching fast.
Hide.
Glory ordered, shoving clay back into the
tunnel. throwing off the vine rope.
She wriggled out of the hole.
She stretched her talons across the sand
and focused on her scales, watching them
blur quickly into the pale brown gold
white colors.
Camouflaged.
She stared up at the approaching
dragons.
There were 2 sand wings. swooping lower
as they got closer.
For an uneasy moment, Glory thought they
must have seen her, but they whooshed
past without even glancing down, and she
realized they were aiming at something
beyond and behind her. moving
cautiously.
Lori crept out another few steps and
turned around.
On this side, the hole was hidden in a
dune, surrounded by a semicircle of dull
green cacti.
Each cactus was half as tall as a full
grown dragon, with tiny thorns as sharp
as fangs.
A few dusty white flowers bloomed between
the prickles.
Beyond the cactus sentries, the dunes
slanted down to an enormous structure in
the distance, the 2 sandwings spiraled
into it, vanishing behind the thick
sandstone walls.
There were no windows that glory could
see.
There was only the solid block shape, like
a monstrous brick dropped on the sand.
Wait, she thought.
There was something dotting the top of
the walls.
Small dark shapes at regular intervals
fluttering now and then in the very
slight breaths of wind.
She squinted, trying to process what she
could see.
It looked like, but it couldn't be.
She closed her eyes abruptly and clutched
her stomach.
It was.
She remembered the scroll now where she'd
read a description of this place.
The dark shapes were dragon heads.
The heads of dragons who had been
executed, and mounted where everyone
could see them, to remind others of the
dangers of disobedience.
According to the scroll, you could smell
them from miles in all directions.
Glory knew where she was now.
She was standing in a kingdom of sand
within sight of Burns stronghold.
Chapter 11.
Burns stronghold had once been the
original Sandwing Palace.
That was where all the trouble had
started.
Glory flattened herself against the sand
and stared at it, remembering the history
webs had taught them. 18 years ago, Queen
Oasis had rolled the sand wings from
here.
Her 3 daughters, burn, blister, and blaze
had been minor dragons, footnotes in the
scrolls of the time.
Oasis was old, fierce, and canny, with a
vast and impressive treasury.
No one expected her to be challenged for
many years yet.
And certainly no one would ever have
expected a puny treasure hunting
scavenger to kill her, but that was
exactly what had happened.
Now the treasure was gone, and the 3
sisters had drawn all the other tribes
into their struggle for power. 18 years
of bloodshed.
Glory flicked her tail, concentrating on
keeping her scales the color of the
sand.
Byrne had driven out the other 2 and kept
the palace for herself.
Or depending on which scrolls you read
blister and blaze had escaped before she
could kill either of them.
They'd gone in search of allies, knowing
that neither one could beat Bern on her
own.
This wasn't how the palace had looked
during the reign of Queen Oasis.
Byrne had added the thick walls, and, of
course, the dragon heads on top of them.
Glory wondered if Burne was down there in
her stronghold right now.
Or was she in the Sky Kingdom, trying to
hold on to her alliance after what glory
had done to Queen Scarlet.
The real questions were, did she know
about this passageway?
And did she have anything to do with the
missing rain wings?
Glory!
Clay hissed from the dark hole in the
dune.
What's going on?
Gloria slid back down the hill to face
him.
We're in the kingdom of sand, she said.
I have no idea how or why.
What's that over there?
Clay asked, pointing north.
Glory turned and saw a wing of dragons
flying high up in the sky.
Their scales sparkled in the sunlight, so
that even from here she could guess that
they were ice wings, white and pale blue
as diamonds.
From their angle of flight, they seem to
be returning from the Sky Kingdom to
their own home on the frozen peninsula to
the north.
Ice Wings, Glory said.
We're not too far from the ice kingdom
here.
That was hard to imagine in this
blistering heat, but she remembered it
from the map on the wall of their
underground cave.
Oh, Clay said brightly.
So we could go find Blaze.
Hooray, said Glory.
She knew the others were hoping that
Blaze would be a good candidate for Queen
so they could choose her instead of burn
or blister, but Glory's hopes weren't
very high, based on what she'd read about
Blaze.
Could Blaze or the ice wings have
anything to do with this passageway to
the rainforest?
But what had they heard in the middle of
the night?
And where had it gone?
All right, let's go tell the others, she
said.
But that is completely impossible
Starflight said, for the 1000000th time.
The kingdom of sand is literally half a
world away, on the other side of the
mountains for moon's sake.
You couldn't have walked there down a
tunnel in the rainforest.
Go look for yourself, Glory snapped.
It's for real.
Someone built a secret passage between
here and Sandwing territory.
She dipped her tail in the stream, glad
to be back in the coolness of the
rainforest.
Her scales felt as if she'd run through a
fire.
Silver sat on one of glory's talons
dipped her paw in the water, and patted
it against glory's leg.
But why?
Tsunami said.
What is the point?
That, glory couldn't answer.
So they could sneak through and eat a
sloth here or there?
That made no sense.
And what made even less sense was
kidnapping rain wings.
Do you think sand wings are coming
through here to attack the mud wings?
Sonny asked hesitantly.
Maybe it was a sandwing who killed those
soldiers.
Seems like a roundabout way of doing
things, tsunami said.
If the sand wings have an animus, they
could create a passage straight into mud
wing territory or something more useful.
I still think this passage has something
to do with the missing rain wings.
Lori said, but I don't understand what.
If they wandered into it by accident
they'd just come back, the way we did, if
they were taken, what would sand wings or
ice wings want with a few rain wings?
Burn likes collecting things, Starflight
remembered.
But you saw her face when Queen Scarlet
was showing me off in the sky kingdom
Glory said.
Burn looked like she'd never seen a rain
wing before, and she doesn't like pretty
things.
She likes horribly weird things.
You're all so lucky you didn't see the
creepy gift Queen Scarlet got for her
when she came to visit.
It was this dead stuffed crocodile with
bat wings sewn on its back, so it looked
sort of like a dragon.
She shuddered. totally hideous.
But Burne loved it.
And you don't know anything about this
passage, tsunami said to Jambu.
Glory's brother lifted his brightly
colored wings, looking baffled.
I know that rain wings didn't put it
there, he said.
Why would we want a way out of the
rainforest?
Life is perfect here?
Unless you make the mistake of going
missing, and then good luck because no
one's going to look for you.
Glory pointed out.
Well, maybe, John Boo said, as if that
were a perfectly normal problem for a
dragon tribe to have.
But it's great for the rest of us.
Glory wondered what color his scales
would turn if she bit him.
Do you even have an animus dragon?
Starflight asked.
What's that?
Jambu answered.
Never mind, Glory said.
Do Sandwings ever visit you?
Or have you ever seen one in the forest?
Jambu shook his head.
Don't think so.
I don't even know what a sand wing looks
like. he said.
Me, Sonny said.
Sort of.
But you've seen them in scrolls, right?
Starflight said.
Scrolls, John Boo said.
Um, those are Starflight looked as if
someone had just asked him whether
breathing was really necessary.
You don't have any scrolls?
He gasped.
Don't you read?
Do you really not read?
Not anything?
John Boo shrugged apologetically.
I'm not sure what you're talking about. he
said.
Starflight had to sit down and fold his
wings over his head for a minute.
Glory coiled her tail as Clay described
Sandwings for Jambu.
Every new thing she learned about rain
wings made them sound worse, a tribe
without scrolls, who didn't care what was
beyond their own borders.
Why weren't they at least curious about
the rest of the world?
It made her want to shake all of them.
Nope.
Doesn't sound familiar.
John Biz said.
I'm pretty sure the only other tribe
visitors we've ever had looked like him.
He pointed at Clay, and they're usually
lost and want to get out of the
rainforest as fast as possible.
Maybe we should destroy it, Sonny said
unexpectedly.
They all turned to look at her.
She shuffled her talons on the damp
forest floor.
The passageway, I mean.
It can't be here for anything good
right?
I know I don't like the idea that burn
could pop out of there any minute, and if
it's making rain wings disappear, Well
who cares why?
Let's just smash the boulder or stuff the
tunnel full of trees and set them on fire
or something.
Glory blinked.
It did sort of make sense.
There was definitely something not right
about this hole someone had ripped
through normal space.
Maybe destroying it would solve the
problem, but Glory wanted to know the
answer too.
There had to be a why.
Tsunami spoke first.
I don't think that'll work.
If there's someone or something behind
this, then wrecking their secret passage
won't stop them.
At least this way we have an advantage
because we know about it.
And what if the missing rain wings are
alive on the other side?
Clay said.
What if there's a chance to save them?
Oh, Sonny said.
That's true.
I'm not going into Burns Palace
Starflight said immediately.
No way.
A monkey in the trees overhead dropped a
nut, and Starflight jumped nervously
aside as it tumbled down beside him.
I will if I have to, Glory said.
She should have been the one to think
about saving the missing rain wings.
If they were still alive.
Of course, she had to help bring them
home.
Even if she did think the whole tribe was
empty headed.
But we don't know for sure that Burne is
involved.
Starflight pointed out.
It could certainly be the ice wings
instead.
We need to spend a lot more time
gathering information.
Maybe spying on the stronghold and on the
ice kingdom, charting their movements
studying the tunnel.
Suddenly something much larger than a nut
thudded out of the tree behind Starflight
the Nightwing yelped and leaped out of
the way, as a bright green dragon
galloped past him and dashed into the
hole in the boulder.
Hey, Glory shouted.
That was mangrove.
Jambu cried.
What is he doing?
He's going to look for orchid.
Glory tucked silver into the nearest
tree.
Wait here, she ordered the sloth.
She folded her wings and ran into the
tunnel after mangrove.
Mangrove.
She called, as his tail whisked around
the corner.
Come back.
We're making a plan.
Don't be freaking dragon.
She added under her breath.
Even the one rain wing she liked was a
nimrod.
She shot around the last corner just in
time to see him disappear out into the
bright desert sunshine.
By the time she burst out behind him and
her eyes adjusted to the light, he was a
green claw mark in the sky, flying away
as fast as he could.
A moment later, his scales shifted color
and he vanished against the blue.
Glory flapped her wings in frustration
and sat down with a sigh.
One by one, her friends emerged from the
tunnel.
Oh, 3 moons, tsunami said as the heat hit
her scales.
It's horrible here.
Sunny stretched her wings wide and tilted
her face up to the sun.
Wow.
She whispered.
Starflight blinked and gazed around.
You're right, he said to Glory.
I can't believe it.
This is really the kingdom of sand.
Jambu tumbled out behind them.
Where's Mangrove?
He asked.
Did he head for burned stronghold?
Starflight guest, shading his eyes to
look in the direction of the faraway
palace.
Glory shook her head and pointed north.
Nope, she said.
I don't think he even noticed it.
Looks like we're off to the ice kingdom.
Chapter 12.
This isn't safe at all.
Starfly called.
This is the opposite of safe.
We might as well just hand ourselves over
to Queen Glacier.
I'm right next to you, Glory said, and
grinned when Starflight lost to Beat and
had to flap harder to keep up.
Not only was it funny, but it was also
nice to know that her camouflage was
working so well.
Her brother certainly seemed to have no
problem.
She glanced around the endless empty blue
that surrounded them as they flew north.
Jambu?
she said.
Still here, answered a patch of sky from
off to her left.
You really don't have to come with us. she
said again.
The semicircle of cacti was now half a
day's flight behind them, but John Boo
could still make it back before dark.
Nah, he said, this is better than
suntime.
I feel like I've been rolled in sunlight
and stuffed with bananas.
I bet the rest of the tribe would love to
come through that tunnel and have their
sun time here on the sand.
Glory pictured a 100 rain wings suddenly
sprawled in the desert, snoring away, only
a few miles from Burns stronghold.
She shuddered.
That would be a really, really terrible
plan, she said.
It's not safe here for basically any
dragon.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Starflight yelped from her other side.
Even rain wings?
said Jambu cheerfully.
Nobody cares what we do.
The world is still at war, Glory said.
And some of the queens are really not to
be trusted.
I don't know what they do with you, but
it wouldn't be friendly.
Why not?
asked Jamboo.
Because you're so dopey, you're just
asking for it.
Because most dragons are naturally
unfriendly, she said, biting and fighting
is what we're built for.
Really?
said Jambu.
We're not.
There was a ripple in the air as he
flicked his tail.
Well, you should be, said Glory.
One day, some other tribe might come to
you, and you'll have to be able to defend
yourselves.
Promise me you'll be careful when we get
to the ice wings.
Don't let them know what you are.
All right, all right, he said.
Well, I think it's pretty cute.
My little sister getting all worried
about me over nothing.
Glory rolled her eyes.
Why did she care?
If her tribe wanted to do idiotic things
did it really affect her?
Well, it did if she planned to stay in
the rainforest.
But was that her plan?
The rain wings were far from the family
she'd hoped for.
But if she didn't stay with the rain
wings, where would she go?
With the other dragonettes, to fulfill a
prophecy she wasn't supposed to be in?
What about after the prophecy was
fulfilled?
Clay had brothers and sisters in the mud
wings.
Tsunami had loved the kingdom of the sea
apart from her crazy mother.
Maybe she'd still go back and challenge
her for the throne one day.
The night wings, of course, would welcome
Starflight with open wings anytime.
Glory glanced over at Sonny.
The little sandwing flew in a tired
flappy way, but her jaw was set and
determined.
Would she ever fit in somewhere?
She was such an odd looking sandwing
without the poison tipped tail all the
rest of her tribe had.
Would anyone want her?
If the dragonettes did fulfill the
prophecy and end the war?
Well, presumably, whichever queen they
chose for the sand wings would be pretty
grateful.
Surely she'd take Sonny in.
Besides, everyone liked Sonny.
Glory shook her head and stretched her
talons.
She was getting way ahead of herself.
First, we find mangrove and get him
home.
Then I find the missing rain wings and
whoever, or whatever is taking, or
killing them.
Then the great dragonettes of destiny
figure out how to stop the war, and maybe
I tag along for that.
And then we'll see what happens.
I wouldn't mind stopping for a nab
though.
Jamba's voice said, out of the blue.
We won't have time for that.
Glory said.
Then again, Mangrove was a rain wing.
So maybe he would stop mid idiotically
foolish rescue for a nap, but they
couldn't count on it.
Also, Jambu, it's not going to be like
this the whole way.
It's going to get really cold by tonight
and tomorrow we'll be in the Ice Kingdom
where it will be seriously freezing.
I'm sure it'll be fine, John Boo said
breezily.
It was already colder than it had been
back at the tunnel entrance, and the
desert sand below had changed to rocky
treeless hills, gradually sloping up as
they flew farther north.
Glory saw Sunny casting a wistful glance
back at the desert behind them.
Starflight was right.
This wasn't particularly safe.
Glory and Jambu were camouflaged, but
there wasn't much of a way to explain a
mud wing, a sea wing, a night wing, and a
sand wing all flying together, especially
right into ice wing territory.
They'd agreed to stop telling everyone
they were the dragonettes of the prophecy
but arriving like this, they might as
well be carrying, here we are, please
imprison us, banners.
Glory wished again that her friends had
just let her come on her own.
She was sure she could retrieve mangrove
by herself.
They were lucky to avoid any ice wing
patrols.
Sunny heard one coming, which gave them
time to hide down in the rocky landscape
and they landed sometime after dark on
ground that crunched ominously under
glory's claws.
Is this snow?
Clay asked, poking the dirt.
No.
Starflight said, in his know it all voice
it's just frozen dirt.
We're going to be really cold tonight.
They'd chosen a spot at the base of a
short cliff, which would help block the
wind, but glory could already feel the
cold seeping up from the ground through
her claws and underscales.
And we shouldn't use fire, tsunami said
bossily.
We can't risk being seen.
Dibs, I get to sleep next to Sunny. said
Clay.
He grinned at her, and she beamed back.
Her warm scales would be the only source
of heat they had.
Even glory would have to put up with
close contact if she wanted to get
through the night without freezing.
Glory knew Clay was joking.
He was more likely to use his own body as
a shield to keep the wind away from the
rest of them.
But she glanced over at Starflight and
caught the crustfallen look on his face.
Oh, Starfight.
Maybe you should actually do something
about that crush of yours.
He'd never admitted it out loud, but Lori
was pretty sure he'd been hopelessly in
love with Sonny his whole life.
She was also pretty sure Sonny had no
idea, and that she might never find out
at this rate.
Not my problem.
Glory reminded herself.
But as they huddled up to sleep, she
edged around so Starflight ended up
curled next to Sonny's wings, with Clay
behind both of them.
She coiled herself as tightly as she
could, and found a spot along Clay's
tail.
Jambu immediately lay down practically on
top of her.
Oof.
Glory whispered, a little more personal
space, please.
I don't know what that is, Jambu
whispered back, but I'm really freaking
cold, aren't you?
Glory sighed.
She was, and John Boo was warm.
And he was her brother.
She curled up for a 2nd night in a row of
uncomfortable sleep.
Glory woke up shortly before dawn.
The sun was a thin, pale line of light on
the horizon, and the dark purple sky
still glittered with stars.
She could see her breath in the air
trails of smoke, as if she could breathe
fire like the others.
She wriggled out from under Jambu, who
slept with his mouth open and his wings
flopped wide.
At least he wasn't pink today.
She found it a little easier to take him
seriously when he was the gray and brown
colors of the rocks below them.
She glanced down at her scales to make
sure they match the landscape as well.
She liked how there was even a subtle
sparkle to them, just like the frost that
covered the ground.
Tsunami shifted in her sleep, growling
softly.
Glory realized that Starflight was
already awake.
He blinked at her over Sunny's back
looking exhausted.
She flicked her tail and signaled that he
should go back to sleep.
Then she spread her wings and hopped up
to the top of the small cliff to see what
the land ahead looked like.
A lot like the land they'd left behind
and the land they were on, apparently.
Except, was that snow in the distance?
Glory gave her scales a moment to shift
and then she lifted into the sky.
They hadn't been able to see it in the
dark the night before, but there was
definitely snow on the taller hills ahead
of them, and more snow beyond that.
Lori shivered.
It would get colder from here, and it was
already close to unbearable.
This had to be tough on Sonny and Clay as
well.
Maybe the others could stay here while
she went on ahead.
In fact, maybe she should go ahead right
now, without them, so no one else would
be at risk.
Except she knew perfectly well that her
idiot friends would follow her and just
get in worse trouble without her there to
help.
If she wanted to go on without them, she'd
have to convince them to be smart, listen
to her, and stay behind.
There was something large up ahead in the
snow covered hills, some kind of
building.
It couldn't be Glacier's palace, though.
Glory knew that was far to the north, on
the coldest tip of the peninsula, where
no other dragons would ever want to go.
This building was almost too far south
for ice wings.
Glory flew a bit closer and saw smoke
rising from a few of its chimneys.
Smoke means fire, she thought, which
means not ice wings.
She circled in the air and studied it a
bit more.
It had to be blaze and her sand wings.
Glory had been wondering how they
survived in the ice kingdom.
Apparently the answer was, by not going
very far into it.
Suddenly, a movement below caught her
eye.
She froze, hovering in the air and hoping
her camouflage was perfect.
There was a dragon among the rocks, not
far from where her friends were sleeping
but not close enough to see them either.
He was stamping his feet, and slapping
his wings together, as if he was trying
to warm up.
Mangrove?
Glory thought, hopefully, gliding a bit
closer.
He wasn't camouflaged exactly, but he was
black, like a night wing.
Maybe he thought that would hide him well
enough.
And then the dragon below let out a small
plume of fire.
Heating the ground below him before
curling up on it.
So it wasn't a rain wing.
It was an actual night wing, on his own
in ice wing territory.
Well, that can't be good news.
Chapter 13.
Why was there a night wing here, of all
places.
Glory glided quietly away and landed
softly out of his sight.
Her curiosity was too strong to resist, so
she needed a disguise.
The only logical dragons that should be
wandering around here were ice wings, and
maybe some of their sand wing allies.
She closed her eyes and remember the ice
wing who had fought clay in the arena
Fjord.
The 1st dragon she'd killed with her
venom.
She'd had no choice.
He'd been moments away from killing
clay.
Plus, she'd had no idea what her venom
would do.
She'd just known instinctively that she
could do something, that she had to do
something.
That she had a weapon she'd never known
about.
Starflight thought that perhaps she
couldn't have used her venom under the
mountain anyway.
He said it might have been activated by
finally exposing her scales to full
sunlight, the way Clay's fireproof
abilities had come to full strength once
he'd encountered mud for the 1st time.
Glory could now but wonder how different
life might have been if she could have
threatened the guardians the way they
threatened her.
Focus, Fjord.
His pale blue scales, the color of sky
filled snow, his darker blue eyes.
She felt the changes shimmer across her
scales.
The hardest part was the extra horns Ice
Wings had around their heads.
She concentrated on making her rough look
like it was made of icicles, and hoped
that would do.
She also could make her claws ridged like
ice wing claws, and her tail wasn't as
whipped thin at the end as an ice wings
would be.
Maybe this is a bad idea.
Maybe there's no way I'll get away with
it.
But it was still pretty dark out, and she
really, really wanted to know what a
night wing was doing out here.
Well, she thought ruefully, if he figures
me out, I guess I'll just kill him.
Somehow, it didn't sound as funny as
she'd hoped.
She leaped into the air and flew back to
the spot where she'd seen this strange
dragon.
For a moment, she was afraid she'd lost
him, before she realized that he was
lying down.
His black scales half hidden in the long
shadows.
Confidence, she told herself.
It's all about attitude.
Hey, she barked, landing with a thump
beside him.
Who are you?
And what are you doing in our territory?
The Night Wing leaped up in surprise and
stared at her.
He was a lot younger and smaller than
Morrow Seer, wiry and graceful in his
movements, even when he was startled.
The silver scales sparkling under his
wings caught the morning light, like
trapped stars.
Great moons.
Where did you come from?
he asked.
He looked up at the sky with a puzzled
expression.
Where do you think?
she said.
And I am asking the questions here.
What are you doing in the ice kingdom?
Technically, this isn't the Ice Kingdom
yet, he said.
Oh, didn't you know that?
It isn't?
She thought.
The map she'd memorized didn't exactly
have borders drawn on it.
Not that those would have helped her out
here anyway.
You're close enough, she growled.
Explain yourself.
She wished she had a spear or something
she could poke at him.
It will be Ice Kingdom territory one day
said the Nightwing.
If Blaze wins the war, that is.
She's promised Queen Glacier all the land
you can see from here to the southern
horizon.
Basically, where the desert starts.
He pointed, but Glory stopped herself
from looking and kept her eyes on him.
The night wing smiled.
I suppose you know all that.
He said.
But it's interesting, isn't it?
That's a lot of land Blaze is willing to
hand over, but not exactly useful land to
either tribe.
So what would Queen Glacier want with
it?
Do you think there's treasure under these
rocks?
That would be my guess.
A diamond mine perhaps?
Maybe you know.
Maybe all the ice wings know, and are
wisely keeping it a secret from Blaze and
her sand wings.
He gave her a wry, clever look, as if
he'd just opened up her mind and spread
it out on the rocks for them to admire
together.
A horrible sinking feeling shot through
glory.
She'd forgotten that Nightwings could
read minds.
Some Nightwings.
She reminded herself, certainly not
Starflight, and she thought not Marosier
judging from his lack of reaction to all
the thoughts she'd had about him.
Maybe this dragon was one who could see
the future instead.
Still, she forced every thought out of
her mind except, what are you doing
here?
Answer my questions, Nightwing, she said
or I'll take you to Queen Glacier, and
you can explain yourself to her.
That wouldn't be a good idea, he said.
You really don't want the rest of my
tribe to come looking for me.
And you really don't want to sit in a
dungeon made of ice until they show up
which would most likely be sometime after
you froze to death.
She pointed out.
So tell me what you're doing here, and
perhaps I'll let you go.
Win-win.
He tilted his head. looking amused.
All right, he said after a moment.
I'm waiting for someone.
Well, a view someone's.
Who?
She asked.
I can't tell you that, he said.
Nightwing business, I'm afraid.
I'm on an assignment.
I didn't know Nightwings had business
Glory said.
I thought you just sculked around in your
secret location.
Congratulating one another on knowing
everything and doing nothing.
The Nightwing started laughing.
Nobody talks to us like that, he said.
Where's your sense of awe?
Your terror of our powers?
He spread his wings majestically, but his
eyes were teasing.
If your powers were that impressive, you'd
do something to stop this war, she said.
Also, I'm the one with the, uh, the
freezing death breath here.
She nearly slipped and said venom, but
either way, it was true.
Nightwing powers weren't that spectacular
when it came to an actual battle.
Starflights were downright pathetic.
Maybe we'll help stop the war someday, he
said.
Maybe we haven't picked a side yet.
Like the dragonettes or the prophecy.
Glory kept her face calm and bored.
That old thing, she said.
I don't believe in prophecies.
Sorry, I know they're a Nightwing
specialty, but seriously?
If you can actually see the future.
Why be all cryptic and vague about it?
Why not give us a prophecy that's like, oh
by the way, Blaze is going to win the war
so give her the crown now and don't even
bother fighting about it.
Skip all the death and bloodshed, and
leave a bunch of poor dragonettes out of
it.
The Nightwing laughed again.
You feel sorry for the dragonettes, he
said.
That's interesting.
I've seen a lot of that around pyrea
actually.
Everyone expects so much of them, but
they also think it's a heavy burden for 5
young dragons.
I wonder if the dragonettes would be
surprised by all this sympathy for them.
He looked thoughtful for a moment, then
yawned.
You haven't seen any sign of them here
have you?
Rumor has it they were headed for the Ice
Kingdom next.
Really?
Glory said impassively.
Why?
To me, Blaze, I suppose, he said.
So, are they here?
In Queen Glacier's dungeon already
perhaps.
Nope, Glory said.
No sign of them.
None at all.
She thought of snowstorms and sheets of
ice.
Blocking the way to all her other
thoughts.
He studied her for a moment.
Right, he said.
Well, they couldn't have gotten here that
fast anyway.
It's a long way from the kingdom of the
sea.
How do you know they were there?
Glory asked.
Oh, wait, I forgot.
Nightwings are all knowing, all seeing
and all brilliant, right?
Don't forget all wonderful and all
handsome, he said.
She snorted to cover her laugh.
How would anyone know that, when you all
stay hidden away like turtles, she said.
Seriously, come hang out with dragons in
the real world sometime.
Is that an invitation?
He asked.
I probably have a day or 2 before the
before my work can begin.
I wouldn't mind seeing the inside of an
ice wing tavern if you'll be there.
Glory felt a shiver of danger slip along
her spine.
So let me get this straight, she said.
You're telling me nothing about why
you're here.
But you expect me to bring you into our
kingdom and buy you a drink?
Nightwings really do think highly of
themselves, don't they?
What if I bought you that drink?
he offered.
Oh, then I'm sure Queen Glacier would
understand.
No problem, Glory said.
She loves strange dragons in her
territory.
It's her very favorite thing.
The Nightwing smiled a little wistfully.
All right, he said.
Never mind.
But maybe you could come back and see me
sometime.
I'll be here for a few more days at least
probably, and it's pretty boring just
sitting here.
Waiting for your mysterious someone's
Glory said, which you're not going to
tell me anything more about.
He spread his wings.
Sorry.
I wish I could.
I bet my job would impress you.
I'm not easily impressed, Glory said, and
was surprised when he laughed again.
Well, good luck with your assignment, I
suppose.
What's your name?
He asked, as she took a step back.
Sorry, I can't tell you that.
She said mockingly, Ice wing business.
Who knew sarcasm could grow in a place
this cold?
He said with a smile.
Will you tell me your name, if I tell you
mine?
Nope, she said.
Frankly, I'm not that interested.
She turned her back and spread her
wings.
I'll tell you anyway. he said, as she
lifted into the sky.
If you'll come see me again.
Will you?
Maybe, she called back.
I'm pretty busy.
My name, he called.
She slowed down to listen, but didn't
look back.
My name is Death Bringer.
Chapter 14.
Death bringer.
Waiting for someone, a few someone's.
You haven't seen any sign of the
dragonettes, have you?
Gloria's head was spinning as she flew
away.
Was the Nightwing here waiting for them?
Death bringer.
Seriously?
The only dragon she knew of who the Night
Wings wanted dead was her.
As soon as Morrow Seer had laid eyes on
her, back under the mountain, he decided
she was going to mess up the prophecy, so
he'd ordered the guardians to kill her
which was why she and the others had
escaped.
Had he sent Deathbringer to finish the
job?
Why waste all that energy hunting her
down?
The Death Bringer had sounded as if he
was waiting for more than just her.
She wondered if that meant the other
dragonettes were in danger too.
Surely the Night Wings wouldn't kill off
any of them.
That had to mess up the prophecy much
more dramatically than glory could.
She landed next to her friends, and
nearly gave Starfly a heart attack.
Ice Wing!
he yelped, flailing over backward.
Tsunami leaped to her feet, teeth bared.
Look out.
It's...
Oh.
Starfly took a deep breath.
This glory's scales shifted back to brown
and gray.
Glory.
Why would you do that to me?
Because it's hilarious, she said.
And shh.
She thought they were far enough away
from Death Bringer, but she wasn't
completely sure how far sound would carry
in the cold, crisp air.
You looked very sparkly, Sonny said
sleepily.
I nearly clobbered you with my tail
tsunami said in a severe voice.
And I nearly bit your snout when you were
snoring last night, Glory said.
So I guess we're both models of self
restraint.
Jambu wake up.
She poked her brother, who was the only
one who'd slept through Starflight's
alarm.
Too cold, he mumbled, flopping one wing
over his head.
Too bad, she said, and poked him again.
Besides, if you get up and move you'll
feel warmer.
More sleeping, he insisted. folding the
other wing over his head as well.
Glory sighed and left him alone.
Starflight, she asked.
Do you have any idea how literal a
Nightwing's name is?
Like, does it always signals something
about what they do?
The other dragonettes started getting up
and stretching.
Starflight scratched his head.
Well, there's Moros here, he said.
He can see the future and deliver
prophecies.
So that's what seeing the morrow is
about.
Yes, thank you, Glory said.
I figured that one out.
But did they know he'd be a prophet when
they named him?
Sonny asked curiously.
Not all night wings are.
So how would they know that?
Maybe another prophet foresaw it?
Tsunami joked.
Starflight poked at the frozen ground
with one claw.
I don't know any more than that, he
said.
Maru seer hasn't told me any night wing
tribe secrets.
And you've read all the same scrolls I
have.
True, Glory said.
Lots of epic nonsense about wonderful
night wings.
They all have these awkward mouthful
names.
I think in the stories their names do
usually match their skills, if I remember
right.
Why are you asking?
Starflight tilted his head at her.
Because I just met one, Glory said.
And I think he's here to kill us.
Well, me, at least.
That got their attention in a hurry.
She told them about Death Bringer, and
everything he'd said, almost everything
anyhow.
She didn't want them to figure out that
she thought he was kind of cute.
That is, before she realized he was there
to kill her.
Let's get out of here, Starflight said
when she finished.
Let's fly south right now and get back to
the rainforest as fast as possible.
Jambu poked his nose out, hopefully.
I like that plan, he offered.
It does sound like the warmest plan.
But what about mangrove?
Clay asked with a shiver.
I saw something else.
Glory said.
I think it's where Blaze and her army
must be camping out.
She described the buildings she'd seen.
Starflight and tsunami both nodded.
Make sense to me, said tsunami.
Blaze would need a place of her own.
She couldn't survive a day in Glacier's
palace.
Right.
It's mostly built of ice, so she wouldn't
even be able to use her fire there.
Starflight mused.
So here's what I'm thinking.
Glory said.
I'm sure a mangrove saw this place too
hell head right for it.
Probably camouflage himself and sneak in
looking for orchid.
So I'll go after him and bring him back.
While you guys hide somewhere, Death
Bringer won't find you.
And then we all fly south as fast as
possible.
Wait.
By yourself?
Clay said.
Can't one of us go with you?
Who?
Glory said.
Who else can disguise herself as an ice
wing?
Her friends all looked at Jambu, who
blinked sleepily.
And be helpful.
Glory added.
I can be helpful, Jambu said with a
yawn.
I bet I'm better at spotting camouflaged
rain wings than you are.
Glory hesitated.
That actually did sound useful.
She wasn't really sure how she intended
to find a mangrove on her own.
You can do that, she said.
It's a game we play starting when we're
dragonettes.
Jambu said.
One dragonette camouflages herself, and
whoever sees her 1st wins.
So no guarantees, but it's probably more
practice than you've had.
She thought for a moment and shook her
head.
It's too dangerous.
I can take care of myself, and I don't
need any help.
Glory, Clay said, in a sort of amiably
threatening voice, you take him or we're
all coming with you.
Glory could tell by the looks on their
faces, that this was true.
Stupid heroic, we're a team idiots.
All right, fine.
We'll go in camouflaged.
But I want to make sure you can look like
an ice wing too.
Try matching what I'm doing.
She let her scales shimmer back into our
ice wing disguise.
Clay winced, and she guessed he'd
recognized which dragon she'd used as a
model.
Watching Fjor die in front of him
couldn't have been any easier for him
than for her.
Now make your scales a bit whiter.
Glory said to John Boo, so we're not
exactly the same, and shift around the
fake icicle horns.
She stepped back and studied him.
I think that'll do.
Can you remember that if we need to
become ice wings?
Sure, he said.
He held out his wings and looked at
them.
This is a pretty cool color.
I'll have to remember it once we're
home.
We also need ice wing names.
UB Penguin.
I'll be Storm.
That should be easy to remember.
I still think one of us should go with
you.
Tsunami interjected.
Mudwings and Seawings are the enemy
here.
Glory pointed out, and no events, guys
but it's not like Starfight or Sunny
would be much help.
No offense?
Sonny squeaked.
How am I not supposed to be offended by
that?
She lashed her tail and scowled.
We'll get in and out faster if we just
keep our scales hidden, Glory said.
Don't worry, we'll be back by tonight.
What if you find the missing rain wings
in there?
Clay asked.
Glory flicked her tail, letting her
scales shift back into the color of the
rocks, will free them, and come storming
out in a big, invisible herd.
All right?
Clay and tsunami nodded reluctantly.
Come on, Jambu, Glory said.
The rest of you stay hidden.
I mean it.
She sprang into the air with her brother
beside her, and let her scales adjust to
the sky around them.
As they beat their way north, she glanced
back once, and saw Sonny staring after
them, while tsunami waved her talons
bossily.
It's still cold, John Boo moaned.
Even with my wings beating.
I think it's even colder.
Well, we're up in the air, Glory pointed
out. and the wind probably isn't
helping.
But this will be over soon.
Don't worry.
She pointed to the building ahead of
them.
Just to warn you, there will be snow, but
hopefully the sand wings keep the inside
warm with their fires.
Snow, Jambu said.
And fire?
You know, I've never seen either of
those.
I've never seen snow up close either.
Glory admitted.
It looks fluffy. said Jambu.
It wasn't fluffy.
It was wet and piercingly freezing
against their talons as they landed
outside the walls.
John Boo let out a yelp of pain, and
glory nearly tackled him to shut him up.
Who's there?
called a voice from above.
They both froze.
There scales the color of the white
ground below them.
A sandwing head poked out a window.
Did you hear that?
he asked.
Another sandwing head wriggled out beside
his.
No, and I don't see anything.
You're imagining things again.
When Burns army shows up to crush us
growled the 1st dragon.
We'll see them coming from miles away
said the 2nd, and they'll be frozen and
weak from the cold, and we'll have ice
wing back up by the time they get here.
Stop interrupting our game.
The 2nd guard withdrew into the room.
The 1st glanced around suspiciously, his
gaze trailing across the snow where Glory
and John Boo crouched.
Finally, he huffed out a snort and
retreated back inside.
Gloria flipped her tail into her
brother's talons and led the way, slipping
around the thick stone walls until she
found a dragon sized door, locked, of
course.
She glanced up.
But she'd already seen from above that
there was no inner courtyard, or openings
anywhere on the roof, other than the
chimneys, which were too small.
The windows were all too narrow for a
dragon to squeeze through as well.
This was a proper fortress.
She wondered if it had been built early
in the war.
When Blaise 1st came to Queen Glacier for
protection and an alliance.
This was a pretty generous gift for
Glacier to give to her ally, a whole
fortress ride in ice wing territory.
Death bringer's words came back to her.
Blaise had promised Glacier all this land
if she won the war.
Glory thought of the other 2 sandwing
sisters.
She wondered what Byrne had promised the
sky wings and mud wings, and whether
blister had promised the sea wings
anything, or if she'd just manipulated
Queen Coral into supporting her.
I'm not seeing a way to sneak in here.
Glory whispered.
Do you have any ideas?
She felt Jambu shrug.
Sorry, he said.
I've never done anything like this.
They tried circling the walls one more
time, but there was only the one door.
Glory couldn't see any gaps in the
fortress's defenses anywhere.
Their only choice was to wait for that
door to open and hope they could slip
inside.
But who knew how long that would take?
The sun was finally drifting up the pale
blue sky, reflecting off the glittering
snow.
Glory did not want to stand out here all
day.
For one thing, Jambu would probably
freeze to death.
She didn't like the cold either, but he'd
never been out of a tropical environment
before.
Same goes for mangrove, she realized.
In fact, how would he have gotten inside
the fortress?
Maybe he wasn't there at all.
Maybe he was lying in a snowbank
somewhere, slowly disappearing into the
ice.
Glory shook her head.
Mangrove wasn't the type to give up if
she read him right.
And neither was she.
We'll have to go in as Ice Wings, she
said.
Just follow my lead.
John Boo's head appeared, nodding
agreeably, as his scales shifted color.
Glory let her scales change as well, then
turned in a circle to check herself as
best she could.
It wasn't a perfect disguise by any means
but hopefully these sand wings wouldn't
look too closely.
And between her camouflage scales and
venom, She felt like she had a pretty
good chance of escaping, even if they did
catch her.
She marched up to the door and rapped
smartly.
Try to look like a soldier?
She hissed to Jambu, who was slouching
and rubbing his neck behind her.
I don't know what that looks like, he
whispered back, just before the door
swung open.
A heavyset sandwing with broken claws on
one talon peered out at them.
Eh?
he muttered.
We have an important message for Queen
Blaze, Gloria announced.
Take us somewhere we can wait until she
returns.
Surely, like her sisters, Blaze would be
off leading a battle somewhere.
Once they were shown into a waiting room
they could change back to camouflage and
search the fortress for mangrove without
being seen.
Eh?
Until she returns.
The Sandwing looked at her as if she were
mad.
Blaze is here.
She's always here.
I can take you right to her.
Chapter 15.
Uh-oh, glory thought.
But it better be good news, said the
Sandwang. stomping around and heading
into the fortress.
She doesn't like hearing bad news, and we
don't like her hearing it either.
Queen Glacier needs to figure that out
and stop sending all these gloomy
reports.
Gloria and Jambu exchanged glances and
hurried after him.
The door thudded, shut behind them, and
another sand wing guard followed close on
their tails, slipping away was not going
to be easy.
Blaze's fortress was not much like the
glorious extravagant palaces of Queen
Scarlet, or Queen Coral.
The halls here were narrow, and nothing
was open to the sky.
A fireplace held a roaring fire in every
room they passed, so the heat was almost
stifling, and yet cold winds still
rattled through the small windows.
There was no treasure adorning the walls
no gold or pearls embedded in the floor.
Instead, the stone walls were hung with
thick, woven tapestries.
Each tapestry had a bright yellow sun
blazing at the center of it, surrounded
by patterns of images from the desert
sinuous lizards, prickly cacti, palm
trees, camels.
White and green and blue cover the dull
gray walls almost from corner to corner.
They miss their home, Glory realized, and
was shocked to find herself feeling sorry
for these sand wings.
They'd come here to support Blaze.
Probably they'd fled alongside her when
Bern tried to claim the throne, and now
they were trapped in this icy world that
was nothing like their own.
Kind of like growing up in a cave instead
of a rainforest.
Cool, Jambu said.
He pointed at a tapestry covered in
rioting green lizards.
That one's really wild.
I like it.
The sand wing soldiers stared at him.
Really?
said the one in the lead.
Our ice wing visitors usually make it
pretty clear that they think our hangings
are.
How do they put it?
garish and gaudy.
Well, they're not our style, Glory said
stamping on John Boo's foot, but we can
still appreciate the artistry.
Huh, said the 1st Sandwang.
Never heard that from an ice wing
before.
He turned and kept walking.
Glory shot Jambu aglare, and he wrinkled
his snout at her.
They reached the center of the fortress
or so glory guest, since there were no
windows here, and stopped in a small
antechamber outside a pair of giant
wooden doors.
One of the sand wings knocked twice and
they all waited.
As the silence stretched out, Glory
realized that there was something huddled
in a corner of the little room.
It looked like a dirty pile of prey fur
at first, but when she peered closer, She
realized there were 2 scavengers in
there.
They leaned against the wall with their
arms around each other, shivering.
What are those?
Jambu whispered to her, spotting them at
the same time.
You're one of those ice wings who's never
left the queen's palace, aren't you?
Guessed the 2nd soldier, overhearing
him.
I hear they rarely see scavengers that
far north.
He prodded the furs with one sharp claw
and the 2 scavengers let out tragic
little whimpers.
We found one of their hidden dens near
the mountains, and gathered up whatever
we could catch.
They're faster than they look.
We got only 6 of them, when there must
have been at least 20.
He shook his head.
These 2 are what's left?
You're going to eat them?
Jambu said.
Don't sound so shocked, Glory thought
lashing her tail, but she could
understand what he was feeling, with her
big eyes and strange arms wound around
each other.
The 2 scavengers looked like overgrown
less cute sloths.
She couldn't imagine eating them either.
The thought made her feel weirdly
queasy.
It didn't help that one of them was
staring at her in the same plaintive way
Silver did when she didn't want Glory to
leave her behind.
Of course, said the guard.
We wreck any scavenger dens we can find
and eat as many of them as we can
glaciers orders.
She thinks one day we'll find where they
bury our treasure.
If it still exists, who knows what
scavengers do with treasure, muttered the
other guard.
He knocked again, and this time the door
swung open under his talon.
The room on the other side was larger
than any they'd seen so far.
The smooth stone floor was covered in
sand, and the tapestries on the walls
here were more intricate, with images of
dragons and crowns and jewels surrounding
the yellow suns.
Giant wine red pillows and camel hair
carpets were piled in a loose nest in the
middle of the room, and sprawled across
this was a strikingly beautiful sand
wing.
She had her chin propped on one talon, and
was gazing listlessly into a mirror on
the sand in front of her.
Her tail coiled gracefully across the
pillows, with a poisonous barb touching
the floor.
Her wings were folded, and her scales
shimmered like white gold against the red
backdrop.
Blaze lifted her dark eyes and saw Glory
and Jambu in the doorway.
She forced a smile, and reached her front
talons toward them in a welcoming
gesture.
Oh, wonderful, she said.
We haven't had visitors in so long.
I was hoping Queen Glacier would send us
news.
Glory bowed and Jambu imitated her.
If this is a bad time, your majesty, we
can wait until later.
No, no.
Please come in, Blaze cried.
Okatillo, please bring us some tea.
Oh, and some of those dried lizards, if
we have any left.
Of course, Your Majesty. said the 1st
guard, with a respectful bow.
Both sandwing soldiers backed out of the
room, leaving Glory and Jambu alone with
Blaze.
I'm guessing it wouldn't be this easy to
get a private audience with burn or
blister, Lori thought.
Blaze was not as cautious or suspicious
as her sisters, but then she had no
reason to suspect a pair of ice wings.
Is it about Queen Scarlet?
Blaise asked, leaning forward.
Did we find out if she's dead?
Are the Sky Wings still following burn?
You know, if Glacier would let me go to
the Sky Kingdom?
I bet I could convince the Sky Wings to
switch alliances to us.
I can be really convincing.
Everyone likes me.
Or they could throw you in prison.
Glory thought, or hand you over to burn.
I know what you'll say, Blaise said
restlessly.
What glacier always says, stay put, and
let her handle things.
I know all that military stuff is too
confusing for me, but I think I could be
useful with a talking part.
Other dragons like hearing me talk.
I'm sure that is true, Your Majesty, said
Glory politely.
So, Blaise said, her pitch dark eyes were
too eerily similar to burns and
blisters.
They gave Glory the creeps, even though
she knew a very different brain was
behind them.
What's your important message?
Option one, make up a lie.
Option two.
Run for it.
Option three.
Tell a version of the truth.
Glory took a deep breath.
The dragonettes of the prophecy want to
meet you.
Blaze set up fast.
The dragonettes?
she cried.
Glacier found them?
They're looking for you, glory hedged.
Well, bring them here, bring them here
Blaise said.
We can have a feast or a party.
We haven't had one of those in forever
because, you know, Queen Glacier
disapproves of that kind of thing, but
for something like this, I'm sure we
could.
Oh, we'll definitely need more dried
lizards.
We even have a pair of scavengers we
could share.
Maybe we should roast a camel.
One of them's a mudwing, right?
He had probably like that.
We don't have anything for sea wings.
Maybe Queen Glacier can send us some fish
or a penguin.
Or do you think she'd like a walrus?
Wait, Glory said.
As tempting as a feast sounded, and she
knew clay would collapse with joy if you
were offered a roasted camel, she wasn't
about to walk her friends back into
another queen's clutches.
There's a catch.
They're not willing to risk coming
inside.
They need you to go meet with them.
Blaise flung herself down on the carpets
again, looking petulant.
But what about my party?
she said, and I don't like going
outside.
It's too cold and it makes my scales all
dry and ugly.
You won't have to go far, Glory said.
Jambu was twitching in a weird
distracting way.
She poked him with her tail.
And isn't it worth it if the dragonettes
end up choosing you to be the next
sandwing queen?
Blaise worried one of her claws between
her teeth, thinking.
Jamboo poked Glory back and cut his eyes
toward the far corner of the room.
Glory squinted, but all she could see was
sand and stone walls and tapestry
except...
Then the sand moved, and for the briefest
moment, a pair of eyes blinked out of the
wall, then vanished again.
Mangrove is here.
I should wait for Queen Glacier, Blaise
said.
She wouldn't like my going off alone.
I'm sure she wants to meet the
dragonettes too.
Glory already did not like the sound of
the ice wing queen.
She'd bet that Glacier was exactly the
kind of dragon who would love to lock up
5 Dragonettes.
Actually, Glory said.
She sent us to tell you that it's a good
idea.
You should go ahead and meet with them
and you can tell her all about it
afterward.
There's nothing to fear from the
dragonettes.
And besides, Penguin and I will be there
to protect you.
Oh, said Blaze.
That is reassuring.
She gave Jambu a concerned look, and he
managed to stop twitching for a moment.
Do you think they'll really choose me?
Blaise asked hopefully, turning back to
glory.
Oh, who am I kidding?
I'm sure they will if they meet me.
All right, I'll do it.
Great.
Jambu burst out.
Let's go.
Right now, Blaise said.
Already?
Glory wasn't sure if that was a good idea
either.
Her friends weren't exactly expecting
Blaze to show up, and it would be hard to
stay hidden from Deathbringer with a
sandwing parading along beside them.
Still, this was what they wanted, a
chance to meet the 3rd queen candidate
without risking imprisonment.
Yep, right now, Glory said.
She shot a significant look at Mangroves
Corner, hoping he'd be smart enough to
follow them out.
Blaise picked up the mirror and checked
her scales from several angles.
Finally, she swept one of the camel hair
blankets off the floor. and flung it
around her shoulders like a cape, then
led the way to the door.
Jambu darted to the corner, grabbed a
patch of sand, which turned out to be
mangrove's elbow, and tugged him along
after them.
Blaise started to turn around, but Glory
was there to distract her.
Tell me about this tapestry. she said
pointing to one with 2 large sand wing
dragons flying across a blue background.
I don't remember seeing it before.
Oh, that one was my idea, Blaise said.
It's the tragic romantic story of how my
brother fell in love with a dragon he
knew our mother would never approve of, so
he kept her hidden from us.
But then she ran off and broke his
heart.
Although we were all thinking, or did
she?
Of course, because it is so likely that
mother just found out and had her killed
which was something she would totally
do.
Blaise chattered on about the tapestry as
she swept through the antechamber.
Glory glanced sideways at the 2
scavengers.
The one with Silver's eyes had fallen
asleep, and looked even more pathetic
now.
Blaze was several steps ahead, and not
paying attention to anything but the
sound of her own voice, Glory scooped up
the sleeping scavenger, and slid it onto
her back.
It did not smell very pleasant at all.
No wonder the rain wings preferred fruit
bananas never smelled this bad.
She folded her wings back over it, hiding
it as well as she could.
Jamboo saw what she was doing, and
grabbed the other scavenger.
Even though it was awake, it barely
struggled as Jambu tucked it under one
wing.
They hurried after Blaze, following her
back through the hallways to the main
door.
They went by a few sand wing guards.
Blaise addressed them by name and they
saluted, but she didn't tell them where
she was going, and none of them looked
suspicious, or even curious.
None of them paid any attention to glory
and Jambu, or to their poorly hidden
stolen goods.
Almost every sand wing they passed was
injured in some way.
Blaze was unscathed, but all of her
soldiers had scars slicing across their
scales, or missing talons, or wounded
tails.
Glory thought of Dune.
Their sand winged guardian who had been
so maimed by the war that he could never
fly again.
It had never occurred to her to ask him
which side he had fought on before he
joined the talons of peace.
A blast of cold air smacked them in their
snouts as they stepped outside.
Blaise wrapped her blanket around herself
more tightly, lifted her claws gingerly
out of the snow, and whined.
Are you sure the dragonettes won't come
inside?
Glory glanced back at Jambu.
A shimmer in the air beside him was all
she could see of mangrove, but she was
relieved to know he was there.
That way, Your Majesty, she said, nodding
south.
Blaise heaved a sigh, spread her wings
and leaped into the air.
Quickly, Glory twisted around, and
dragged the scavenger off her back.
She dumped it on the snowy ground, and it
woke up with a yelp.
Jambu dropped the other one next to it.
Go on.
Run for your scrawny lives, Glory said.
Poking her scavenger with her snout.
The scavenger scrambled backward, then
grabbed the other one's arm and took off
running through the snow.
You think they'll be all right?
Jambu asked, as he and Glory flew after
Blaze.
It's so cold out here.
I bet that's what all those furs are for
Glory said.
Anyway, I'd rather freeze to death than
be eaten by a sand wing.
Blech!
Jambu said.
Meat eaters.
I don't get it.
They caught up to blaze and steered her
toward the spot where their friends were
waiting.
As they flew.
Glory scanned the ground below them for
any sign of death bringer.
The sun was high in the sky, although it
felt like it was far away, behind a
ceiling of ice.
The frost glinted on the ground, and now
Glory could see scrubby patches of brown
grass and twisted shrubs.
A gray wolf trotted across the rocks, but
he was the only sign of life she saw.
Wherever death bringer was for the day.
He'd hidden himself well.
Her friends had done their best too.
Several large boulders had been shoved
together below the cliff to look like a
fallen rock pile, and glory nearly flew
right over it.
She circled back down to land with Jambu
and Blaze behind her.
Sonny was the 1st one out.
You did it!
she cried.
You found...
Him.
Wait.
She squinted at Blaze.
Uh, glory?
That's an actual sandwing.
I know.
Don't worry.
Mangrove is here too, Glory said, flicking
her tail.
It's all right to show yourself now.
The rain wing slowly materialized in a
dull, green, unhappy color.
He ducked his head and wouldn't meet her
gaze.
Yikes.
Blaise yelped, leaping away from him.
How did that happen?
Where did he come from?
She looked around wildly.
As if she expected more dragons to
suddenly poof out of the landscape.
What do you know about rain wings, your
majesty?
Glory asked.
She watched Blaze's face intently
wondering if the sand wing knew anything
about the missing rain wings, and if it
would show in her expression.
But the potential queen looked as
mystified as before.
I've heard they're pretty, she said
tossing her head, but I've never seen
one.
You have now, Glory said.
She held out her wings and let them shift
to a light, non-threatening purple.
At the same time, John Boo's scales
shivered back to pink, although a paler
chillier pink than usual.
Ooh, Blaise said enviously.
She reached out and took one of Jambu's
wings in her talons, inspecting the
scales as if he were an inanimate
tapestry instead of a living dragon.
Jambu blinked at glory, but didn't pull
away.
Wow.
I wish I could do that, Blaise said.
I'd be a different color every minute.
She turned over the wing, so Jambu had to
contort himself into an odd position.
She didn't seem alarmed or angry to been
tricked by their ice wing disguises.
Glory wasn't sure whether to admire her
bravery or roll her eyes ablaze's lack of
caution.
Do you think the change in camouflage
would still work if I had someone make
like, a coat of rain wing scales for me?
Blaise asked.
That could be pretty.
She eyed Jamboo's scales like she was
trying to figure out how to take them off
him.
Mangrove finally looked up and met
Glory's eyes with a worried expression.
By now, clay, tsunami, and Starflight had
all emerged from the rock pile as well.
Starflight pointed at Blaze, his eyes
wide.
Glory, he cried.
This, this is, you found, I know, Glory
said.
Everyone, this is Blaze.
Blaze, these are, she hated the phrase
but it was what everyone called them.
These are the dragonettes of destiny.
Chapter 16.
Oh, wow, it is so, so, so exciting to
meet you, Blaise said brightly.
Where's the Sky Wing?
Glory managed to keep her face and scales
from showing any reaction.
The Sky Wing is dead.
She wanted to yell.
You're stuck with me instead.
Deal with it.
Glory is our 5th dragonette, Clay said.
He nodded toward her Oh, Blaise said
regarding glory with skepticism.
But...
She's a rain wing.
And the prophecy calls for a sky wing
doesn't it?
What prophecy?
John Boo asked.
What's a dragonette of destiny?
Are you serious?
Glory said to him.
Do you know anything about what's going
on out here?
It's far too complicated to explain?
Starflight said, with a flick of his
tail?
There's a war going on.
Clay said kindly, and a prophecy that
says, 5 dragonettes will stop it, and
that's us.
Oh, John Boo said.
Neat.
Yes, far too complicated, tsunami said to
Starflight.
The black dragonette frowned at her.
It's a little more specific than that.
Blaise pointed out.
It says 2 of the Sandwing sisters will
die.
Hopefully not me, and it says the 5
dragonettes are a mud wing, a sea wing, a
night wing, a sand wing, and a sky wing.
We've got a rain wing instead, said
tsunami, and we're fine with that.
There's also me, Sonny piped up.
I'm the sandwing, even though I'm weird
looking.
Blaze peered down at Sonny.
Oh my gosh, you are weird looking.
What's wrong with your tail?
Why are your scales the wrong color?
I don't know, Sonny said. spreading her
wings, but I am still the sandwing in the
prophecy.
Are you sure?
Blaze asked.
She circled around Sonny, inspecting
her.
Wow, you all are not what I expected.
For one thing, you're smaller, and I
thought you'd be, I don't know, prettier.
She stopped at glory.
Explain the rain wing again.
Also, the other 2 rain wings.
Why are they here?
You should go, Glory said to Jambu.
She glanced at Mangrove. who was
shivering and tugging his wings around
himself.
Take him home.
You're both going to freeze if you stay
out here any longer.
I'm sorry, Mangrove said to her.
I thought, I know.
We'll find her, but not here.
Glory pointed south.
Both of you go.
We'll catch up soon.
Jambu didn't argue.
He was also shivering from wing tip to
wing tip, and he looked especially glad
to have an excuse to get away from
Blaze.
Where are they going?
Blaze asked, as the 2 rain wings lifted
off.
Isn't a rainforest kind of far from
here?
You know, we actually have some questions
for you.
Starflight interjected.
Like, can you tell us why you should be
queen instead of your sisters?
Because I'm prettier and nicer and
friendlier than they are.
Blaise said.
Obviously.
She smiled and whirled in a circle
holding the blanket out so it flapped
like a flag.
I mean, haven't you met them?
Aren't they both awful?
Yeah, Clay said ruefully.
Well, Starflight said, then call the look
on Tsunami's face.
I guess they are.
But could you survive a challenge?
Tsunami asked.
If you did become queen, how long would
you last before someone tried to take the
throne from you?
Ouch!
Blaise said.
That's kind of rude, isn't it?
I'm a much older dragon than you.
I've been in a battle, more or less.
She flicked her poisonous tail back and
forth.
And I do have this deadly tail.
So do all sandwings, tsunami said
unimpressed.
Hey, how do you cure someone who's been
scratched by Sandwing Tail?
Sonny asked.
I mean, say by accident.
She did a good job of sounding like she
was just curious, but Glory knew she was
thinking of webs.
There's this cactus juice that heals our
poison, Blaise said, with a dismissive
wave, grows all over the desert.
Once again, Glory thought, she's not
suspicious at all, or worried about
keeping sand wings secrets, apparently.
Anyway, Blaze insisted to tsunami.
I'll have Queen Glacier to help me if
anything goes wrong.
Tsunami snorted.
Glacier can't fight for you in a
challenge for the throne, Starfight
said.
She can't?
Blaise said, as if this was surprising
news.
Huh?
Well, she can still come down and kill
whoever's challenging me.
She wouldn't mind.
But that wouldn't be fair, Sonny said.
That would violate all the challenge
rules.
Right, Starflight?
He nodded, but Blaze was already talking
over them.
Who cares?
She said.
Don't even worry about it.
I'll be such a great queen that no one
will want to challenge me.
There, that's an excellent plan.
So how does this prophecy thing work?
Are you guys going to kill my sisters?
That would make my life much easier.
Glory lashed your tail.
She hadn't thought of that.
Killing off burn and blister.
It was certainly one way to fulfill the
prophecy, if they could do it, which
seemed unlikely, considering armies of
dragons had been trying to kill all of
the sisters for 18 years already.
Sonny looked taken aback as well.
We are not hired killers.
She said.
We were thinking we tell everyone who we
choose, and they'll all listen to us and
stop fighting.
Oh, said Blaise.
That sounds nice.
What's the power of wings of fire?
do I get that?
These were all questions Glory had had
about the prophecy her whole life, and
yet she felt weirdly irritated to hear
them coming from Blaze, as if the
dragonettes had all the answers.
At the same time, it occurred to her to
wonder why Blister, the smartest sister
hadn't asked these questions.
Perhaps she knew the answers already.
Or perhaps she wanted someone to think
she did.
We're figuring it out, Clay said.
It's not like we chose this, Glory said.
We were sort of shoved into this whole
destiny thing.
You weren't, Blaise said, her voice light
and puzzled.
There's no rain wing in the prophecy at
all.
Why don't you just go home?
In the awkward pause that followed?
Glory imagined all the other dragons
having the exact same thought.
Why didn't she just go home, where she
could sit safely in the rainforest and
stay out of the war and sleep all day?
Maybe I should, she thought.
I mean, is it worth it?
Fighting for one of these 3 awful
sandwings?
Wouldn't it be easier to give in and
accept that I'm meant to be a lazy rain
wing?
It was almost a relief to be distracted
by a nightwing assassin landing on top of
the rock pile beside them.
The others whipped around to stare at him
their tails lashing.
Blaise squinted in a puzzled way.
Oh, hello.
Is he in the prophecy?
She asked.
He's cute.
Cuter than this one.
She waved a talon at Starflight's wounded
expression.
Why, hello everyone, said Deathbringer.
Isn't this a coincidence?
I was just talking about you all this
morning.
He turned to glory and tilted his head at
her purple scales.
Mystery dragon.
Hmm.
There's something different about you.
Did you get your clothes trimmed?
Very funny, she said, burying her teeth
at him.
You could have told me you were one of
the dragonettes.
Deathbringer said.
I'd have asked for your autograph.
I see now that you're uh, rain wings, so
glory, right.
That was creepy. that he knew her name
even if she kind of liked the sound of
him saying it, but it had to confirm her
theory about him.
Otherwise, why would he have bothered to
learn it?
Right, the one you were sent here to kill
Glory said.
Somehow, I think that would have started
us off on the wrong talent.
I'm not necessarily here to kill you.
Deathbringer objected, and even if I were
it seems like a much better opportunity
to kill her.
He suddenly opened his front talons
revealing a pair of sharp, silvery
disks.
Their edges gleamed like knives as he
flung them, one after the other, right at
Blaze.
The sand wings shrieked and stumbled back
dropping the blanket, but she didn't move
fast enough.
One disc embedded itself in her long neck
releasing a spurt of bright red blood
that sprayed all over Sonny, who was
standing next to her.
The 2nd disk sliced through the edge of
one of tsunami's wings as she leaped in
front of Blaze.
It ricocheted into one of the rocks with
a ringing sound.
Tsunami collapsed, clutching her injured
wing.
Sonny screamed, looked down at her blood
spattered scales, and screamed again.
Clay jumped forward and clapped both his
talons over the cut in Blaze's neck.
Throw me the blanket.
He yelled to Starflight.
The night wing looked back at him in
froze in terror.
Glory grabbed the blanket and flung it to
Clay, who started to wrap it around
Blaze's neck, but then Deathbringer was
there, landing on Blaze's back, and
tossing Clay aside as if the hefty mud
wing weighed no more than a salamander.
Two more silver disks appeared in
Deathbringer's talons.
Glory leaped at the assassin, and knocked
him backward off blaze.
They rolled on the frozen ground, his
black wings tangling with hers.
He was very strong, and astonishingly
fast.
A black pouch around his neck thumped
against her chest, and she realized that
must be where he kept his weapons.
She seized it between her claws, just as
he pinned her down, his talons on her
wings.
Killing Blaze was your assignment, she
said.
No, but I like to work outside the box, he
answered.
And if I kill her, I figure it'll get me
out of the trouble I'm in for not killing
you.
You can try to kill me, she growled.
But I doubt it'll be as easy as you
think.
She ripped open the pouch and caught a
few of the silver disks as they spilled
into her talons.
Several others clattered to the ground
around her, but one was all she needed.
She pressed it to Deathbringer's neck
before he could jump away.
You missed the biggest artery on Blaze's
neck, she said.
If I remember my dragon anatomy correctly
right here.
She applied a little more pressure, and
Deathbringer flinched as the silver edge
left a thin trail of blood on his
scales.
He lifted his talons from her shoulders
and carefully backed off her.
Glory stood up, keeping the disc poised
at his neck, and glanced over
Deathbringer's shoulder.
Clay had the blanket tied firmly around
Blaze's neck, but blood was already
seeping through the camel hair fabric.
The sand wing queen leaned against him
looking faint.
Tsunami had also climbed to her feet, and
was examining the cut on her own wing
with a scowl.
Starflight hadn't moved.
Sunny was still staring at the blood all
over her talons and wings.
I did mention the pot about how I don't
actually want to kill you, right?
Deathbringer said, eye and glory, and the
disks she held with a faintly amused
expression.
I'm pretty sure I snuck that in there.
Oh, all right, Glory said.
I'll just trust you then, shall I?
If you let me kill her.
I can let you all go, he said.
I should give you a fair head start
before they send someone else after you
especially since no one knows where
you'll go next.
All of us, Glory said.
You're here to kill all of us?
No, he said, still smiling.
Just a couple of you.
Well, that makes me feel better, she
said.
Stop looking so pleased with yourself.
She poked his neck, and he tried, and
failed to look serious.
Which couple of us?
Sonny asked.
Who's they?
Tsunami demanded at the same time, who
sent you?
The night wings, Starflight said
bleakly.
That's it, isn't it?
Because of what happened in the kingdom
of the sea, because we didn't choose
blister.
The Night Wings wanted us to choose
blister?
Glory said.
A tsunami world to stare at Starflight.
Why would they care?
I don't know, Starflight said.
That's all Moro Seer told me, that we had
to pig blister, and I should convince you
all to agree to it.
That's so mean.
Blaise interjected, opening her eyes and
looking a bit more alive.
Why should the Nightwings get to decide?
They've never even met me.
I'm awesome.
Oh, that's why you were acting so weird
around blister, Clay said to Starflight.
Deathbringer suddenly lunged forward
faster than a striking snake, and seized
Glory's front talons, she thwacked his
head as hard as she could with her wings
and kicked at his underscales with her
back claws.
Now, stop, he cried.
It's like you want me to kill you.
Just then the sound of wing beats reached
their ears.
Glory and Deathbringer both froze and
looked up at the sky.
Queen Glacier.
Blaze breathed with a relieved sigh.
I knew she would save me.
The glitter of diamond wings approaching
from the north was unmistakable.
The ice wings were on their way.
Chapter 17.
Given a choice between the ice wing queen
and a night wing assassin, Glory wasn't
sure she'd actually prefer the ice wing
queen.
Imprisonment in the Sky Kingdom, and in
Queen Coral's Summer Palace, had been bad
enough.
If they wound up in glaciers dungeon
they'd probably all freeze to death by
the end of the day.
Let me go right now, she said to
Deathbringer.
To her immense surprise, he did.
He stepped back, his talons raised to
look harmless, and actually dared to
smile at her.
Time to go.
Tsunami ordered.
They'll be here in about 2 minutes.
Oh, no.
Wait, Blaise said.
She spread her wings and waved at the
incoming ice dragons.
You should meet Glacier.
You'll like her.
We can't leave Blaze here with him.
Clay said, pointing to Death Bringer.
That's true, Glory said.
She narrowed her eyes at the assassin.
You have 10 seconds to take off, or we'll
knock you out and leave you for the ice
wings to deal with.
Shouldn't we do that anyway?
Blaze asked.
I mean, he did try to kill me.
Queen Glacier will be so mad.
This one time, a Skywing flew all the way
here and nearly got me, while I was
getting some sun, and Glacier literally
ripped off his wings before she killed
him.
It was really gross, but also kind of
sweet, you know, like she really cares
about me.
Or she really cares about all the land
she'll get if you become queen, Glory
thought.
Sonny looked faintly sick.
Guess what, I don't want to see. she
said.
One dragon ripping the wings off another
dragon.
Not ever.
Thanks.
All right, I'm convinced, Deathbringer
said, backing away.
But you really should have let me kill
her.
He paused with his wings spread and gave
Glory a cheeky grin.
So, when can I see you again?
Get out of here, Glory said.
Glad that Jambu wasn't there to loudly
interpret the colors that were trying to
shift through her scales.
Death Bringer bolted into the sky.
Blaise followed him with her eyes for a
moment, then seemed to lose interest.
She turned to Clay and tsunami with a
winning smile.
Please don't go, Blaise said.
Queen Glacier will be so grateful to you
for saving my life.
Now we can have that party I mentioned.
Sorry, tsunami said.
We are not sticking around to become
captives again.
We'll uh, we'll be in touch, Clay said.
Keep applying pressure to this until a
healer can look at it.
Blaise rallied herself to stand upright
and give them all a little nod.
It was delightful to meet you, she said
even if you are missing a sky wing, and
some of you are a little funny looking.
I promise you'll be pleased if you choose
me.
She waved a wing weekly in the direction
of the desert.
I can offer you whatever land you want.
You could each have land enough for a
palace of your own.
Quit giving away your territory.
Glory snapped.
I know the kingdom of sand is big, but
life in the desert is tough, and your
subjects need every oasis, and if you do
become queen, you'll need to rebuild your
treasury somehow.
So remember that too.
Queenly advice from a rain wing.
Blaise giggled, as if the pain in her
neck was making her loopy.
No, I have heard everything.
Glory frowned at her, but the sand wing
didn't seem to notice.
Come on.
Clay said gently to Sonny, urging her
up.
Sonny held her blood stained talons out
and Starflight jumped forward to take
them between his.
You'll feel better once we're in the
desert.
He said.
Don't let them follow us.
Tsunami said to Blaze as the others took
off.
They'll be too busy rescuing me, Blaise
said, lying down in a graceful
melodramatic pose.
Glory and tsunami exchanged eye rolls and
lifted into the air.
The ice wings were almost upon them.
They had to fly as fast as they could.
Tsunami faltered for a moment as she went
aloft.
Does it hurt?
Glory asked, flying close to her.
Will you make it to the passage?
I'll be fine, tsunami said, through
gridded teeth.
It's just a cut.
After a moment she added, But yes, it
hurts.
Gloria stayed alongside her as they flew
through the cold, pale blue sky.
She glanced back several times, but saw
no sign of ice wings in pursuit.
No sign of a night wing trailing them
either.
Glory, tsunami said after a bit.
Can I ask you something?
Why didn't you use your venom on that
assassin?
Glory felt a tinge of embarrassed pink
creeping along her scales and fought it
back until she matched the sky.
That wasn't an invitation to disappear
tsunami said.
I just didn't feel like killing him.
Glory answered.
I don't want to kill any more than I have
to.
But he is literally on a mission to kill
you, tsunami said.
Killing him 1st is kind of the definition
of self-defense.
Maybe, Glory said.
I just, It didn't feel like he was trying
to kill me.
Tsunami shook her head.
All right, but so you know, from where I
was standing, it certainly looked like
it.
Whatever, Glory said.
We'll probably never see him again.
The real question is why the night wings
are getting so involved.
First, they try to get us to choose
blister, and then they send an assassin
to kill us.
Don't they want their prophecy to come
true?
Maybe, like everyone else?
They only wanted to come true their way.
Tsunami grumbled.
What's their way?
Glory wondered.
What difference does it make to them who
the queen of the sand wings is?
I have no idea, tsunami admitted.
Well, if they have something to say about
this war, Glory said, they can come on
out and fight it, instead of hiding and
making vague predictions every few
years.
And sending assassins, tsunami added
cowards.
It wasn't often that tsunami and glory
agreed about something.
Glory couldn't remember the last time
they'd had a conversation this long
without arguing.
It wasn't that she disliked tsunami.
She didn't even really mind her
bossiness.
But she did feel like someone needed to
talk back whenever tsunami started acting
like the boss of everyone, just to make
sure tsunami's head didn't get too big
for the rest of her.
On the other talent, tsunami had been
much better since their escape from the
kingdom of the sea.
Glory could see that she was trying to
include the others more, instead of just
telling them all what to do.
And tsunami never talked about her future
as a queen anymore.
When it used to be her favorite topic of
conversation.
Maybe she'd meant it when she said, she
didn't belong in the kingdom of the sea.
Maybe she'd really given up on ruling her
tribe one day.
It was dark by the time they spotted
Burns' stronghold in the distance, and
the semicircle of cacti they were looking
for.
Glory and tsunami spiraled down to the
ground and found Starflight, frantically
digging in the sand.
The hole is gone, he cried.
It's disappeared.
A bolt of green panic shot through
glory's scales, trapped between the ice
wings and burn with an assassin out
hunting them, was not how she wanted to
spend the night.
It's not gone, Clay said firmly.
Let me dig.
He muscled Starfly aside, looked up at
the cacti and started to dig in a
slightly different spot.
What are you doing?
Tsunami called to Sonny, who looked like
she was trying to tango with a cactus up
the hill.
You heard what Blaise said, Sonny
panted.
If we take this back, maybe we can heal
webs out.
She flinched back from the thorns, shaking
her front talons.
We don't need the whole cactus, tsunami
said amused.
Break off one of those arm things and
bring that instead.
That is what I'm trying to do.
Sonny said irately.
Tsunami floundered up the sandy rise to
help her.
Glory noticed that Sonny had used sand to
rub off some of the blood stains, but
there was still dark dried blood caught
between her scales and talons.
There, Clay said.
Found it.
He swiped some more sand away from the
entrance to the tunnel.
Starflight let out his breath.
Oh, he said.
That must be why no one spotted it
before.
The wind covers it with new sand every
day.
He edged toward the tunnel.
So, we can go?
Glory checked the sky again as Sunny and
Tsunami slid back toward them with a
chunk of cactus.
No dragons anywhere that she could see.
She nodded at the tunnel, and Starflight
darted gratefully inside.
The others followed, one by one.
Glory went last, piling up as much sand
behind her as she could.
As she came out of the tunnel into the
dark forest, a ball of fur exploded from
the tree above her and landed on her
neck.
The sloth wrapped her arms and legs
around Glory's neck, and began warbling
and chirruping furiously.
I think I'm being scolded, Glory said to
Clay.
She reached up and smoothed Silver's
fur.
Worm.
The sloth said sternly, snuggling in
closer.
Sonny dove into the stream above the
waterfall, washing Blaze's blood off her
scales.
Glory realized that Jambu was gone, but
Mangrove was sitting beside the stream.
His wings drooped as he stared into the
water.
I assume you didn't see any sign of the
missing rain wings there?
Glory said to him.
He shook his head.
Nothing anywhere in that fort.
I slipped in when a patrol of sandwings
came out.
I searched the whole place.
He kicked a clump of reeds.
Useless waste of time.
Probably, Glory said, but at least now we
know.
How are we going to find Orchid?
he asked.
Glory stared at the hole in the boulder.
In the dark, with only a sliver of
moonlight slipping through the trees, it
looked like a mouth, jaws wide open to
swallow dragon's hole.
We heard something here a couple of
nights ago.
She said.
Maybe, if we lie in wait, we'll catch it
again.
She turned and looked at tsunami.
All we need is someone who can see in the
dark.
Chapter 18.
Glory shifted on her branch inside.
The knight clung to her wings like hot
sticky cobwebs.
A vine of moon colored flowers nearby
filled the air with a smell like muskrats
rolled in lemons.
It was not pleasant.
You didn't have to stay.
Tsunami whispered.
Yes, I did, Glory said.
I know you.
No matter what you see, you'll leap out
of this tree and attack it if you're here
by yourself.
I... tsunami paused.
Well, I still might do that.
Then at least I'll be here to help, Lori
said, grinning in the dark.
They crouch like that for a while
listening to the creaking, chirping
sounds of the rainforest at night.
Some kind of insect was desperately
announcing the end of the world in a
shrill whine from the top of their tree.
If glory had been able to see it, she
would have eaten it in a heartbeat, just
to shut it up.
They'd spent the rest of last night and
today in the rain wing village, recovering
from their long flight.
Sunny had squeezed the cactus juice into
Webb's wound, and reported jubilantly
that she thought it was working.
The others had stayed there for tonight.
Glory thought it was unlikely that they'd
catch the mystery monster on their 1st
night watching, and they looked pretty
exhausted.
She'd also made Mangrove promise not to
follow them again, and she'd left silver
with Sonny, because the only thing they
knew for sure was that the monster ate
sloths.
What did you think of Blaze?
Tsunami asked in a whisper.
Should we choose her?
I don't know, Lori whispered back.
I didn't really like her, did you?
She really needed to shut up about Sky
Wings, tsunami said.
Glory couldn't agree more, but she was
glad tsunami had said it instead of her.
She seemed much less sinister than burn
or blister, Glory said, but also
completely incompetent.
Is it fair to give the sand wings a
totally useless queen like that?
And she's certainly not going to win the
war just by us saying she should.
That's true, tsunami said.
She'd never survive in actual combat
especially against one of her sisters.
Anyway, Glory said.
It's not up to me.
You guys decide whatever you want.
I mean, since I'm not in the prophecy
anyhow, so I shouldn't get a say.
Stop talking like that or I will thump
you, Tsunami said, in a loud hiss.
Glory could feel her glaring even in the
dark, and she felt obscurely pleased.
Shh, Glory said, flicking her tail at
tsunami's wings.
What was that?
Snap.
Both dragons froze with their heads
lifted.
Glory's ears twitched.
Snap, slither.
That's it.
Glory whispered.
Her heart was pounding again.
She tried to squint through the darkness
of the boulder, but she couldn't see
anything moving.
The sounds of something large rustled
through the undergrowth.
It was breathing heavily, snuffling in
and out, like a congested rhinoceros.
It didn't come out of the hole, tsunami
whispered.
It's on the other side of the creek, near
the other tree.
But I can't.
I'm not sure.
She leaned forward, trying to see under
the branches.
Suddenly, another noise reached them, as
if from a long way away.
It sounded like, Whistling.
Glory leaned forward, listening
intently.
It was the Dragonette's song.
The ones she'd last heard when the
prisoners were singing it in the Skywing
Arena.
The dragonettes are coming.
They're coming to save the day.
They're coming to fight, for they know
what's right.
The dragonettes.
Someone was whistling their song.
That is coming from the hole, tsunami
whispered.
She crouched to peer through the leaves.
A dark shape appeared at the opening of
the boulder.
At the same time, the dragons heard
thumping and crackling as the mystery
creature fled back into the forest.
Glory cursed under her breath and leaped
to her feet.
Should we go after it?
The tsunami had already launched herself
out of the tree and flung herself at the
boulder.
She collided with the shape there, and
they both yelped with pain, rolling and
grappling on the ground.
Glory sprang after her and seized the new
dragon's tail.
The 3 of them wrestled until glory and
tsunami had him pinned down, and glory
could sit on his chest.
She was not particularly surprised to
discover, it was Deathbringer.
The night wing had sand between his claws
and an unrepentant expression on his face
from what she could see in the ripples of
moonlight that made it through the leaves
overhead.
What kind of assassin stalks his prey and
whistles at the same time.
Glory asked him.
We should kill him right now.
Tsunami hissed.
You scared our monster away, Glory said
poking his snout.
So now we're extra mad at you.
Yes, that plus the trying to kill us
tsunami said.
One monster, Deathbringer said, a little
too innocently.
Glory peered at him with growing
suspicion.
Did he know something?
Did you follow us through the tunnel, she
asked, or did you already know it was
there?
How would I know it was there?
he asked.
That's what I'd like to know, she said.
Let's take him back to the village and
interrogate him, Tsunami said.
I don't think that's safe, Glory said.
I mean, for the rain wings or for the
others.
We should keep him as far away from
everyone as possible.
Tsunami wrinkled her snout, thinking.
Or, she said, we go back to plan A, kill
him right now.
Tsunami, I don't think you want to do
that any more than I do.
Glory said.
That shut her up.
Glory had noticed tsunami getting
queasier about killing other dragons
after her experiences in the Sky Wing
Arena.
Self-defense was one thing, but they had
Deathbringer trapped under their talons.
All right, tsunami said finally, after a
long pause, you're right, I don't want
to.
But I was hoping he'd think we wanted to
so good job backing me up on that.
Sorry, I couldn't read your mind like a
stupid night wing, Glory said.
Speaking of which, are you the mind
reading kind of night wing?
She narrowed her eyes, a death bringer?
What am I thinking right now?
That I'm much too charming, clever, and
good looking to kill?
He guessed.
That was actually a little closer to
accurate than Glory liked.
She flared her rough and poked us now
again.
Wrong, she said.
I'm thinking that you're starting to be
an awful lot of trouble.
Have you decided to kill me after all?
The rakish grin faded from Deathbringer's
face.
He studied her, as though he were
seriously considering the question.
Not sure I like the length of this pause
Lori said.
I've been wondering if there's an
alternative, said Deathbringer, but
that's not usually my call.
Whose is it?
Tsunami demanded.
The Nightwing Queen?
Death bringer made a peculiar expression
which Glory couldn't interpret.
I can't say.
I don't understand why any Night Wings
would want me dead, Glory said.
That has become ever more mystifying to
me as well, Deathbringer said, in a
manner that managed to sound both gallant
and truthful.
So you're mystified, Glory said.
But you'll still probably do it.
I wouldn't say, probably.
Deathbringer offered.
I'd say maybe.
I wouldn't call that reassuring, glory
shot back.
I'd call that the opposite of
reassuring.
He grinned at her again.
He really needed to quit doing that.
It was very distracting.
So what do we do with them?
Tsunami asked her.
We can't let him go, and we can't take
him back to the rain wing village.
We could tie him up, leave him in the
forest, and hope the monster eats him.
Glory said.
She squinted at Deathbringer's face.
He didn't look even a little bit
worried.
Did we mention the monster?
she asked him.
It's been abducting or possibly eating
rain wings around here?
I bet it'll be pretty excited to find you
all tied up.
Oh no, Deathbringer said.
Please don't leave me alone where a
monster could get me.
Glory opened her mouth and then closed
it.
She'd just had a possibly brilliant and
perfectly terrible idea.
One she'd have to think about for a
minute.
She poked him and the snout again.
Was that sarcasm?
she asked.
Tsunami?
Did that sound weirdly sarcastic to you?
Like he doesn't believe in monsters?
Tsunami said, which I'm not sure I do
either, just for the record.
Or he's in cahoots with it.
Glory thought.
Or at least he knows what it is, and
isn't afraid of it.
She decided not to say this out loud.
Tsunami's enthusiasm for interrogation
might spring up again, and Glory was
fairly sure it would be a waste of time.
They weren't going to get anything useful
out of Deathbringer by looking fierce and
demanding answers.
Besides, now that a plan was forming in
her mind, she wanted to try it out, which
meant she had to get rid of tsunami.
Let's drag him away from the tunnel and
tie him up.
She said.
Then you go tell the others, and we can
take turns watching him until he decides
to tell us who wants us dead and why.
And which of us?
tsunami suggested.
He said he was sent to kill a few of us
not just you.
And also, you know, how to avoid it, said
glory.
You'll have to wait a while.
Deathbringer said.
I'm not allowed to tell you anything.
Tsunami and glory ignored this.
They ripped vines down from the trees and
wrapped the strongest ones around his
wings.
Tsunami tied his talons together so he
couldn't run, slid a rope around his neck
and prodded him ahead of them into the
forest.
After a short walk, they found a tree
that tsunami approved of, and tied him to
it with a tightest knot they could
muster.
He'll burn through these vines the moment
we walk away.
Tsunami pointed out.
So we don't walk away.
Glory said.
You go tell the others.
I'll sit here with my extremely deadly
secret weapon pointed at him.
What's that?
asked Deathbringer.
Wait, let me guess.
You'll rape your wit.
Try to escape, and find out the dead
way.
Glory offered.
He leaned back against the tree, looking
perfectly comfortable and thoroughly
uninterested in escaping.
Peculiar dragon.
Glory thought.
Send back clay first.
Glory suggested to Tsunami, he can take
the next watch.
I hope you hear how bossy you're being
tsunami said.
I'm letting it slide for now, but I'll
remember this.
Oh, go away.
Glory flapped her wings at her until the
sea wing lifted off into the darkness.
As her wing beats faded, the night sounds
of the rainforest settled over them.
An orchestra of insects warbled and
chirped away as the trees rustled.
Night birds called, and frogs muttered in
the background like a disgruntled
audience.
It's so noisy here.
Death bringer said after a moment, so
alive.
Is it not like that where you come from?
Glory asked.
It's a lot quieter than the Ice Kingdom
he pointed out.
And the kingdom of sand.
He didn't say anything about the
Nightwing Home, but she didn't really
expect him to.
She stared into the trees, thinking
hard.
Once Clay arrived to take her place, she
could slip away.
No one would notice she was missing for a
while.
She could go out and look for the monster
by herself, which was the best way to do
anything if you asked her.
Don't do it. said Deathbringer suddenly.
You better not be reading my mind, she
snapped.
I don't have to, he said.
You have, I'm about to do something
stupid written all over your face.
It's not stupid, she said.
It's quite clever, and it might be the
only way to catch the monster.
Maybe you should leave the monster
alone.
He said.
Forget about it.
Get back to the prophecy fulfilling
business.
That stopped her for a moment.
The prophecy.
Putting an end to the war was important.
Finding a few rain wings hardly compared
but she'd made a promise.
I'm not even in the stupid prophecy, she
said.
I know, he said.
But I bet you'd still be remarkably good
at making it come true.
That doesn't make any sense, she said, and
the rain wings are my tribe.
They need my help.
She felt a burst of certainty in her
chest, and I have to do this on my own.
Wait, said Deathbringer, with a
gratifying note of alarm in his voice.
Why?
You have friends.
Let them help you.
Glory shook her head.
They can't help me with this.
The monster, or whatever is out there
isn't going to approach a group of
dragonettes.
It attacks rain wings who are out in the
forest alone.
So you're...
Gloria smiled at Deathbringer.
I'm going to use myself as bait.
Chapter 19.
Watch him carefully, Glory instructed
Clay.
Don't let him talk.
Deathbringer complained through the vines
she'd tied around its snout.
She didn't want him spilling the beans to
clay before she could get away into the
forest.
Also, she'd gotten sick of listening to
him Yammer all night long, trying to
derail her plan.
This way, she'd been able to watch the
sunrise in relative peace and quiet
shortly after which Clay had shown up.
No worries, Play said.
I'll just sit here and be my usual
intimidating self.
He threw back his shoulders and tried to
scowl.
Absolutely terrifying.
Glory assured him.
Deathbringer managed to look skeptical
despite the vines obscuring most of his
face.
I'll send someone else soon to take the
next watch, she said, backing away.
But first, I'm going to catch a monster.
It wasn't that stupid a plan, no matter
what Death Bringer said.
Alone rain wing was exactly the kind of
target the monster would go after, and
she couldn't risk enlisting another rain
wing as bait, they were all too dopey to
be any use, even mangrove.
Besides, as far as she could tell, she
was the only rain wing willing to use her
venom on other living things.
It wasn't her favorite thing to do, but
it was still a weapon, a powerful one
that few dragons knew about, and she was
sure she could use it to escape any
situation if she had to.
She headed back to the tunnel first.
She was still certain that it was
connected to the missing rain wings
although she couldn't figure out how.
It started with a question, who had put
the tunnel in place, and then, what was
their plan?
To steal a rain wing here and there?
Why?
Glory nosed around the forest near the
tunnel opening until she found a clearing
where she could sit and think for a
moment.
Burn seemed like an obvious suspect, since
her stronghold was not far from the
tunnel.
But glory had seen the look on Burns' face
as glory's venom sizzled on Queen
Scarlet's scales.
It was pure, shocked terror.
The sandwing queen had clearly never seen
anything like glory's venom before.
If she were the one abducting rain wings
for the past year, surely she'd have
heard about their training sessions, and
she'd know all about it.
Glory stopped at a small bush, and
sprayed it with her venom.
Black goop spattered over the leaves, and
almost immediately the whole bush wilted
shriveled up, and died.
Glory tilted her head at it, feeling
weirdly guilty.
Maybe she could practice her aim while
she waited for the monster to attack
her.
She chose another bush with long dragon
tail leaves, and tried to hit just one of
them.
Half the bush went, and melted into the
grass.
Hmm, Glory said aloud.
Not awesome.
She tried again, and again, the clearing
was starting to look a bit worse for
wear.
Glory stopped and smacked herself with
her tail.
Try using your brain for half a moment
glory.
If she made a mess like this with her
venom practice, then surely the other
training dragonettes would have too.
So even though Bromeliad wouldn't show
her where Kinkachu had disappeared, there
was a chance Glory could find it on her
own.
She started at the waterfall and circled
out from there, walking so she could
study the bushes as she went past them.
Fat, spiny frogs stared at her, making
woo goo woo noises in their throats.
A pair of red and gold birds with large
beaks followed her for a while, gossiping
loudly in what sounded like garbled
dragon language, but she found nothing, no
signs of venom anywhere.
Maybe the training sessions had been in a
whole different part of the forest, maybe
the secret tunnel really had nothing to
do with the abductions.
Glory stubbornly kept searching.
What other reason could there be for the
tunnel?
Who would need to get quickly between the
desert and the rainforest?
No one.
No one came to the rainforest at all, and
the rain wings certainly never left.
But the war is closer than they think, she
thought.
It's right on their doorstep, ready to
fall through into their peaceful world.
She glared up at the treetops as an image
of Queen Magnificent flashed through her
head.
And what is that useless queen going to
do about it?
Blaze is no better than magnificent.
If we pick her, we leave the sand wings
as weak and vulnerable as the rain
wings.
She looked up at the trees again.
Was it getting darker?
The sun had been up for only a couple of
hours.
A fat raindrop splattered against her
snout.
The leaves above her whoosht like dragon
wings as the wind rushed through them, and
more rain came pattering down in scatters
and sprays.
Glory drew her wings close to her.
Rain probably washed away any trace of
venom training days ago.
She realized, but she kept going, sodden
undergrowth squelching below her talons.
She found herself in a small circle, where
the trees above bent together to form a
kind of umbrella canopy, keeping the
ground below relatively dry.
She stopped there, stretching and shaking
her wings.
This is stupid.
She told herself, I'm not going to find
anything, and I'm not going to get caught
by anything in this weather either.
What kind of creature would be out
hunting in the rain?
She might as well head back to the
village and dry off.
But as she turned to fly away, She
spotted a dark patch on the bush of pink
flowers beside her.
Gloria paused, then edged closer and
peered at it.
Several of the leaves were withered and
dead, looking sickly, black and twisted.
A glossy pattern of dark droplets had
hardened on the ground under the bush.
Someone was training here, Glory
thought.
Maybe Kinkachu, maybe one of the other
missing dragons.
She poked the piles of leaves that
covered the ground and found half a talon
print in the dirt, a small one, even
smaller than Sonny's.
She leaned down to sniff at it, and that
was when something bashed her on the back
of her head.
Glory started away to the feeling of
movement, and something uncomfortable
pressing against her wings, she kept
still for a moment with her eyes closed
trying to figure out what was happening.
It felt like she was being dragged along
the ground.
Her left side was unpleasantly damp and
slimy, as if she were wrapped in
something that instantly soaked up the
mud and clung to her scales, rain still
splattered around her, the sound muffled
now by whatever she was in, a giant sack
of some kind, she guessed.
Her wings were bound to her sides, and
thick cloth was wrapped around her
claws.
More disturbingly, some kind of vine or
rope was tied around her snout, binding
her mouth shut, which meant using her
venom was out of the question.
It also meant that whatever had called
her wasn't just a mindless mystery
beast.
It was smart enough to tie her up.
It probably knew about her venom, or it
might just be wary of her teeth.
Her tails whacked against something solid
and she winced.
She cracked open her eyes and saw only
darkness.
No, wait.
Not total darkness, faint green light
filtered through the thick canvas around
her, the sack pressed close to her
snout.
It smelled like dead animals and rotten
eggs and fire.
Overwhelming the damp, leafy scent of the
rainforest outside.
Glory tried to listen for clues, but all
she could hear was wet slithering, which
might be just the sack sliding over the
forest floor.
Then a shiver ran down her spine, like
sharp claws scrabbling to escape.
She recognized the weird prickle under
her scales.
It was the feeling she got from the hole
that led to the kingdom of sand.
I was right, she thought.
They're taking me to the tunnel.
Somehow, without her venom, she didn't
feel quite as triumphant about being
right as she'd hoped.
She heard splashing, and a moment later
water soaked through the sack as she was
dragged through the stream.
A couple of grunts followed, and Glory
felt herself lifted up into the air, then
dropped onto cold stone.
Something shoved at her tail, and she
started to slide down and down, as if it
were slick ice below her.
Wait, she thought with a sickening
lurch.
The tunnel to the desert doesn't go
down.
Where am I?
She smacked into a wall and slid around a
corner, picking up speed again.
This isn't the hold of the kingdom of
sand, but it feels like that hole.
So is this the same kind of passageway?
ripped into the world where it shouldn't
be?
And where does this one end?
She tumbled suddenly into open space and
slammed into a pile of thin firs, which
did not do much to blunt the impact of
the rocks underneath them.
Glory lay there for a moment, trying not
to groan.
Every bone in her body ached.
Every scale felt as though it had been
scraped raw.
She was pretty sure she'd bent her tongue
when she landed.
She could taste blood in her mouth.
The smell of death and smoke was stronger
now, and it was no longer raining, but
there was hardly any light coming through
the sack.
This was definitely not the desert.
It was chilly, instead of blazingly warm
although the sound of a fire crackled
somewhere nearby.
Glory could hear a distant rumble like
faraway thunderclouds, except that it
felt like it was coming from below the
rocks instead of up in the sky.
Heavy feet thudded down beside her, and
something snuffled loudly around the
sack.
Its breathing sounded the same as
whatever had eaten the dead sloth in the
night.
Glory clenched her talons.
Was it planning to eat her, because it
was in for quite a surprise if it...
Another one, said a disapproving voice.
The snuffling hitched for a 2nd, as if
startled, and then a hoarse voice beside
Gloria's head said, yeah, easy catch.
She was all alone in the forest.
Stupid, like all rain wings.
Dragons, Lori thought.
Relief warred with fury.
They're just dragons.
Nothing mysterious and creepy.
Apart from the basic mysterious
creepiness of kidnapping other dragons
that is, well, I can handle a couple of
creepy dragons, just as soon as they take
this sack off me.
She flexed her claws, wondering if she
could rip through the cloth around them.
Didn't you get the message, said the 1st
dragon.
Yeah, said the one with a garbled
breathing.
But I like the prey in the rainforest, and
I was hungry, and then this dragon was
just asking to get caught.
Besides, I thought his message was
stupid.
It's not stupid.
If it keeps us safe.
The 1st dragon side.
Throw her in with the others, but from
now on, do as you're told.
Yeah, yeah.
Grumbled the 2nd dragon.
All right, I got it.
No more hunting or grabbing dragons in
the rainforest until Death Bringer says
it's all clear.
Chapter 20.
Glory had never been so glad that her
scales were hidden.
There was no way she could stop the
colors flooding through them.
She couldn't even guess what they were
turning to right now.
Deathbringer did know who was taking the
missing rain wings.
He was connected to them, and somehow he
had told them to stop, until it's all
clear.
What did that mean?
Until he'd finished killing the
dragonettes, or until Glory and her
friends stopped snooping around the
tunnel.
And how did he get a message to these
dragons?
Glory had left him in the ice kingdom, and
then caught him coming out of the desert
tunnel into the rainforest.
He'd said he followed the dragonettes to
the hole in the sand, but maybe he'd
known about it before.
Maybe he'd gotten there first, gone
through to this place, warned these
dragons, and then gone back to the desert
tunnel after the dragonettes were back in
the rainforest, but...
Glory remembered that Deathbringer had
conveniently appeared just in time to
stop them from catching the creature in
the dark.
He did that on purpose.
He was warning off the other dragon.
This one with a weird breathing.
Deathbringer knew we would catch him.
Maybe he wanted us to catch him.
Her tail curled, and my friends are alone
with Deathbringer.
I have to get back to them.
I have to get back right now.
She flung open her wings and lashed her
tail, clawing at the sack frantically.
Whoa, yelled the hoarse voice.
A little help here.
Gloria's heart sank at the sound of
footsteps and wing beats.
There were a lot more than 2 dragons out
there.
She kicked out blindly, fighting as hard
as she could, but Talons grabbed her from
all sides, pinning her to the ground.
You'll never get her there like this
gasped one of the dragons.
You'll have to knock her out again.
My pleasure, said the hoarse voice.
And once again, something slammed into
Glory's head, and then all was darkness.
Hey.
Something nosed glory in the ribs, and
she woke up with a small yelp of pain.
Are you awake?
Tiny claws lifted glory's eyelids and
something blurry came way too close to
her snout to peer at her.
Oomph, Glory said, through the gag around
her mouth.
She tried to push the something away, but
her talons felt heavy, and she missed.
Ha ha, don't even try, said the little
voice.
I've spent my whole life waking up
dragons who'd rather be sleeping instead
of training me.
I am excellent at dodging when they get
all mad about it.
The tiny claws poked at her rough.
How come I don't know you?
Glory said again.
Her head hurt.
She rested it back on the ground and
blinked until the world came into focus.
A small diamond shaped snout hovered only
a few inches from hers.
Gigantic dark eyes peered out of gold and
orange scales.
The little dragonette couldn't have been
more than 3 years old.
She poked Glory's rough again.
Don't worry, I know you can't talk.
I'm the only one without a gag.
They decided my venom wasn't strong
enough, or I couldn't shoot it far enough
to be dangerous, or something, I guess
which is a little unfair because if
somebody would just train me properly, I
think I'd be super great at it, and then
these horrible dragons would be super
sorry for putting me in a cage.
A ripple of scarlet fury moved through
her wings.
Glory reluctantly sat up so she could
look around.
The pain in her head flared viciously, and
she had to close her eyes until it
receded into a dull throb.
When she opened them again.
She realized that the blurriness around
her wasn't just her eyes.
The air was hazy with smoke.
Pulsing heat wafted over her scales
although she couldn't see any sign of a
fire, she glanced up and saw jagged stone
walls pressing close overhead.
It seems like the heat was coming from
the rocks themselves.
Back in a cave, she thought.
Awesome.
The sack was gone, but the bindings
around her wings and claws were still in
place.
Her mouth was still bound as well, but it
felt different from before.
Whatever clamped her snout shut now, was
much heavier than the earlier vines.
She crossed her eyes trying to get a look
at it.
It's a metal band, the little dragonette
explained, tilting her head
sympathetically.
Like this one around my neck?
It's to keep you from using your venom.
But it's also so we can't camouflage
ourselves and disappear.
They'll always be able to see the metal
band.
She pointed to a thick, brassy clamp
around her own neck.
Smart but annoying, right?
She paused.
Kind of like me.
Ha ha.
My name's Kinkaju, by the way, in case
you were wondering.
So there's one of the missing rain wings
Glory thought.
Where are the others?
The small cave held only herself and the
dragonette?
A half moon of light glowed the cave
opening not far away.
Glory took a tentative step toward it
then another when nothing happened.
Nothing fell from the roof.
Nothing attacked her.
No alarms went off.
What sort of prison was this?
Kingachu followed her, still chattering.
I know what you're thinking, she said.
I'm super good at that, especially
nowadays when I'm the only one who can
talk, and so I have to imagine the other
side of every conversation I have.
Maybe telepathy is contagious or
something.
But anyway, you're thinking you can walk
out of this cave, and trust me, you
can't.
But you'll have to go see for yourself
because everybody does, I guess, instead
of listening to me.
Gloria reached the entrance and stopped.
Kinkachu was right.
There was no walking out this way.
A wide sluggish river of molten lava load
passed just outside the cave.
It glowed gold and orange bright, the
only splash of color in a barren black
landscape, with her wings bound, glory
would never make it across.
She leaned out to see where the lava
river started.
A hulking dark mountain filled the sky
half hidden by the smoke pouring out the
top.
Smaller rivulets of lava dappled the
slope, and a red glow came from a few
holes in the rocks.
It was hard to tell whether it was night
or day.
The light was so strange, and the sky was
swathed in dark clouds.
Glory guessed that she'd been knocked out
for a few hours at least.
The rotten eggs smell was thick in the
air.
Sinister, right?
Kinkachu said in her ear, and glory
jumped.
Who would actually want to live here?
I don't get it.
Who does live here?
Glory wondered.
The talons of peace?
Is this where they hide?
And then she realized that parts of the
landscape were moving, and they weren't
rocks after all.
They were dragons, black dragons, with
silver scales glittering under their
wings.
She could see at least a 100 of them
scattered across the mountain, and
several more flying above it.
She inhaled sharply, and regretted it, as
sulfur filled her nose.
I know where we are.
This is the secret home of the night
wings.
Chapter 21.
Glory turned to the dragonette and waved
her bound claws of the gag around her
mouth.
Oh my gosh, said Kinkachu, staring at
Glory's scales as they changed color.
You're excited about something.
I wonder what?
Ooh, and curious.
Sure, of course you are.
You must have lots of questions.
I sure had lots of questions when I got
here.
Hey, now you're...
Frustrated, super frustrated and getting
mad.
Wow, what are you so exasperated.
Glory shoved her aside and marched back
into the cave.
Oh, you're mad at me, said Kinkachu
trotting along behind her.
I'm used to that.
The cave was not very big, ending
abruptly at a steep drop off at the back
Glory stared down into a pitch black
abyss.
With no fire, and no ability to see in
the dark.
No rain wing would get very close to that
even if her wings were free, glory
wouldn't go near it.
That's how I visit the other prisoners
Kingachu said.
All their caves, and the one I'm supposed
to stay in open out onto this.
Glory looked at the dragonette with new
respect.
Kinkachu's wings weren't bound, but they
were tiny.
Most 3 year old dragons couldn't fly for
long without needing a rest.
She couldn't have known how long she'd
have to fly when she 1st jumped into the
darkness, looking for other prisoners.
That was a special kind of brave.
And crazy.
Kinkatu tilted her head at glory.
I have no idea what that color means, she
said.
Wow, you really are different.
She reached up and tugged on the ropes
around Glory's wings.
But this is the same, she sighed.
I can't get any of them off.
I' sorry.
It's some kind of super impossible knot.
Glory held up her claws.
Thick canvas covered them, tied together
with another robe around each forearm.
Here too, Kikachu said, pointing to the
knot, see how tight that is?
Glory squinted at it.
She didn't know much about knots.
She nodded to Kingaju's talons, and the
little dragonette shook her head.
They're not sharp enough to cut through
the rope.
I've tried.
Kinkachu sliced one tiny claw across the
rope, but it didn't even look frayed.
Glory lashed her tail.
It is frustrating.
Kinkachu agreed.
Stupid night wings.
But if we tried to escape, they'd read
our minds or foresee it and stop us
anyway, right?
Glory discovered that she could still
growl.
Does that mean you want to try?
Kinkaju asked, perking up.
Her ruff flared around her face.
Because nobody else wants to try escaping
but I so do, because, oh my gosh, you
haven't even seen how awful the food is
here.
They keep bringing us horrible dead
things.
I mean, things that have been dead for
weeks, I think.
It is mega gross and makes us totally
sick when we eat it.
There's no fruit at all.
Taper finally just let himself starve to
death.
It's so awful.
I try to eat as little as I can.
How am I supposed to make an escape plan
with a dragonette who won't shut up?
Glory wondered.
When I can't even ask her any questions.
Such as, what did the night wings want
with the rain wings anyway?
Why were they kidnapping them and holding
them prisoner?
What did Deathbringer have to do with
this plan?
And why had he told them to stop?
Confused?
Kinkachu guessed, pointing at glory
scales, and... frustrated again.
I need a color for stop that, Glory
thought.
Something flapped outside the cave
entrance.
Kinkachu turned toward the sound, then
winced, and closed her eyes.
Glory pushed past her and peered out.
Three night wings flew over the lava
river, and disappeared into another cave
not far from glories.
A few moments later, they reappeared
dragging a limp rain wing behind them.
The rain wings scales were a heavy gray
like rain clouds.
It was a color of sadness glory hadn't
seen on any other rain wing.
He was conscious, but neither struggled
nor helped the night wings.
He just hung between them, like he'd
given up completely.
Glory thought of Jamboo's vibrantly
joyful scales and felt a stab of anger.
At the night wings, for ripping innocent
dragons from their homes, and at the
other rain wings, for letting this happen
to their friends, without even noticing
or caring that they were gone.
The black dragons lifted the rain wing
over the river and carried him up the
slope of the mountain, letting his tail
bump across the rocks.
Glory watched until they all vanished
into a sort of fortress halfway up the
mountain.
It looked like a jumbled pile of rocks, so
she hadn't realized it was a building
before.
Poor Gibbon, Kinkachu said.
They take him all the time.
I guess his venom is way more interesting
than mine or something.
Glory whirled to stare at her.
Oh yeah, Kinkaju said.
When they take you up there, try
pretending your venom doesn't work right
or something.
That's all they want us to do.
Melt things.
It's so weird.
Like, can't they melt their own things?
So far, I've melted an orange and a pile
of leaves.
They told me to melt this metal claw
thing too, but of course that's stupid.
Our venom doesn't work on non-living
stuff.
And then they had me spit some venom into
a bowl, and who knows what they want with
that?
I don't get it.
They're studying us.
Glory realized, or at least they're
studying our venom.
She turned and began pacing the length of
the cave.
Are they hoping to use it themselves?
As a weapon?
But the night wings don't fight.
They stay out of the war.
So who do they need weapons for?
Are they planning to join the war soon?
On whose side?
Blisters, of course, she thought
immediately, smacking herself in the head
with her tail.
That's why they wanted us to choose her
for the prophecy.
But why join the war now?
And why torture rain wings for their
venom, when night wings have their own
ever so special powers they never shut up
about?
That must be what thinking hard looks
like.
Kinkachu said, hopping onto a boulder and
watching glory with great interest.
Your scales are all kinds of colors right
now.
I've never seen another rain wing do
that.
Oh, I wish you could talk to me.
Me too.
Glory thought.
Maybe we could escape together.
And then you could be my teacher, Kinkaju
said.
I swear I'm not as awful as everyone says
but we'd have to get you across the lava
and then we'd have to find the tunnel
back to the rainforest, and then we'd
have to get past the guards there, and
then we'd have to get all your bindings
off.
Or maybe we'd have to do that first.
Actually, that would make more sense.
Because then you could fly and fight and
stuff.
But I have no idea how to do any of
that.
She stopped.
Her wings drooping, and suddenly looked
very young.
Glory had been wondering why Kinkachu
didn't escape on her own, but if she
didn't know where the tunnel was, and
there were guards to fight along away, it
was a tall order for a little dragon
especially when failure would surely mean
she'd end up bound and gagged like the
other rain wings.
Maybe I could find something sharp enough
to cut the ropes, Kinkaju said
brightening again, like a really sharp
rock, or, well, there's not much around
here except rocks.
Oh, or I could check one of the really
disgusting dead things for sharp bones
when our dinner comes.
That would be pretty gross, though.
Maybe you should do that.
Glory thumbed her tail on the ground to
get Kinkaju's attention.
She pointed to her mouth, then her
stomach, then her mouth again, and tried
to turn her scales the color of
curiosity.
You're asking me a question, Kinkachu
said, with great delight.
Wait, let me guess.
You're...
Hungry.
Glory frowned and tabbed the rope around
her mouth, pointed to the cave opening
flapped her arms like wings, pointed to
her stomach, and pointed to the rope
again.
Kinkaju furrowed her brow.
Something about the night wings and
food.
Oh, oh, I know.
You want to know if they take off the
metal band when they feed us?
Am I right?
She turned toward the cave entrance as
Glory nodded.
I guess you're about to find out.
The little dragonette darted over the
drop and vanished into one of the gaps in
the far wall.
Glory could see her eyes shining in the
dark, still watching.
Four night wings ducked into the cave, one
after the other, crowding the narrow
space.
Glory held her ground and glared at
them.
At least there was no sign of Morrow
seer.
She was safer as an ordinary rain wing
prisoner than she would be if they found
out she was the dragonette messing up
their prophecy.
The one they'd already tried to kill more
than once.
The last dragon who came in had a
disturbing scar twisted across his
snout.
Strange bubbles, a deformed skin
protruded from his jawline, and one of
his nostrils was sealed shut, so he
breathed in a loud, snuffly way.
When he spoke, Glory recognized the
hoarse voice of the dragon who'd captured
her.
He was the one in the forest, she
realized, listening to his peculiar
breathing.
The creature in the dark, the one who ate
the dead sloth.
Looks normal to me, he said gruffly.
One of the others gave him a scathing
look.
On the contrary, she said, there's
clearly something wrong with this one.
What do you mean?
said a 3rd dragon.
Observe her scales.
Every other rain wing we've picked up
turned instantly green, the color that
seems to indicate fear, but this one, I
don't know what it indicates, but I am
seeing shades of red and orange.
Perhaps a little black here and here.
The Nightwing used a thin stick to point
to spots on glory's wings, with clinical
detachment.
She could have been describing a
moderately interesting beetle for all the
emotion in her voice.
So she's matching the environment, said
that they're a dragon.
That's something they do too, isn't it?
Glory narrowed her eyes at them and
turned a deliberate, violent shade of
purple.
Oh my, said the unemotional dragon.
We should take her to the lab immediately
for closer study.
I strongly recommend not feeding her and
not touching that gag until we know more
about her.
Bosh. said the scarred Nightwing.
All rain wings are the same.
Rotten and useless.
Besides, Queen Battle Winner doesn't like
to have her orders questioned.
The 4th dragon spoke up.
He stepped forward with something furry
and horrible smelling in his talons.
It's feeding time now.
You can go ask her if this one should go
to the lab afterward.
I will. she said stepping back.
I've registered my concern here.
You do what you like.
The Nightwing slid out of the cave and
flew off.
Leaving only 3 for me to fight.
Glory thought.
You may have studied the venom of
pacifist, well trained, frightened rain
wings, but you've never studied me.
The scarred dragon produced a long spear
from a sheath on his back.
The sharp end had 3 twisted claw like
points, and glinted evilly in the reddish
light.
He hefted it in his talons and flicked
his black tongue at glory, as if he were
hoping she'd give him an excuse to hurt
her.
He hates us, she thought, meeting his
eyes.
It's personal for him.
Her gaze shifted to his scar.
Ah, that looks like it could have been
caused by a venom strike.
I wonder which rain wing was bold enough
to do that.
With a shiver.
She realized he was the 1st dragon she'd
seen who'd survived a venom attack, which
meant it was possible to survive a venom
attack, which meant Queen Scarlet really
might still be alive.
The dead pile of fur landed by her feet
and the other 2 guards pulled out long
spears of their own.
Lori stared down at the meal they were
offering.
Kinkaju wasn't exaggerating.
It did smell horrible, and long dead.
She could barely tell what it had once
been, a muskrat, perhaps, a nasty bite on
its side, looked a lot like the one on
the sloth by the river, black and
infected.
One of the guards leaned forward, and
jabbed his spear toward her face.
Glory leaped back with a muffled snarl.
Hold still if you want to eat.
Growled the scarred dragon, or else
starve.
We're fine with that too.
Glory clenched her talons and eyed the
spear as it bobbed closer.
It was hard to see exactly what the guard
did, but she felt the spear points hook
into some kind of latch on the metal band
then twist and pull.
The clamp slipped open and off, and the
night wings all jumped back with their
spears up.
But not fast enough.
Chapter 22.
Glory lunged forward with her fangs bared
and seized the closest spear in her
talons, she yanked it toward her, throwing
the guard off balance, and shot a jet of
venom that missed his face, but sprayed
across his wings and back.
He let go of the spear, and stumbled
toward the cave entrance with a shriek of
pain.
The scarred dragon dropped his spear.
He shot out of the cave, shoving aside
his injured tribe made as he went by.
Glory whipped toward the last guard and
tried to turn the spear on him, but her
wrapped talons were clumsy, and she
fumbled the weapon.
He darted toward her, stabbing for her
neck.
Glory hissed a spray of venom at him, but
to her surprise, he dodged and rolled
under it.
A moment later, he knocked her over and
pinned her face down.
He shoved her snout into the rocky floor
and pressed the points of the spear into
her neck.
Nice try, rain wing, he snarled, but it's
not that easy to fool a...
His weight suddenly disappeared from her
back as his howls echoed around the
cave.
Glory leaped to her feet and found
Kinkaju beside her, with her front talons
pressed over her snout.
I can't believe I did that.
Kinkachu yelped.
Oh my gosh, look at him.
The night wing staggered into the wall
clawing at his neck.
Kinkachu had hit him with only a few
droplets of venom, but those were smoking
and bubbling on his scales.
He turned back to the 2 rain wings with
pain crazed rage in his eyes.
I'm sorry, Kinkachu cried.
Oh, that looks like it hurts so much.
Glory yanked the spear out of the guard's
claws and shoved him over the drop off at
the back of the cave.
She could hear him flapping and
blundering around in the dark, still
yowling.
But Kinkachu said.
He'll be fine.
Once he remembers he has fire, Glory said
we should be gone by then.
I didn't realize you meant escape, now
Kinkachu said.
I mean, like, right now?
That is so crazy.
You're crazy.
Her voice was edgy and manic, but her
scales were bright yellow with
excitement.
Tone it down a bit, can you?
Glory said, nodding at the little
dragonette's wings.
We don't need to alert the whole mountain
as we escape.
Try looking like them.
She turned her own scales the same
gleaming black as the night wings
outside.
And I'm glory, by the way.
Got it, Kinkachu said, flipping her
tail.
Inky Black spread across her scales, as
if someone was pouring the night sky onto
her.
But how do we get you over the lava
river?
Whoops.
Glory had forgotten about that.
Or rather, she hadn't thought that far
ahead.
She'd seen an opportunity to use her
venom, and took it without thinking, Who
am I?
Tsunami?
She scolded herself.
Worse yet, she knew the scarred night
wing would be back any moment with
reinforcements.
She clamped her teeth down on the canvas
that covered her talons with a violent
shake of her head.
She ripped the cloth until it tore
loose.
As soon as her claws were free, she
seized a spear and turned it on the ropes
wrapped around her body.
The guards are coming.
Kinkaju said anxiously.
Pretend you're a night wing dragonette
and stall them, Glory said.
She jabbed the spear point awkwardly at
one of the ropes, and stabbed herself in
the underbelly.
With a hiss, she hefted the weapon and
tried again.
Yes, all right, stall them.
No problem, Kingaju said.
She darted toward the cave entrance.
The 1st night when Glory had attacked, was
lying halfway across the opening, moaning
softly and writhing, as if he were trying
to wriggle out of his own skin, Kinkaju
blinked at him for a moment, then lifted
one of his wings so it draped across her
shoulders and back, covering the brass
band around her neck.
She leaned a little way out of the cave
and looked up.
Quick, she shouted suddenly, making glory
jump.
She attacked us and escaped.
We saw her go that way.
She pointed down the mountain.
Hurry, don't stop.
She was flying super fast.
No, no, I'll take care of him.
Go after her.
She's getting away.
The whoosh of wings shot by overhead
sending a blast of hot air back into the
cave.
At the same time, Glory finally hooked
the spear into the knot of the rope.
With a twist, she managed to saw the
sharp points across the fibers until they
split.
But as that rope slid off, she realized
there were 4 more separately knotted
around her.
I'll never get these all off before they
realize it was a trick and come back, she
thought.
There had to be another way across the
river.
Maybe there was something they could use
as a stepping stone.
She hurried to the opening and stared out
looking for large boulders.
Kingaju watched her trustingly.
A squadron of 5 night wings was flapping
away down the mountain toward a black
sand beach and an expanse of gray, stormy
water.
Only 5 night wings to stop me?
Glory thought.
She glanced up the mountain, but there
was no sign of an alarm. or extra forces
mobilizing.
I guess they're not really that worried
about me escaping, she said uneasily.
I'm getting pretty worried about it
though.
Kinkachu offered.
Hey, Glory said, poking the wounded
guard.
You can still fly, can't you?
He flinched away from her.
I can't, he moaned.
Everything hurts.
It didn't even look that bad.
He'd avoided the worst of the spray, and
most of the damage was along one side of
his back.
You're going to hurt a lot more unless
you carry me over this lava, Glory said
or cut these ropes off for me.
She bared her fangs at him, and he threw
his wings over his head, scuttling
backward into the cave.
Actually, said a new voice, I have a
better offer.
Glory whirled around as a black dragon
descended from the sky and gave her a
cheeky grin.
Hello, Glory, said Death Bringer.
Chapter 23.
Don't give me that smug face.
Glory snapped.
This isn't my smug face.
It's my heroic face, Deathbringer said.
And how funny is this?
First, I was your prisoner.
Now you're mine.
Perhaps you haven't heard what I do to
dragons who try to keep me prisoner, Glory
said with a hiss.
All right, stop it, you two.
Clay flapped up behind Deathbringer and
landed beside glory.
Clay, glory cried.
What are you doing here?
We came to rescue you, he said, nudging
her wing with his.
Aren't you pleased?
I'm right in the middle of rescuing
myself, Glory said.
She was having a hard time keeping her
scales black when the side of clay made
her feel as pink as her ridiculous
brother.
Maybe some other time.
Don't listen to her.
Kinkaju cried.
We definitely need rescuing.
Please, rescue us.
How did you even get here?
Gloria asked.
I mean, how did you know to look for me
here?
Clay nodded a death bringer, who flicked
his tail and managed to look even more
smug.
He talked me into it.
When you didn't come back, he told me he
knew where you'd gone, and that he'd help
me find you if I set him free.
Sounds like a trick, Glory said, eyeing
Deathbringer suspiciously.
Why would he work against his fellow
night wings?
Was this a way to get clay into their
clutches as well?
Let's escape 1st and ask skeptical
questions later, said Kinkaju.
She jumped into the air, wings flapping.
Sensible Dragonette, said Deathbringer.
He gave glory an unreadable look, teasing
but worried, and self satisfied, but
sweet all at once.
You can express your undying gratitude to
me later.
I'll wait.
Go ahead and hold your breath, Glory
suggested.
Up you go.
Clay said.
He spread his wings so glory could climb
onto his back.
She hesitated for a moment.
Part of her said, you can do this
yourself.
You don't need help.
Just get your wings free and save your
own scales.
But there wasn't time.
And although she couldn't trust
Deathbringer, There was no one more
trustworthy than clay.
She clambered onto his back, still
holding the spear and awkwardly adjusting
her balance without her wings.
He was in the air almost before she could
get her talons around his neck.
She slipped sideways, and nearly knocked
him into the lava.
Clay's tail brushed the bubbling red hot
river below, and he lurched upward with a
hiss of pain.
It's all right, he said quickly, it'll
heal fast.
Don't worry.
Fire resistant scales like clays would
definitely have come in handy here, Glory
thought, glancing down as he flew
higher.
She saw several other caves overlooking
the lava river, but no snouts sticking
out.
We have to get the other rain wings, she
shouted in clays ear.
We have to set them all free.
Now?
he asked.
We'll be lucky if we make it out without
getting caught.
I can't just leave them here. she cried.
I promised Mangrove I'd find Orchid.
And you did, he said.
Now you know where she is.
We can come back and get her, with
backup.
He glanced over his shoulder and put on a
burst of speed.
Lots and lots of backup.
Glory looked behind them as well, and saw
a cluster of night wings standing on a
high rocky ledge.
Three of them were pointing at clay and
shouting to the others.
Black scaled heads were turning toward
the sky all across the volcano.
She also saw Kinkachu flapping madly to
keep up with them.
What she didn't see was a certain
dangerous know it all assassin.
Deathbringer's not with us, she called.
Of course not, Clay called back.
He swooped down between 2 curved stone
columns and banked right.
His tribe can't know he helped us.
Glory thought uneasily of the dragon
she'd wounded back in the prison cave.
Surely he had seen Deathbringer and
overheard their conversation, but really
that was Deathbringer's problem.
What happened to his mission?
The one about killing us, remember?
Maybe he doesn't want to anymore, Clay
said with a shrug.
Suspicious glory thought.
Or as Kinkaju would say, mega
suspicious.
And yet she also felt a weird loss, like
she wished she'd had a chance to say
goodbye.
She twisted to look back again, but he
really wasn't there.
Oh well.
Maybe the next time he shows up to kill
me.
She realized that Clay was winging
rapidly toward the black sand beach that
ringed the island at the base of the
volcano.
Twisted, leafless trees grew on the
volcano's slopes, like bones sticking out
of the dirt.
Beyond the beach, the ocean roared and
churned, gray and unfriendly, and
speckled with foam.
Um, clay, Glory said.
We're not flying back to the rainforest
across that ocean, are we?
No way, Clay said.
I don't even know which way the rest of
Pyria is, or how far.
Do you?
Nope, Glory said, but it makes sense to
me that the night wings live on an island
one that's not on any maps.
I would have thought they'd pick a nicer
one though.
This place is ghastly.
She coughed. wondering if the smell of
rotten eggs would ever clear out of her
snout.
Clay dove toward a cave halfway up a
small rocky cliff at one end of the
beach.
The passage to the rainforest is in there
he called.
Get ready to fight.
Always, ready, panted Kinkaju beside
them.
Glory opened her mouth and tasted the
smoky air.
She couldn't see any guards on the beach
below.
Didn't you have to fight them on your way
out of the tunnel?
she asked.
No, Death Bringer went ahead of me and
distracted them, but they'll be back by
now.
Also, Kinkaju gasped.
Company, behind.
Glory didn't have to look back.
She'd already heard the wing beats, and
she didn't really want to know exactly
how many night wings were on their
tails.
She gripped the spear in her claws.
Imagining Morrow's sear on the pointy end
of it.
The cave yawned wide in front of them.
Clay didn't slow down as he shot between
the rocky walls.
Glory blinked, her eyes adjusting to the
darkness, and then she saw the light of a
fire glowing up ahead.
Four night wings were gathered around the
fire, each of them carrying one of the
wicked looking spears.
The wrongness, feeling emanated from a
perfectly circular hole in the rock wall
behind them, and they were clearly not
planning on letting anyone get to it.
We have to get past them fast, Glory
thought, or else we'll have all the ones
behind us to deal with as well.
The 1st guard saw them coming, jumped up
and slammed into clay.
Glory catapulted over his head, dropping
the spear, and just missing the fire as
she crashed into one of the other
dragons.
Talons seized her tail and wings, and
more talons fumbled for her snout, not
happening.
Glory thought.
No one would muzzle her weapon again.
Her jaw sprang open, and she swung her
neck around, spraying venom at the guard
who was trying to hold her down.
Black droplets spattered across his chest
screaming, he leaped back and stumbled
into the fire, then fled toward the beach
with smoke rising from his scales.
The other 2 guards pounced on glory from
behind, wrestling her back down again.
They were both huge, the size of Morrow
Seer, with metal armor buckled over their
underbellies and strange helmets
protecting their snouts.
Glory's face was pressed into the
ground.
She lashed her tail furiously, trying to
smack them the way tsunami would have, but
one of the guards stepped on it and
pinned it down.
Glory struggled against the weight of the
2 dragons.
Above her, Clay was battling the 1st
night wing.
Their claws clashed, and bouts of fire
blasted through the air.
Kinkachoo.
Glory thought.
Where had she gone?
Had she made it into the tunnel?
The tiny dragonette suddenly popped up
behind the guards, holding the spear
Glory had dropped.
She swung it hard, and smacked one of the
night wings on the head with a blunt
end.
He tottered sideways with a yell, then
whipped around with a murderous gleam in
his eyes.
Kingajou!
Glory shouted.
Use your venom.
But, Kinkaju said, dodging a swipe of the
night wings claws.
I don't, or the spear.
The pointy end this time.
Kinkaju looked down at the spear with a
surprised expression.
She hefted it, and jabbed it at a guard
as he came at her again.
He knocked it aside and thrust his own
spear at her.
Kinkaju yelped, and Glory saw a streak of
blood slashed across her neck.
Glory clenched her talons with rage.
How dare he?
Kinkaju was just a tiny dragonette.
Not only that, she was a rain wing, which
meant she'd never been trained to fight.
There was just one guard holding glory
down at the moment.
She thought of Sonny's tricks from battle
training and stopped struggling.
On top of her, the guard let out a
pleased hiss.
Glory let her scales ripple into the
color of the rocks below her.
Foolish rain wing, hissed the guard.
I can still feel you.
I can still see your wing bindings.
Glory knew that, but she was hoping the
strangeness of holding something he
couldn't see would make him slower.
Taking a deep breath, she suddenly
twisted herself into a tight spiral.
The night wing's talons slipped on her
scales, and she was able to get her tail
free for a moment, long enough to swing
it around and jab him sharply in the
middle of his back.
Sonny loved this move, and at 1st none of
them had understood why.
If she'd had a poisonous barb on her tail
like other sand wings, it would have been
terrifying, but with a harmless tail.
What was the point?
Then they'd each experienced it, and
discovered there was something freaky and
unsettling about it.
It felt like being hit by lightning at
just the wrong spot.
It was as if their scales knew they could
have been badly injured.
If there had been poison at the tip of
that tail, it would have paralyzed their
spines instantly and killed them a few
moments later.
So it was weirdly chilling, and an
effective distraction in the middle of a
fight.
Glory had no idea if this would work when
a rain wing did it to a night wing, but
it was worth a try.
The guard stiffened, as if he'd just been
shocked by one of the electric eels in
Queen Coral's prison.
It was only for a moment, but in that
moment, Glory was able to throw him offer
and free her snout.
She went straight for Kinkaju's attacker
shooting venom at all the exposed scales
she could see.
He screamed and slammed back into the
rocks.
Glory saw another gash along Kinkachu's
side, the little dragonette was shaking
and her scales were ripples of pale green
and white.
Claws seized Glory's tail before she
could get to Kinkaju.
Get out of here.
Glory shouted, pointing at the hole.
Go. Kinkaju hesitated, looking beyond
glory at the night wing guard.
For a moment, glory was certain that
she'd disobey and stayed to help fight
but then, without arguing, Kinkachu
darted for the tunnel and vanished into
the darkness.
Well, good, glory thought, as a spear
viciously clocked her in the head, someone
being sensible for once, unlike my
friends.
She tried to turn around, but the night
wing threw her into the wall.
Stars spun dizzily in Glory's vision.
Don't pass out.
If the Nightwings recaptured her.
She'd never get another chance to use her
venom and escape.
They'd probably let her starve to death
instead.
Blurrily, she saw clay suddenly drop out
of the air, and her heart leaped into her
throat.
Was he hurt?
She staggered a step toward him, but a
sharp pain in her back leg stopped her.
The guard had stabbed her with his
spear.
Glory hissed angrily, and lunged for the
spear as the guard pulled it back.
He stabbed it at her again, violent and
fast, and she felt it scratch her
underbelly like a sharp line of bee
stings.
At the same time, Clay landed right in
the middle of the fire.
Flames licked at his underbelly and wings
and a scorched smell filled the cave.
Glorious scales hurt just looking at
him.
Even if he healed fast.
She knew his skin was burning right now.
Clenching his jaw.
Clay crouched, and picked up smoldering
coals from the fire in his talons.
The night wing in the air above him
didn't have time to figure out what was
coming.
Clay flung the coals right in the guard's
face, and started grabbing and throwing
more as the guard frantically clawed at
his snout.
Clay!
Glory yelled, as her own opponent flung
her off balance, Glory fell backward, and
the night wing was on her in an instant
wrapping his strong talons around her
snout to force it shut.
Red hot coals came flying through the
air.
Most bounced off the dragon's armor, and
one ricocheted painfully against glory's
bound wings, but a few found the gaps in
the armor and slid inside.
The guard let go of glory and started
clawing at his armor, howling with pain.
Glory had just made it to her feet again
when someone grabbed her shoulders.
She whipped around with a hiss and barely
managed to stop herself from shooting
venom and clay's face.
Quick, he cried, shoving her onto his
back.
She grabbed his neck again as he bunched
his legs and flung himself over the
guards at the hole.
One of the injured night wings lunged for
Clay's tail, but when he saw glory
opening her mouth, he flinched away.
Clay dove into the tunnel, which spiraled
up and around.
Glory held on tight, burying her head in
his scales as they flew.
She could hear rain falling up ahead.
Almost there.
She thought.
Almost safe, for now.
Chapter 24.
They emerged into a sun shower.
Rain dripped down through the leaves, but
shafts of sunlight still dappled the
trees, reflecting flashes of light off
the droplets, and catching rainbows in
the spider webs and waterfalls.
Clay tipped Glory off onto the ground, and
flopped into the nearest mud puddle
breathing heavily.
She sat up, shaking herself, and looked
up at the tunnel to the Nightwing
Island.
There was no sound of pursuit, no
thumping wing beats, no black snout
crawling out to continue the battle.
It took her a moment to realize how close
they were to the other passage, the one
that went to the desert.
The 1st tunnel was in a boulder.
This one went straight into the 2nd dark
tree, on the other side of the stream.
She wouldn't have noticed the hole in the
tree trunk if she hadn't been looking for
it.
It was above her eye level, carved into
the tree at a height where most dragons
would have to look up to see it.
It was as dark as the tree itself
disappearing into the wood, and it pulsed
with such a feeling of not supposed to be
there, that she wanted to look away the
moment her eyes came anywhere near it.
A 2nd tunnel, she said to Clay.
That is so weird.
Do you think there are more?
Wake me when you figure it out, Clay
said.
No, hang on.
Never wake me up again.
I'm going to sleep for a few 100 years.
He scooped up 2 talon fulls of mud and
poured it onto his head, closing his eyes
with a sigh.
Kinkaju shot out of the treetops and
cannoned into glory.
I'm so glad you're all right, she
yelped.
I didn't want to leave you there, but I
was so scared.
You did the right thing.
Glory said.
Ducking to avoid the spear, Kinkaju was
still swinging around.
Here give me that.
And go look in that hole to see if
anyone's following us.
Kinkaju's eyes went wide.
But what if they are?
Then what do I do?
Scare them back to their hideous island
Glory said, poking the spear at her
bindings.
I'll come help you as soon as I get my
wings free.
And if I can figure it out, I'll use this
thing to get your neck band off too.
She nodded at the metal ring on Kinkaju.
The little dragonette shuffled her feet.
But, um, listen, I...
I'm not sure I want to use my venom on
any more dragons, it made me feel really
really awful.
Then just pretend you're going to, Glory
said.
She nudged the dragonette toward the
tree.
Sit in the tunnel entrance with your
mouth open and try to look sinister, all
right?
Kingaju perked up.
Sure, I bet I can look sinister, super
sinister.
Just watch me.
She flapped up to the hole, curled her
tail around her talons, opened her mouth
and squinted fiercely down the tunnel.
She looked more like a decorative
doorstop than a guard, but it would have
to do for now.
Glory kept one eye on her as she worked
to free her wings.
It was a little unsettling that no one
had chased them through the tunnel.
Maybe the Nightwing thought there'd be
more dragons waiting on this end to fight
them off.
How long had she been gone?
She squinted at the angle of the sunbeams
and realized it must be morning.
It felt like she'd been trapped in the
night kingdom for a month, but it had
been only a day.
She had one rope left to untie when she
heard voices approaching through the
forest.
This is a terrible idea.
Can't we discuss it like sensible
dragons?
There's no time.
Clay and Glory have been kidnapped by
that Nightwing assassin.
I have to save them.
But we don't know that he took them, and
we don't know that he went through the
tunnel or where they might be in the
kingdom of sand, and we're over here
Glory called.
There was a pause, followed by some
vigorous flapping.
Starflight and tsunami burst out of the
trees, and soared down over the stream to
land beside clay.
A few moments later, Sonny caught up to
them.
Glory's sloth was sitting on her head
clutching Sonny's horns with a startled
expression.
Oh, I knew you were all right, Sonny said
brightly.
She hesitated, squinting at clay and the
mud dripping over his snout.
Her eyes took in the wounds slashed along
glory's scales.
Um, are you all right?
Of course, Clay said, squishing himself
farther down into the mud puddle.
Silver leaped from Sonny onto Glory's
neck and started tugging on Glory's ears
warbling a furry complaint.
Glory caught her between her claws and
stroked her head.
Sorry, she whispered, but it wouldn't
have been safe for you.
Irv.
The soft objected.
Where were you?
Tsunami cried.
Death bringers escaped.
He could be anywhere.
He could jump out and try to kill you at
any time.
Actually, he's in there.
Glory said, pointing up at the tree.
Her friends all crane their necks to
appear at the hole.
Another tunnel?
Sonny said.
She glanced across the stream and
shivered.
I mean, I noticed the weird feeling, but
I thought it was still coming from that
one.
Where does this one go?
Starflight asked.
Glory tilted her head at him.
It goes to the night kingdom, she said.
Starflight inhaled softly and stared up
at the tree.
She saw the anxiety and curiosity
tingling through him as clearly as if his
scales could change color too.
His tribe was through there, and his
original home.
She wondered what he would think of the
island, the smell, the scorched air and
unfriendly rocks, the horrible smoky
cloud that hung over everything, and the
fact that his fellow night wings were
kidnapping rain wings for their venom.
All things considered, she thought she'd
rather have her own tribe of lazy but not
evil dragons.
Listen, she said.
You may want to sit down for this.
They decided to leave tsunami and clay
guarding the tunnel.
Don't let anyone come through there, Glory
said fiercely.
If you even see a hint of a snout poke
out, you jab it with this thing as hard
as you can.
She handed the spear to tsunami.
No problem, Tsunami said with relish.
She spun the spear between her talons.
We'll be back soon, Glory said, with an
army of rain wings.
Tsunami and Starflight exchanged glances
and glory flared her rough at them.
I know what you're thinking, she snapped
so don't say it.
It's just Starflight said.
I mean, is that a good idea?
Rain wings aren't very army-like.
The night wings would crush them easily.
Especially if any of them look into the
future and see you coming, Sonny said.
They didn't foresee me escaping, Glory
pointed out.
They're not all powerful.
We can stop them and rescue the others.
Maybe it's a misunderstanding.
Starflight said, resting his front talons
on the tree.
Maybe if I went through and talked to
them, Then maybe you'd end up in a lovely
lava prison too, Glory said, or dead.
Let's not forget that you might be one of
the dragon's death bringer was sent to
kill.
She spread her wings, letting them
shimmer into the colors of the cobweb
rainbows.
But feel free to stand here worrying
about it all day.
I'm going back to get my tribe, with or
without you.
She beckoned to Kinkaju and leaped into
the air.
It was a relief to use her own wings
again.
She stretched them wide as they soared up
to the highest branches.
Silver clung to her shoulders, making
happy furry noises.
Kinkaju took the lead with an eager flick
of her tail.
Glory had figured out how to get the band
off with a night wing spear.
It had left a painful looking dent in
Kinkaju's neck, but the little dragon was
too happy to mind.
Bursts of pink and yellow spiraled
through her scales, getting brighter the
closer they got to the village.
Have they been looking for me every day?
The dragonette asked, looping back to
circle around glory.
Did Bromelia just have a heart attack
when I disappeared?
I can imagine her face.
Kinkaju pursed her snout in a hilariously
accurate impression of Bromeliad.
That dragonette got herself kidnapped on
purpose.
She's always been trouble.
Kinkaju giggled.
I hope she wore out her wings looking for
me.
Grumpy old cow.
Gosh, won't everyone be excited when I
finally turn up?
Um, Glory said.
Don't be upset if there's no welcome home
party.
There's coconut.
Kinkaju cried, spotting a small dragon
lounging in a hammock on the outskirts of
the village.
Aw, look how exhausted he is.
We took gliding lessons together all last
year.
I bet he's been helping to search for
me.
Coconut, it's me.
I'm back.
She swooped up to the hammock and poked
it vigorously with her tail until the
emerald green dragon inside sat up
blinking, hmm?
He said.
What?
I'm back.
Kinkaju said, wrapping her wings around
him and nearly knocking him out of the
hammock.
I'm all right.
I made it home.
Coconut disentangled himself politely.
Kinkaju?
He squinted at her.
You went somewhere?
I've been gone for almost 3 whole weeks
Kinkaju said.
Her smile faded as the other dragon shook
his head.
Didn't you miss me?
Um, he said, I've been very busy.
I bet, Glory said disgustedly.
You, be at Magnificence Pavilion in one
hour, and bring every other rain wing you
can find.
We are having a tribe meeting.
Oh, what?
Coconut said.
And if you're not there, I will know, and
I will personally come tie you into this
hammock, so you're stuck here forever
Glory said.
Go start telling everyone, go.
Coconut flailed out of the hammock and
flapped away, looking confused.
Glory steered Kinkaju toward the center
of the village.
The dragonette's wings were drooping and
speckled with a blue gray.
Disappointing young dragons who count on
them, Glory said. seems to be a rain wing
specialty.
Someone must have looked for me?
said Kinkachu.
Yes, I did, Glory pointed out.
She saw the Queen's tree house up ahead
and veered that way.
Starfight and Sunny hadn't caught up
yet.
Maybe they were busy talking about how
this plan of glories would fail.
Or maybe they were checking on webs again
as if that was at all important compared
to saving the rain wings.
The line to see magnificent was shorter
today.
Only 2 dragons sat on the waiting
platform, and neither of them looked
particularly upset.
Glory swooped right past them and dove
through the vine curtain, skidding to a
stop on the wood floor.
The rain wing queen jumped, and her sloth
leaped onto her head, looking startled.
I found them, Gloria announced.
She glanced at the dragons magnificent
was meeting with.
A young rain wing whose blue green scales
looked like he was trying to match
tsunamis, complete with white dots to
mimic her pearls, and a shrunken old
dragon with a silvery tinge to his ruff.
I found the missing rain wings, Your
Majesty.
Oh, call me Maggie, said the queen.
What missing rain wings?
The ones you sent me to find?
Glory said impatiently, like Orchid, and
Queen Splendor, and Kinkajou here?
Oh, said magnificent.
A shimmer of dark purple rippled through
her scales.
Marvelous, I'm so pleased.
Do go tell mangrove.
It'll be so nice not to have to deal with
that headache anymore.
She turned back to the other rain wings.
No, no, listen, Glory said.
They were abducted.
We have to go rescue them.
Magnificent, blinked at Kinkaju.
Except her, Glory said.
I mean, we got her out, but the others
are still there.
We need to get the tribe together and
organize an expedition to save them.
An expedition?
Magnificent echoed.
Her eyes wandered to a lizard that was
crawling slowly through the window.
Save them from what?
Asked the blue green rain wing.
From the night wings, said glory.
They've been kidnapping rain wings and
holding them prisoner, she hissed
remembering the gray dragon's tail
thumping sadly along the ground as the
night wings carried him off.
You want us to fight other dragons?
said the queen.
How would we do that?
Glory clutched her head.
She knew her scales were vibrating with
furious sunset colors, but she needed all
her energy for arguing with a queen.
With your venom, she said slowly.
With your camouflage, with your claws and
teeth, with anything that will save your
fellow tribe mates.
We are not fighters, the queen said, as
if she were explaining the 3 moons to a
very small dragonette.
Rain wings aren't built for it.
We are a peaceful tribe.
So what do you suggest?
Glory snapped.
Ask the night wings nicely to give back
the dragons they stole?
Because kidnapping dragons certainly
makes them seem like a pretty reasonable
tribe, open to negotiations and all
that.
Queen Magnificent examined her claws for
a moment, then picked up her sloth and
scratched it under its chin.
Well, let's think about this sensibly.
Do we really need to get them back?
Glory felt as if she'd just been dropped
in the Night Wings volcano.
She stared at the queen.
You mean, you would leave them there?
Whoa, said the blue dragon, staring at
Glory's scales.
I've never seen anyone turn that color
red before.
It's only a few dragons, said the queen
with a wave of one talon.
Right?
Five or six. 14, said Kinkaju.
Not counting the 3 who already died
there.
Even mangrove didn't realize how many
were missing, Glory thought.
She felt another wave of anger.
Three dead before anyone even went
looking for them.
Were they waiting to be rescued?
Did they believe someone would come for
them?
Or did they know there was no hope?
See?
Only 14 said magnificent.
It doesn't really make that much
difference, does it?
There are plenty of other dragons in the
tribe.
For a moment, glory was speechless.
She had never, ever, not once in a
1000000 years, imagined there could be a
queen who would let her subjects die
without lifting a claw to save them.
If the queen didn't even care, what
chance did any rain wing have, and there
was nothing glory could do.
She wasn't part of the prophecy, she
wasn't a normal rain wing, and she
couldn't save the rain wings on her own
no matter how much she wanted to.
Without the queen, with no army, she was
as useless as a sloth.
She wanted to scream a 1000000 things at
the queen.
What is wrong with all of you?
Don't you have any loyalty or empathy?
Someone should care when a dragon
disappears.
And then she realized exactly what she
wanted to say.
She spread her wings and pointed at the
larger dragon.
Queen Magnificent?
I challenge you for the throne of the
rain wings.
Chapter 25.
You mean you want to turn it being queen
said magnificent, tilting her head in a
puzzled way.
I'm sure that could be arranged, if you
insist, I can talk to the others and try
to fit you in between grandeur and
exquisite next year.
No, I need to be queen now, said Glory.
She tried not to think about how much
bigger than her magnificent was or how
many years older she must be.
Then again, I'm sure she's never had any
battle training or faced a Skywings claws
every morning for 6 years.
Because if you won't rescue those rain
wings, I will, whatever it takes, even if
it means taking the throne from you.
Oh, wow.
Kinkachu breathed.
I don't see how you could possibly do
that, said Queen Magnificent.
She looked down and started rearranging
one of her flower necklaces.
It's not very complicated, Glory said.
We fight.
Whoever survives gets to be queen.
The other rain wings in the room all
gasped.
The queen's scales shimmered white and
green.
She stared at Glory.
You would kill another dragon, just so
you could be queen.
That's how it works in every other tribe
Glory pointed out.
Not here, said Magnificent.
That's barbaric.
What's barbaric?
is abandoning dragons of your tribe when
you could save them, said glory
fiercely.
Queen Magnificent waved her front claws
airily, and addressed herself to Kinkaju
and the blue green dragon.
I'm sure no rain wing would follow a
queen who got her thrown by violence.
Agreed.
The blue green dragon shrugged, but
Kinkachu puffed out her chest and glared
at the queen.
I'd follow glory anywhere, she said.
It's not the rain wing way.
Magnificent protested.
As far as I can tell, the rain wing way
is to lie around and do nothing.
Glory snapped.
So why don't you do that?
And I'll just go ahead and be Queen.
After all, no one really wants the job
right?
Maybe, I don't want you to have it, said
the queen with a growl.
There is an old tradition, interjected
the ancient dragon suddenly.
If anyone wants to hear about it.
The old rain wing chuckled, as they all
turned to him.
Don't look at me like that, Maggie.
It's the fair thing to do, and it gives
you as much chance, if not more, of
keeping the throne.
What is it?
Glory asked.
A contest. he said.
Legend has it the dragons once vied for
our throne like any other, but over time
the rain wings devised a new method that
did not end in death.
If a challenger wished to take the throne
she had to defeat the present queen in a
competition.
And the queen had the right to choose the
nature of the contest.
That sounds exhausting.
Magnificent said peevishly.
It sounds fair to me, said Glory.
Typical rain wing nonsense, but honestly
becoming queen without any killing would
be fine by her.
What kinds of contests did they have?
The old dragon squinted into the air.
Let me think, he said, counting on his
claws.
Once there was a gliding race through the
treetops, and when I was a very young
dragonette, I saw a camouflage contest.
One would hide while the other tried to
find her, and then vice versa.
The winner was the one who found the
other fastest.
A game of hide and seek to become queen
Glory said.
Why not?
She hoped no one could tell that she was
a bit shaken.
She was pretty sure she'd be better at a
fight to the death, than she would be at
tree gliding, or flower picking, or
whatever a magnificent would come up
with.
But if she wanted to be queen of the rain
wings, she'd have to start acting like
one.
Keeping her scales evenly red, she turned
to magnificent.
Go ahead and name your contest, your
majesty.
Magnificent narrowed her eyes.
I want a day to think about it, she
said.
That is customary, agreed the old
dragon.
Glory lashed her tail.
The kidnapped rain wings might not have a
day.
Who knew what the night wings would do
now that they'd been found out?
What if they killed all their prisoners
to hide the evidence?
Or what if they were gathering an army
and shoring up their defenses right now?
A quick, overwhelming attack before the
night wings could prepare?
That what glory had been planning.
Maybe I could go back tonight by myself
she thought.
Maybe I could sneak through the tunnel
and free them all and melt any night
wings who tried to stop me and bring
everyone home.
But she remembered the feeling of
nightwing claws pressing her into the
stone, and the cold band of metal around
her jaws.
If she went back alone and got caught
there wouldn't be time for anyone to come
after her, the night wings would kill her
on sight, and then there would be no hope
for the imprisoned rain wings at all.
No, she couldn't rescue anyone without an
army, which meant she needed the power of
the throne behind her, and to get that
she had to win this contest.
And with a day, she might at least have a
chance of preparing.
Maybe Jambu could teach her tree gliding
like he'd promised.
All right, she said. meeting the queen's
eyes.
Sunrise tomorrow.
At the arboretum, said magnificent, with
a sly smile, as if she knew perfectly
well that Glory had no idea where that
was.
Also memorize the layout of the rain wing
village.
Glory noted to herself.
Just in case she chooses like a scavenger
hunt or something.
Magnificent nodded toward the old
dragon.
What was your name again?
Handsome, he said.
He winked at glory.
Our names don't always end up suiting
us.
Handsome can oversee the contest, since
this was his stupid suggestion
Magnificent said.
If that's all right with you, Pipsqueak.
Sounds perfect, Glory said.
Enjoy your last day as queen.
She ducked out through the vine curtain
and stood on the bridge for a moment
breathing deeply.
The full impact of what she'd just done
was finally starting to hit her.
Am I crazy?
Do I even want to be queen of the rain
wings and be stuck here forever?
Trying to organize these hopeless
dragons?
She could just imagine what her friends
were going to say about this.
She looked up and saw about 25 rain wings
all crowded onto the waiting platform
staring at her.
One of them was coconut.
Apparently, this was the best he could
muster when asked to gather the whole
village.
But judging from their expressions, they'd
heard Glory's conversation with
magnificent.
And from what she knew about rain wings
this was the kind of news that would
spread quickly, mainly because it meant
they'd have some entertainment at sunrise
tomorrow.
Kingachu bounced out of the tree house
behind her, and solve the dragons as
well.
Coconut, she cried.
Did you hear that?
The other dragonette scuffed one talon
across the wooden platform.
Sure, he said.
We're going to have a proper queen for
once.
Kinkaju said proudly.
A few of the rain wings exchanged glances
turning an odd shade of light, purplish
orange.
Glory guessed it meant puzzled or
confused.
It wasn't a color she wore, or let
herself wear, very often.
A proper queen, echoed another of the
rain wings, is, uh, is that something we
need?
What's wrong with the ones we've got?
asked another.
Why don't you ask Gibbon that question?
Kingaju shot back.
Or Orchid, or Splendor, or Tulong, or
Loris?
All of the dragons were frowning now.
Several of them glanced around at the
trees, as if they expected orchid and
splendor to come sauntering out to be
interviewed.
Hmm, that's right, Kinkachu said.
Haven't seen them in a while, have you?
That's because they've been kidnapped
like I was, and they're still trapped
there.
Except for taper and bright, and
orangutan, who died of awful deaths, alone
and far away from everything and everyone
they loved.
And the only dragon who's willing to do
anything about it is glory.
That's why she should be our queen.
Glory did not enjoy the awkward pause
that followed.
A number of the rain wings wrinkled up
their snouts, as if they were trying to
figure out who this glory character was.
Don't listen to her.
From Iliad shouldered her way to the
other dragons and glared at Kinkaju.
Her tongue flicked in and out of her
mouth.
This dragonette is trouble.
She's been hiding in the forest for 3
weeks to spite me, and now she's made up
a ridiculous tale just for the
attention.
Violent orange shot through Kinkaju's
wings, and she bared her fangs of
Bromeliad with a hiss.
Put a sheep in it, Bromeliad.
Gloria said, pulling Kinkaju back behind
her.
It's all true.
I was there too.
She turned her attention to the other
dragons on the platform, and the ones who
are starting to gather in the trees as
well.
Listen to me.
Your friends are suffering.
They're tortured and trapped in caves in
a horrible place that smells of smoke and
death.
There's no fruit.
There's no sun time.
Horrified murmurs swept through the
branches overhead.
No sun time?
Somebody squeaked.
Glory took a step along the bridge, and
several of the rain wings quailed back.
This could have happened, could still
happen, to any of you.
If you won't go rescue them, who will?
They'll be lost there forever.
Glory lashed her tail.
I know you'd rather sleep than deal with
problems, but these dragons are from your
tribe, and they need you.
She glanced back at the treehouse behind
her and raised her voice.
That's why I'm going to take the throne
tomorrow.
It's not because I want the biggest
pieces of fruit or the highest sun
platform.
I'm doing this for the missing rain wings
and for you, so that you don't have to
spend the rest of your lives, looking
over your shoulders and thinking, our
friends are still lost.
And we could have saved them.
Chapter 26.
Glory took a deep breath and studied her
audience.
Most of the dragons looked confused.
But if you had dark purple stripes
rippling over their scales, guilt and
shame, living right next to pride on the
color spectrum.
Hmm, glory thought.
That's about all the noble speechifying
I've got in me.
Somehow it had always seemed more
believable and less awkward in the
scrolls she read.
The stirring speech was always where
chapters ended.
But right now, a host of dragons were
just staring at her, and she couldn't
remember anything from the stories about
what you did at the end of a noble speech
or how to slink away gracefully
afterward.
So there, said Kinkachu. sticking out her
tongue at Bromeliad.
Glory was pretty sure that wasn't it.
What do we do now?
Kinkaju asked Glory brightly.
The blue gray was gone from her scales
and all her energy had returned.
Never mind.
I know exactly what we're doing first.
Finding something decent to eat.
Glory turned her back on her wide-eyed
audience and focused on Kinkaju.
You go ahead.
I have to tell my friends what just
happened, and also find someone to teach
me everything about rain wing skills in
the next day.
I can do that, Kingachu said.
After I eat, I'm going to eat every piece
of fruit in the rainforest.
Where should I meet you?
Try the healer's hut.
Glory said with a sigh.
Bring mangrove too.
Kingajoo shot off into the trees.
Glory swiveled her head around and
checked that silver was still asleep on
her shoulder, ignoring the crowd.
She spread her wings and flew away.
If she remembered magnificent directions
correctly, the healer's tree house was
not far.
She spotted the red berries growing on
the balcony, and swooped down to a tree
house, whose leafy roof was dotted with
skylight holes.
Inside, only 2 of the beds were taken, one
by Webbs, and the other by a sleeping
rain wing with a bandage on his snout, as
if he had bumped into a tree while flying
around.
Three rain wings and shades of white and
soothing blue were gathered in a corner
eating bananas, and talking in low
voices.
Sure enough, Sonny and Starflight were
crouched beside Webbs, watching him
anxiously.
Well, Sonny was watching webs.
As usual, Starflight was watching Sonny.
Webbs was sprawled across a nest of
spider shaped leaves in the sunlight.
He was asleep, breathing peacefully for
the 1st time since blister had attacked
him.
Sonny was right.
The cactus juice clearly was working.
The scratch on his tail wasn't completely
healed, but the edges looked much less
raw, and the black had faded instead of
spreading further.
I guess you saved him, Glory remarked
sliding up beside them.
I hope so, Sonny said.
But he's still really sad.
He keeps mumbling in his sleep about how
it's his fault the skywings found and
destroyed the summer palace.
Well, it is.
Glory said.
Oh, very sympathetic, Starflight said.
Come on.
Webbs didn't know crocodile was following
him.
Crocodile.
The last dragon, Glory had used her venom
on before the night kingdom.
She saw a flash of the mud wings
terrified face, and shoved the thought
away.
That was self-defense.
It was always self-defense.
The kind of self-defense her fellow rain
wings really needed to learn.
Sunny brushed Glory's shoulder with her
wing, and Glory flinched back.
You should put something on your
scratches, Sonny said.
This isn't a scratch.
Gloria informed her, pointing to the
bleeding slash on her back leg, which had
started to throb in a fiercely painful
way.
It's a battle wound.
Yes, you're very tough and scary, Sonny
said.
She beckoned to the white and blue rain
wings, while Glory wondered if that was
sarcasm.
Sarcasm from Sonny?
It didn't seem likely.
She twisted to watch as the rain wing
stabbed some kind of paste on her
injuries.
Watch it.
She hissed.
But after a moment, the stinging faded
and all she could feel was cool
numbness.
Lori studied the wounds and sniffed the
paste, which smelled a bit like mint.
Hmm, she said finally.
A dragonette named Kinkaju is on her way
here.
She needs some of that too.
She caught Sonny's significant look and
gave the healers a nod.
Thanks.
Where's your army?
Starflight asked Glory, only a little
Snidely.
They're a work in progress, said Glory.
Sonny leaned over Webbs, adjusting the
dressing on his injury.
So, by the way, Glory went on, I've
decided to be queen of the rain wings.
Sonny tripped, and Webbs let out an oof
as she landed on him, but he didn't wake
up.
Starflight turned to stare at glory
incredulously.
But why?
You've never wanted to be a queen, he
said.
You don't know that, said Glory.
She was aware of the healers hovering
just within earshot, trying to look busy
but obviously eavesdropping.
It just didn't come up because we were
too busy hearing about how much tsunami
wanted to be queen.
Anyway, I have to if I want to lead them
into battle against the night wings.
Battle?
Starflight said anxiously.
I think you'll be a great queen, said
Sonny, with a flutter of her golden
wings.
Rule. agreed the sloth, waking up and
leaning around glory's neck.
Maybe we don't have to fight the night
wings.
Starflight said, in a plaintive voice.
Let me talk to them.
Maybe I can find out why they've been
taking rain wings in the 1st place.
They still need rescuing.
Glory snapped.
Maybe the Nightwings will let them go
Starflight said.
Maybe if I explain to them, that keeping
dragons tied up in caves is wrong, Glory
said.
Sure.
That's probably never occurred to them.
Or that they should have asked politely
before stealing rainwing venom?
And don't forget the med wings, Sonny
added.
Why did they kill those 2 soldiers?
Glory had forgotten about the dead mud
wings.
If that had been the night wings too, then
what on pyria were they up to?
Listen, she said to Starflight.
I know you don't want to meet your tribe
for the 1st time on the opposite side of
a battlefield, but they can't be
trusted.
It's not even safe for you.
We have no idea whether Deathbringer was
supposed to kill you as well.
They would never kill me.
Starflight protested.
I'm one of them.
Barely, said Glory.
Anyway, I'd rather find out the truth
with a whole lot of venomous backup
wouldn't you?
Starflight twisted his talons together.
Glory glanced out the nearest window and
saw a pair of dragons shift quickly to
camouflage on the branch outside.
She squinted, and thought she could see
shimmers of movement on several other
branches as well.
Apparently, her tribe was finally
interested in her.
Wait, said Sonny, sitting up and flaring
her wings.
If you want to be queen, don't you have
to kill magnificent?
They have this whole no killing way of
taking the throne?
Glory said.
They're rain wings.
Of course, they do.
They do?
That's fantastic, Sonny said, with
unexpected intensity.
That's how all the tribes should do it.
Maybe after we stop the war, we can teach
everyone the rain wing way of changing
queens.
Glory gave her a quizzical look.
That was a lot of enthusiasm for a rain
wing way of doing things.
She was pretty sure most dragons wouldn't
feel that way.
Why don't we take our revolution one step
at a time, she said. flicking her tail at
Sonny.
The other tribes have been doing things
their way for 100s of years.
So, Sonny said, things can change.
If queens didn't kill their challengers
Starflight interjected, what would stop
the challengers from trying again the
next day?
and the next?
Or if the challenger won, the queen could
just come try to take it back.
Instead of ruling her kingdom, a queen
would have to spend all her time simply
trying to keep her thrown.
Then we make new rules, Sonny said
stubbornly.
Like, she can only be challenged at
certain times of the year, or each
challenger can try twice before giving up
or something like that.
We're dragons, not caterpillars.
We can do things differently if we choose
to.
Dragons are dragons, Sonny, Glory said.
Fighting is part of our nature.
Not for the rain wings, Sonny said, and
their dragons too.
But, but there's something wrong with
them.
Glory thought.
She didn't want to say that out loud with
a healer is listening, and however many
dragons were just outside the window, but
she knew Starflight must be thinking it
too.
Maybe rain wings are more evolved than
the rest of us, Sonny said.
Maybe all dragons should try to be more
like them.
They're happy, aren't they?
True, Glory thought.
But maybe I could have been happy as
Queen Scarlet's prisoner, as long as I
got to lie in the sun and eat pineapple
all day.
And then where would my friends be?
I don't think it's enough to just be
happy, Glory said slowly.
I think you have to care about something
too.
Like other dragons who need you, for
instance, and you still have to be ready
to fight, just in case some creepy, less
evolved dragons decide to invade your
territory and kidnap a bunch of you.
I don't believe anyone can be truly happy
without scrolls, Starflight said
wistfully.
I haven't seen a scroll in weeks, and I'm
perfectly miserable.
Poor Starflight, Sonny said. with genuine
sympathy, brushing his wings with hers.
Well, when Gloria is queen, she can fix
all that.
Starflight can teach everyone to read, and
tsunami can teach them to defend
themselves, and will make a list of all
the eggs and all the dragons in the tribe
so no one will ever get lost again, plus
save the missing rain wings, and choose a
sand wing queen, and stop the war.
Glory said.
No problem.
Give me a week.
Sonny beamed, as if this sounded like a
perfectly reasonable plan to her.
When I'm queen, glory thought, I like the
sound of that.
Through one of the windows, Glory saw
Kinkachu and Mangrove approaching.
A few more curious dragons were tailing
them through the trees, and Glory spotted
more eyes watching from the leaves.
Mangrove was an unexpected, dappled
mixture of bright yellow and lime green
excited and terrified, she thought.
But more complicated.
With the return of Kinkaju, now he knew
that Orchid was alive, but he also knew
what an awful place she was in and how
hard it would be to get her back.
Glory hoped Clay and tsunami were ready
to stop him if he tried to dash through
the tunnel and do any rescuing by
himself.
Well, before we change the fundamental
essence of dragons and revamp the rain
wing tribe, First, I have to win, she
said.
So right now, I have to go train for this
contest thing tomorrow.
If anyone wants to come watch while the
others guard the tunnel, it's in the
arboretum at sunrise.
I'll be there, Sonny said.
It'll be nice to know a queen we actually
like.
If you win, Starflight added gloomily.
I will win, Glory said.
Glancing again at Mangroves Scales.
She thought of orchid, and the other
rainforest dragons, chained and muzzled
and fed rotting prey, imprisoned away
from the sun and their own tribe.
I have to.
Chapter 27.
Papaya, Glory said.
Starfruit, Tangelo, Clementine, Kumbu
Dragonberry, Mango, Fire Pair, and that
one's a trick that only looks like a
fruit, but is actually a poorly designed
snail.
She poked the purple snail's shell with
one claw, and its nervous antennae
vanished again.
The sun was high above them, and the
morning rain had stopped, although the
leaves kept showering the dragons every
time someone bounced through and shook
the trees.
All the toucans and parrots and
lowerkeets that had disappeared during
the rainfall were back, perched on the
highest branches, and hollering joyfully
at the sun as if they'd never expected to
see it again.
And now glory could identify all the
birds in sight, after studying with
mangrove and kinkaju all morning.
Birds, insects, flowers, fruit, anything
magnificent might tester on she would
memorize.
Whenever she felt her brain getting tired
she'd think of the smoky air choking the
caves of the rain wings, and that would
snap her back into focus.
Wow, said Kinkaju.
She blinked large dark eyes at glory.
How did you learn all of that so fast?
You really never had any of these
before?
Mangrove asked, surveying the 40 or so
fruits arranged around the platform.
One or 2 maybe, said Glory.
I should taste them all too, right?
Just in case she chooses a blind taste
test?
I don't think anyone's ever thought of
that before, said Mangrove.
But you never know.
He peeled the banana with a few swipes of
his claws and tossed it to her.
Clay would dominate a blind taste test
Sonny offered, from her perch in the
trees above them.
Sunlight danced on her golden scales.
A small orange monkey with a black face
was playing with her tail, but Sonny
either didn't notice or didn't mind.
I would.
Clay said wistfully.
Are you going to eat that whole thing?
Glory took another bite, and then lobbed
the rest of it, Adam.
Clay fumbled to catch it and ended up
with bananas smeared all over his
talons.
He licked it off with a contented
expression.
You can practice your camouflage at the
same time.
Mangrove said.
See if you can match this mango.
He rolled it to her with his nose.
Glory studied the outside of the mango
and let her scales slowly turn a dull
green with black speckles, shading to
warm red around her wings and tail.
So cool, said Sonny.
Are you going to eat that whole thing?
Clay asked.
Glory laughed.
Clay.
Let me at least try it.
She tried slicing it open as neatly as
mangrove had opened the banana and made a
terrific mess.
Cheerful orange yellow pulp squirted all
over her scales, and Silver scrambled
down Glory's arm to lick it up.
Stop wasting time.
She scolded herself as she helped the
sloth balance.
The days half gone, and you still need to
practice venom targeting and tree gliding
and camouflage.
I'm not sure this is the right time to
tell you this?
Sonny said, but you're being watched.
Glory and Mangrove looked up sharply.
She'd asked him to choose a spot where
they could practice without attracting
too much attention.
It was unsettling to keep finding rain
wing eyes on her every time she turned
around.
The whole tribe must know she wasn't a
normal rain wing, but they didn't need to
see all of her mistakes the day before
she tried to become their queen.
But Sonny was right, even though they
were in a secluded corner of the
village.
Glory could see dragon heads peering
around tree trunks and poking out of
hammocks, staring her away.
As she whipped her head around to look at
them, most of them quickly changed color
and disappeared.
But if she'd spotted those few, she could
imagine how many more might be out
there.
Camouflaged and curious about the
challenger for the throne.
Well, take me or leave me, Glory
thought.
I'm not a typical rain wing, but maybe
that's what you need for a queen.
All right.
What can we do next?
she asked, popping berries in her mouth.
Raspberries are sharper than cloud
berries.
Figs taste like desert winds.
Guavas are the ones I could eat every day
for the rest of time.
Venom practice?
Next to suntime, Kingachoo said, and
Mangrove nodded with a glance at the
sky.
Are you crazy?
Glory said.
She seized a papaya and accidentally
crushed it between her front talons.
I have one day to prepare for this.
I'm not going to spend it snoozing like a
slug.
Sun time isn't about snoozing, Mangrove
said sternly.
It's about recharging.
Terrible, furable, agreed Glory Sloth
climbing up to tug on Glory's ears.
I'd rather study.
Glory said.
She saw Kinkaju's crestfallen face and
added, you 2 can go ahead.
I'll practice on my own.
You will not, said Mangrove.
You need this energy to win.
You will sleep if we all have to sit on
you to make it happen.
I volunteer, Clay said.
I'm a world champion at sitting on my
friends.
Clay, Glory said, over Sunny's giggling
this isn't a joke.
I don't have time to be lazy.
Glory has some issues with the word lazy
Sonny announced.
Our guardians used to call her that all
the time, so she feels like she needs to
prove something by showing she doesn't
need to sleep.
Glory flared her rough and glared at
Sonny.
Excuse me, are you explaining me?
Sonny shifted her wings in a friendly
shrug.
Well, that's what Starflight said, she
offered, but it makes sense to me.
Sleeping when you need to is not lazy
said Mangrove.
That is a crazy dragon's way of
thinking.
Sleeping is as important as breathing.
You wouldn't skip that because there's no
time for it.
Or food, Clay agreed.
You can't skip sleeping or food.
The mudwing dragonette hopped off his
branch and thudded down next to her
squashing a mango under his big claws.
He crouched so his brown eyes were
directly even with glories.
Silver leaned over Gloria's head and
tried to poke at his horns.
Glory.
He said.
Stop panicking for one moment, and think
about how you feel right now.
And I don't mean mad.
I mean physically.
I'm not panicking, Glory said, ruffled.
I am pretty close to mad though.
And he prompted.
And getting closer, she shot back.
He gave her a patient look.
And...
Exhausted.
Glory realized, as she took a deep
breath.
She hadn't really slept in a, well, in a
really long time, not properly.
She thought about the brush of sunlight
on her scales.
Fine, she snapped, but wake me up in one
hour.
Understand?
We'll see, Clay said.
Cheered the sloth.
Come on.
Kinkaju said excitedly.
I know the best spot.
As Glory, Kinkaju, and Mangrove took off
there was a flurry of wing beat
throughout the trees around them, as
camouflaged rain wings none too subtly
followed them.
Kinkachu led the way to a platform that
was built right above the treetops with
no leaves between it and the blue arc of
the sky.
The surface dipped in the center. and was
lined with cloud soft pink blossoms
growing along the vines that were woven
around the wood.
You take this spot, Kinkachu said
pointing to the hollow in the middle.
Glory reluctantly curled up in the vines
and immediately felt warmth soaking into
her bones.
Silver flopped happily into a spot on
Glory's shoulder and snuggled in.
Glory jumped, as Kinkaju nestled on one
side of her, and Mangrove settled on the
other.
That answered that question.
Other rain wings didn't mind touching one
another.
So it was just her who had a problem with
it.
Um, she started to say, but the 2 rain
wings were already breathing deeply.
Glory closed her eyes, certain she'd
never fall asleep like this.
A moment later, she opened them, and
found herself looking into the amber eyes
of Queen Scarlet.
Chapter 28.
Glory leaped back with a hiss and opened
her mouth.
Don't you dare, snarled the queen.
Haven't you done enough already?
Glory paused, studying the Skywing's
face.
It was perfect, as perfect as it had ever
been.
A shimmering orange like the orchid
growing from the moss behind her, with
the small rubies above her eyes
glittering in the bright sunlight.
And then Scarlet's whole body flickered
somehow.
And under the perfect scales, Glory saw
something dark and melted, a horrible
smeared mess where a face used to be.
Behind Scarlet.
She caught a glimpse of a dim room with
glass jars hanging from the ceiling.
Some of them glowing strangely.
Oh.
You're not really here, Glory said, as
the rainforest reappeared, and Scarlet's
scales smoothed back to perfect.
The queen was perched on the edge of
Glory's sleeping platform, but now that
Glory looked closely, she could see that
the sky wings claws didn't sink into the
leaves below her.
Glory sat down and curled her tail around
her talons.
Kinkachu and mangrove were fast asleep on
either side of her.
The sloth was snoring on her shoulder, and
the sun had climbed higher in the sky.
Am I even awake?
Glory asked.
No, said Scarlet.
I've been trying to catch you asleep for
days.
She held up a small star shaped sapphire
that glowed an eerie blue light through
her claws.
Once I realized what this was.
A dream visitor, Glory said, recognizing
the shape from her scrolls.
I read about those.
An animus dragon made 3 of them 100s of
years ago, right?
I thought the last one in existence was
lost with the sandwing treasure, when the
scavenger killed Queen Oasis and stole it
all.
Apparently not, Scarlett said. opening
her claws to glance down at it.
So you're really alive, Glory said.
You don't sound as disappointed as I
thought you would be, Scarlett said.
Glory flicked her tail.
It's not that I want you dead.
I just want you not trying to kill us.
I never tried to kill you, Scarlett
pointed out.
I quite liked you.
We could have had a thrilling time
together.
She stood up and paced toward glory until
their snouts were almost nose to nose.
Which reminds me, I wanted to try
something.
Abruptly, she lashed out with her free
talent, slashing at glory's face, her
claws sliced right through glory's scales
like raindrops splashing icy water over
her.
It was cold, but it didn't hurt.
Scarlet's claws weren't really there.
Glory fixed that thought in her head as
Scarlet lunged again.
She closed her eyes and sat perfectly
still.
There was nothing the Skywing queen could
do to her right now.
She was no more dangerous than any
dream.
After a few moments.
Glory opened her eyes again, and Scarlet
stepped back, hissing.
Smoke rose up from her nose, winding
around her horns, and the dark, misshapen
snout underneath flickered through again
for a moment, along with the room
beyond.
Where are you?
Glory asked.
If I tell you.
Will you find me and free me?
Scarlett asked.
Not likely, Glory said.
Wait, let me think.
Absolutely, definitely not.
But you owe me, Scarlett said, stamping
one foot.
Glory tilted her head sideways.
How exactly do you figure that?
For what you did to me.
Scarlet seethed.
I was beautiful before.
I had everything.
Including a pretty rainbow dragon on a
tree.
Glory said.
I remember.
If you don't free me, Scarlett said, I
will find a way out of here myself, and
then when I find you, I will kill you.
You know?
Something tells me that's on your agenda
either way, Glory said.
Scarlet hissed deep in her throat, and
then shot a blast of flame at glory's
face.
Calm and blue.
Glory thought.
Stay calm and blue.
Is someone keeping you prisoner?
Glory asked.
A thought occurred to her.
Is it the night wings?
If you're not going to help me, Scarlett
growled.
I'll find someone else who will.
And suddenly she was gone, leaving only a
curl of smoke in the air.
So there's my answer.
Scarlet is alive.
Glory noticed that the leaves below her
were shaking.
Oh, wait.
That's me.
Kinkaju stirred, as if she felt glory
shaking too.
She nestled closer, and glory felt sun
drenched warmth along her scales.
Slowly she closed her eyes, breathing
deeply, and drifted out of the dream.
When she woke up, she knew right away it
had been longer than an hour.
Silver was crouched in front of her
stroking Glory's nose with a worried
expression.
The other 2 were awake, and stretching
contentedly.
Don't you feel better?
Kinkaju asked.
Yes, Glory admitted.
And no.
Then let's do tree gliding next.
Kinkaju said cheerfully.
Fine by me, said Mangrove, and Glory
nodded.
She was too shaken to argue.
She wondered what Scarlet would think of
glory becoming queen of the rain wings.
She wondered if being a queen would make
her any safer.
Sonny and Clay waved from their branch
down below.
Should I tell them?
I should tell them.
I will tell them, but not yet.
Glory wanted to talk to Starflight 1st to
see what he could remember about dream
visitors, and if he could guess anything
about the room she'd seen behind
Scarlet.
His giant brain was what she needed for a
puzzle like this.
As glory lifted into the sky, setting off
a commotion of hidden wings.
She wondered where the sky wing queen was
and when she would see her again.
Chapter 29.
The arboretum, it turned out, was the
heart of the rain wing village.
Vines and branches were woven tightly
together to form a wide field high above
the ground, open to the sky, and
surrounded by tree houses, walkways, and
hammocks.
Several of the tree houses around the
edge appeared to be set up for trading
fruits and flower garlands, brilliant
blue and coppery orange birds, darted
through the leaves, chattering, and
calling to one another, like an audience
gathering for a performance.
There seemed to be room for the entire
village to gather around the edges of the
circle, and it looked like the entire
village had shown up.
The rumble of dragon voices mixed with
the chirruping of sloths, and sent
shivers through the wooden walkway where
Glory stood, studying the green stadium
in front of her.
Glory was reminded, uncomfortably, of the
Sky Wing Arena, where her friends had
battled for Queen Scarlet's amusement.
From the way Tsunami's tail was twitching
Glory guessed she felt the same way.
This is unfair.
Tsunami grumbled.
If you win, you'll have to call me your
majesty, Glory said, grinning.
I know.
Won't that be hilarious?
And your face will look like that all the
time, tsunami said.
It's going to be so hard not to bite
you.
But if you do, my guards will throw you
in my dungeons, Glory said, with an
imperious wave of her talons.
Rain wings don't have dungeons.
Kinkaju pointed out.
There's a surprise.
Well, I'll make one, just for tsunami
Glory said.
Maybe I should have let Starfly come to
this instead, tsunami said.
Postpone my agony a little bit.
Starflight and Clay were taking a shift
watching the Nightwing Tunnel.
They'd seen nothing come out of it yet
not so much as a puff of smoke.
Glory found that both alarming and
reassuring.
Maybe the night wings were afraid to
fight rain wings.
That would make attacking them a bit
easier.
She hadn't had a chance to talk to
Starflight yet.
He'd stayed out by the tunnel all night.
I'll talk to him right after the contest
she thought.
Telling him about Queen Scarlet ought to
distract him from fretting about fighting
night wings.
And I cannot think about Queen Scarlet
right now.
I could have watched the tunnel, Sonny
said.
I don't understand why no one will let me
take a turn on guard.
Well, for one thing, I need you here to
cheer me on, Glory said, who could do
that better than you?
I think I'm being patronized, Sonny
said.
She poked at the wooden platform below
them with a harmless point of her tail.
But I'll cheer for you anyway.
You're definitely going to win.
I'm not worried.
Glory was a little worried.
For one thing, her opponent had
apparently multiplied overnight.
Queen Magnificent was waiting in the
center of the canopy.
Her scales were resplendently purple, with
scalloped gold edging on each individual
scale, which was a color trick Glory had
never tried.
She had taken off most of her flower
necklaces.
Replacing them with one small wreath of
lilies on her ruff, which had the effect
of looking like a lacy white crown.
Arrayed behind her were 4 more rain wings
all quite large, quite beautiful, and
quite outraged, judging from their
expressions and coloring.
Who are they?
Glory asked Kinkaju.
The other queens, Kingajoo whispered.
I mean, you know, the ones who take turns
being queen.
I guess they don't particularly want you
to take their job either.
Are any of them better than magnificent?
Glory asked.
Maybe there was another option.
It didn't have to be her.
As long as the rain wings had a queen who
would take care of them.
But Kinkaju was shaking her head.
They're all pretty much the same, she
said.
She pointed to one of the queens, who
looked like she'd eaten a few too many
avocados and papayas during her reign.
That one's dazzling.
She'll grant anyone anything they ask if
they bring her enough tribute.
She has the throne before magnificent.
After magnificent, it passes to
grandeur.
Grandeur was a stately older dragon with
half asleep eyes and a sour expression.
Her ruff was indignantly pale orange at
the moment, but the rest of her scales
were pale lavender, and seemed to glitter
with tiny dewdrops.
During her reign, Kinkachu said.
She'll only see petitioners once a week
for an hour.
First come, 1st served, and if you don't
get in during that hour, you have to wait
until the next week.
The lines practically stretch around the
jungle.
And then she says no to pretty much
everything.
She's really, really old.
She's been one of the queens for as long
as anyone can remember.
Kingaju pointed to the next dragon, who
had 2 sloths flopped on her back, and one
more perched in the curve of her tail.
This queen had scales the same silvery
color as the sloths, with a soft shimmer
to them that looked like wind brushing
through fur.
That's exquisite, said Kinkaju.
Obsessed with sloths.
She has about 20 more at home.
Talks about them constantly, feeds them
the best fruits, grooms them with their
own claws.
And whenever she's queen, she has
everyone build tiny hammocks for the
sloths to sleep in, and weave them tiny
flower necklaces.
No dragon is as important to her as those
sloths.
Dazzling, grandeur, exquisite.
Glory muttered.
Adding those to the list of things she'd
memorized in the last day.
And the last one?
Let me guess.
Splendiferous, astonishing, too beautiful
for dragon eyes to bear?
That's Fruit Bat, said Kinkaju.
All right, said Glory.
Didn't see that coming.
Who picks the names for newly hatched
dragonettes if no one has any parents
here?
There's a list we cycle through.
Kingachu said.
Usually the ones with shiny names are
more likely to want to be queen.
Fruit bat is an exception.
She's working on this experiment to see
if she can take this sense out of flowers
and make herself smell like them all the
time.
Glory wrinkled her nose.
Weird, but interesting at least.
What in the world does that have to do
with being queen?
Kinkaju shrugged.
It's not going very well.
She's been working on it for something
like 30 years.
She started taking a turn as queen so
that she could have access to the Royal
Gardens, and by the end of her month, the
gardens are always a wreck.
My friend Tamarin is one of the flower
caretakers, and it drives her crazy.
Sounds like magnificent might be the best
of all of them.
Glory said, twisting one claw through a
hole in the wood.
Magnificent's main problem is that she's
forgetful.
Kinkachu pointed out.
She can never remember what she's agreed
to do, or what's going on in the tribe, or
who asked her for what, and she doesn't
really care.
We're all pretty used to it by now.
She turned her dark, shining eyes to
glory.
But if we had you as our queen instead
then everything would be different.
I hope so, Glory thought.
I hope different in a good way.
But what if I'm no better than they are?
She glanced across at Fruit Bat, who had
her nose buried in a massive orchid
necklace hung around her neck.
All right, I'm pretty sure I'll be better
than some of them.
The old dragon who had been in the
Queen's tree house slithered out to stand
next to magnificent.
He squinted around and beckoned to
glory.
Wish me luck.
Glory muttered, handing her sloth to
Sonny.
Silver burbled something anxious sounding
and clambered immediately up onto Sonny's
head for the best view.
Magnificent, flattened her ruff, and
looked down her nose as Glory landed in
front of her.
The other 4 queens lashed their tails.
So what's the plan?
Glory said, shaking out her wings.
I have to defeat all 5 of you.
She'd chosen a summary gold color for her
scales that matched the dragonflies
darting through the treetops.
She was determined to stay that color
throughout the contest, no matter what
magnificent through adder.
Glory's 1st goal?
Don't let anyone see that you're upset or
angry, or worst of all, scared.
No.
Handsome interjected. before magnificent
could answer.
That is not the tradition.
The challenger competes only against the
current queen.
But my fellow royalty didn't want to be
left out, said Magnificent, so I worked
them into the competition.
She smiled in a way that made glory want
to strangle her with a hammock, which
means you're going to need a team as
well.
I don't have a team.
Glory started, and then stopped herself.
Well?
I kind of do.
She turned and glanced back at Sunny and
Tsunami, who were watching with round
eyes from the platform.
I don't need to drag the others into
this.
Surely I can defeat the queens myself.
What can 5 rain wings do that I can't?
And wouldn't everyone be impressed if I
beat all of them?
All by myself?
With no help whatsoever?
She flexed her wings, which were still
sore from the robes that abound them
tightly just one day earlier?
This line of thinking felt familiar.
It was how she had convinced herself to
go out alone as bait.
And I made it back, didn't I?
I could have handled that situation fine
on my own.
But she knew it wasn't true.
Without Kinkachu, Clay, and Deathbringer
she'd still be stuck in a night wing
prison, or perhaps even dead, if the
night wings had had time to figure out
who she was.
So don't be an idiot.
Winning the throne with help won't make
you any less of a queen.
You get to choose your dragons, said
Magnificent, any 4 you wish.
That makes it easy for me, Glory
thought.
She had exactly 4 friends in the world
after all.
She could ask mangrove to go guard the
tunnel and send back Starflight and
clay.
She opened her mouth to call him, and
hesitated.
Maybe, a little too easy.
She studied dazzling, grandeur, exquisite
and fruit bat.
They looked ready, alert, and eager to
compete.
Not a look she'd seen on many rain wings
before.
They're convinced they're going to win.
Go ahead, said the Queen.
Call them out here, anyone you like.
Glory tilted her head at magnificent.
This is a trick.
She wants me to pick my friends.
And then the contest will involve
camouflage, or venom, or something that
only rain wings can do.
Not only that, but my future subjects
will think I trust outsiders more than I
trust them.
Which, frankly, I do, because most rain
wings are hopelessly incompetent.
But right now, I need their help.
I choose Kinkaju, Glory said.
She heard a loud squeak of surprise
behind her, and a murmur ran through the
watching dragons.
A three-year-old dragonette?
said magnificent archly.
This should be funny.
And I choose mangrove, Glory went on
ignoring her.
Mangrove stepped out of the crowd
opposite her and gave her a small bow.
Orchid was still out there.
He'd do anything to save her.
Glory could count on that.
Now it got a little harder.
Glory closed her eyes and side.
I choose Jambu.
Yes!
Her brother shouted, leaping into the
air.
That's me.
He bounced across the vines toward her
grinning all over his goofy pink face.
Who else?
Glory ran through the dragons she'd met
in the rainforest.
Liana?
Vermiliad?
Coconut.
Not a promising set.
She didn't know much about any of them
but none of them had impressed her as
team players.
Kinkachu came up beside her, fidgeting
excitedly and spilling deep purple blue
bubbles through her green scales.
Glory remembered someone the little
dragonette had mentioned when she was
describing the queens.
It was a risk, choosing a dragon she'd
never met, but she couldn't be worse than
any other rain wing.
And I choose Tamarin, she said.
All glory knew about her was that she was
friends with Kingaju.
She cared about her work with the flowers
and she wasn't the biggest fan of Fruit
Bat, which sounded like 3 good features
to glory.
The crowd murmured again, sounding like
waves rushing in from the ocean, and
Queen Magnificent barked a startled
laugh.
Tamarin?
Kinkachu cried.
But are you sure?
Too late, said Magnificent.
That's who she chose.
Someone give Tamaron a shove in the right
direction.
A small dragon popped out of the crowd
and stumbled forward a few steps, then
stopped.
She stood very still, with waves of pale
green rippling across her scales.
Her eyes were an odd light shade of blue
and stared blankly past glory at the
trees.
What is it?
Glory asked, glancing at Kinkajoo.
Why shouldn't I pick her?
You can, said Kinkachu.
It's just that.
Tamarin is blind.
Chapter 30.
Kinkachu hurried forward and whispered in
her friend's ear, then led Tamarin over
to glory.
The blind rain wing moved confidently
across the unsteady vine surface, as if
she knew where every leaf and every gap
would be.
She kept her wings up and out, like an
insect's antennae.
This is glory, Kinkaju said.
Our next queen.
She held out Tameron's front talons to
feel glory's face and wings.
Why would you pick me?
Tameron blurted.
She wore only one garland of flowers
around her shoulders.
The shades of red and pink and purple
didn't match at all, but they smelled
amazing.
It made Glory think of coconuts and honey
without making her hungry.
I told her about you.
Said Kinkaju.
Her voice faltered a little, giving away
that she hadn't quite mentioned
everything.
I had no idea there were any blind
dragons, except an old scroll stories
Glory said.
She fluttered a wing in front of
Tamaron's eyes, but the rain wing didn't
blink.
How do you fly between the trees?
How do you land?
Don't you accidentally walk off platforms
and fall out of hammocks all the time?
Not anymore.
Tameron answered.
The green was starting to fade from her
scales as she relaxed.
The 1st year, yes, all the time.
She lifted her wings higher to reveal an
old scar twisting across her underbelly.
Glory spotted a few others on Tameron's
wings and neck.
These weren't like the battle scars the
war had given to so many dragons.
These told the story of a tiny dragonette
crashing into trees, plummeting off
walkways, and impaling herself on stray
branches as she tried to learn to fly in
total darkness.
But everyone took care of me.
Tamaron said.
There was always a dragon watching me
helping me, and teaching me.
Glory glanced at the watching tribe.
She would have guessed that no one would
take responsibility for a little blind
dragonette.
Instead, everyone had, which gave her
hope.
And now I have the village memorized.
So I know all the distances and
obstacles.
Tamron's ruff folded down and then opened
again, as if she was sensing the shifting
wind currents.
Queen magnificent, unfurled her purple
wings and stood up on her back talons.
Let's begin, she called.
Unless you've changed your mind.
We're ready, Glory said.
No inspiring speech?
John Boo said.
Sounding disappointed.
Kinkachoo and Mangrove tilted their
snouts toward her expectantly.
Tamron's ears twitched.
I gave one yesterday.
Glory protested.
So now do one just for us.
Kinkaju said.
Her scales kept shifting to match the
dark green leaves below them, as if she
was trying to hide whatever she was
really feeling.
Mangrove, on the other hand, was a
resigned sky blue.
Um, all right.
Do your best.
Glory said.
And thanks and stuff.
Kinkaju stifled a laugh.
Wow. said Mangrove.
I feel so moved.
Queen Magnificent beckoned imperiously
and 2 portly rain wings flew up beside
her, carrying a low table carved from a
single log of mahogany, arranged neatly
on top were 5 nuts, each polished brown
and about the size of a dragon eye.
This contest has 5 parts, each related to
the special talents of our tribe. said
Queen Magnificent.
You assign one team member per part, and
whichever team wins 3 out of the 5
contests wins the crown.
She pointed a sharp claw at the 1st nut.
Venom targeting.
She pointed to the second.
A flower hunt?
The 3rd Treetop Race.
The 4th, fruit gathering.
The last nut she picked up and turned
over in her front talons.
And naturally there must be a camouflage
competition.
We are rain wings after all.
She set it down again with a toothy
smile.
Let's start with fruit gathering.
So the competitors can work on it while
we finish the other contests.
Certainly, said handsome.
Quite logical.
It's a very straightforward contest.
Each dragon has an hour to collect as
many different types of fruit as he or
she can find, the one who comes back with
the most variety wins.
Dazzling will compete for our side
Magnificent said, sweeping one wing
toward the portly queen.
And for yours.
Glory studied her own dragons, beating
back the anxiety that threatened to climb
up her scales.
The contests all featured rain wing
skills.
So on the one talon, she had outwitted
magnificent by choosing rain wings
instead of her friends, but on the other
talent, she barely knew her teammates.
She had no idea what they were good at.
All right, Glory said to them, keeping
her voice low.
Who should do what?
Jambu, you teach tree gliding.
Are you fast?
Can you do the treetop race?
Well, of course.
Her brother said, glowing with bright
pink enthusiasm.
Give me the flower one, said Tamaron.
If it's about flowers, I can do it.
Glory hesitated.
She said flower hunt, though.
I know, flowers, Tameron insisted.
Give her a chance, said a voice in
glory's head, it's what a good queen
would do.
All right, glory glanced to the row of
nuts on the table, thinking through the
other contests.
Her day of training hadn't exactly left
her feeling confident about most of
these.
I guess I should do the camouflage
contest, she said.
I have no idea where to find fruits in
the rainforest, and I'm not exactly a
venom expert.
She thought of the mess she'd made of
everything they'd put in front of her
yesterday.
Mangrove.
I know you're a fruit gatherer.
But Kingaju.
Sorry, but I got the impression from
Bromeliad that venom practice wasn't
going well with you.
That's because Bromeliad is a slow old
baboon.
Kingaju said hotly.
I'm super great at venom shooting.
I swear.
Plus, mangrove can carry more fruit than
I can.
Glory rubbed her forehead.
She only had to win 3 of the 5 contests
after all.
All right, she said.
Turning back to the waiting queens.
Mangrove will do the fruit gathering for
us.
Mangrove spread his wings and bowed to
dazzling.
At a signal from handsome.
They both flew off into the trees, heading
in opposite directions, and sending up
tornadoes of tiny crimson butterflies as
they went.
Now, said Handsome, he glanced up at the
sky and turned in a slow circle, so that
all the watching dragons could hear him.
Next, the treetop race, a test of speed
and agility.
Magnificent spun one of the nuts on the
table.
Exquisite. that means you.
And me.
Jambu said delightedly.
Handsome grand.
I'll never forget the last treetop race I
saw.
Weren't you in that?
He asked grandeur.
Who was your challenger?
No one worth mentioning.
Grandeur said frostily.
Naturally, I won.
But you're too old for racing now.
Magnificent said dismissively.
Grandeur gave her a wholehearted glare
that magnificent completely missed.
The sloth on exquisite tail clambered up
to her neck as the silver queen stepped
forward.
She dipped her wings so the other 2
sloths could slide off onto the vines
strong shoulders.
Glory noticed, big wings.
I bet she's fast.
Jambu looked like a bright pink monkey
next to the sleek silver dragoness.
Hansom pointed up at the treetops
surrounding the arboretum, a small
platform, about 3 dragons wide, was set
in the high branches.
Peach colored flowers studded the dark
wood planks, tied in bunches with strands
of silver sloth fur.
That is the start and end of the race, he
said.
You will fly 3 times around the arboretum
staying outside the ring of trees.
If you fly inside the ring, you will be
disqualified.
If you touch your opponent.
You will be disqualified.
As long as you stay outside the ring, you
may take any path around, but you must
touch down on the platform as you
complete each circuit.
Understood?
Got it, Jambu said, flexing his wings.
Exquisite didn't answer.
She had her front talons curled around
her 2 sloths, and was cooing at them as
they clambered over her claws.
Your majesty?
said Handsome, and then caught himself.
That is, I mean, exquisite.
Do you understand the rules?
Of course.
She said, disentangling her pets.
She set the 3rd one down next to them and
stroked their heads.
I'll be back in a moment, darlings.
I just have to win this race for Auntie
Maggie.
Stop calling me that.
Magnificent said crossly.
I'm nobody's auntie.
Certainly not a bunch of sloths, and this
isn't just for me, you big fur head.
It's your throne too.
There, there.
Exquisite said to the sloths, who had
curled up into a sleepy pile of fur.
Auntie Maggie isn't mad at you.
She's just in a bad temper because she
has to actually do something today.
In a loud whisper that absolutely
everyone could hear.
She added, besides, she's jealous that
you all are so much prettier than her
sloth.
Magnificent snarled in a very unqueenly
way, and shot a dark look at the 3 sloths
as if she might throw them off the
arboretum while exquisite was racing.
Good luck, Glory said to Jambu.
Please win.
That's the plan, he said cheerfully.
He followed handsome and exquisite up to
the platform, then leaned over the edge
and waved the crowd of dragons around the
edges of the arboretum.
Sonny and several other dragons waved
back.
It occurred to Glory to wonder who
everyone was rooting for.
Did anyone want her to win?
Did they know what that would mean?
Or about all the things she wanted to
change about their world?
Her gaze swept across the rain wings, the
tribe that might soon be hers.
She tried to read their scales, but as
far as she could tell, today most of them
had chosen their colors for their looks
as though they were showing off at a
party.
The only emotions she spotted were bright
yellow bursts of excitement in their
scales here and there, and she had a
feeling they'd be like that about
anything new that happened.
Handsome stepped onto a branch shaped
like a coiling dragon tail and spread his
wings.
Start when you hear the toucan call, he
said to Jambu and exquisite.
Don't forget the rules.
Ready?
And...
Call.
Glory was so startled by the sound that
came out of his throat that she missed
the beginning of the race.
Handsome had perfectly imitated the
noises she'd been hearing from the big
beaked birds.
If that was another rain wing talent, it
was one she'd never even thought of
trying before.
Exquisite shot ahead of Jambu, swinging
smoothly from branch to vine to branch
her tail was longer than Jambu's, giving
her a wider swing and farther reach, but
his narrower wings helped him dive
between some tangles of branches that she
had to maneuver around, and by the time
they got back to the platform for the 1st
time, his snout was almost brushing her
tail.
Go, Jamboo.
Sunny yelled from her spot on the
walkway.
You're going to win.
You're the fastest dragon in the forest.
Woohoo.
Kingaju nudged Tamarin, and they both
started hooting and shouting as well.
Personally, glory thought that much noise
would have been an annoying distraction
but it seemed to add wind to Jambu's
wings.
He banked around a trunk, dodged a loop
of hibiscus covered vines, and shot past
exquisite on the outside.
Well, if it works, Glory thought.
Yay, she hollered.
Jambu is the best.
Uh, you're an awesome glider.
Good, uh, flying.
Yay.
She called it tsunami, giving her an
amused look, and stuck out her tongue at
the sea wing.
Jambu brushed the platform a 2nd time
with his claws and took off again.
A few moments later, exquisite, thudded
down in the same spot and gave chase, her
wings pumped, and her brow was furrowed
angrily.
Glory's heart pounded as she watched them
swerve through the trees.
One more circuit.
If John Boo could stay ahead just a bit
longer, he'd win.
Hang in there.
She dug her claws into the vines below
her. wishing she could be up there, giving
him her speed somehow.
Jambu ricocheted off a tree, and dipped
through a hole in the branches, he veered
around the last curve, and suddenly flung
his wings up to stop his momentum.
He thrashed in place for a moment, and
glory saw a vine wound around his neck.
He twisted backward, gasping for air, and
flailed to the side.
With a horrible lurch in her stomach
Glory watched Jambu tip over, crossing
into the ring of trees.
At the same time, exquisite whisked past
him and landed neatly on the platform.
She lifted her wings, and turned in a
triumphant circle, as deep blue purple
waves whished through her scales.
But glory had seen something else too.
That vine hadn't appeared out of
nowhere.
Something was scurrying away from the
spot where Jambu had nearly strangled
himself.
Several somethings, in fact, with shaggy
silver fur.
Chapter 31.
How dare you accuse us of cheating?
Magnificent demanded.
The better question is, how dare you
cheat?
Glory demanded right back.
My teammates' sloths were right here in
front of us the whole time, said the
queen.
These 3 were, said Glory, pointing to the
fur balls that were clambering up to
exquisite's shoulders.
We know exquisite has several others who
could have been planted out there in the
trees, just waiting to get in the way if
it looked like she wasn't going to win.
Hmm, said grandeur, narrowing her eyes.
She'd been sitting in the same position
looking bored and regal throughout the
race.
Ridiculous, scoffed exquisite.
Her sloths aren't nearly smart enough for
that, said magnificent.
They most certainly are, exquisite
snapped, flaring her rough.
She glanced at Glory and carefully
settled it again.
But they would never do such a thing.
They do anything you told them to.
Kingachu cried, as a surge of orange
outrage rippled down her tail, she
snapped her teeth at the nearest sloth
and it chirped fiercely at her.
Enough, said Handsome.
Jambu, what did you see?
Glory barely recognized her brother with
his scales, this dismal blue gray color?
He lifted his shoulders despondently.
I don't know.
It all happened so fast.
One moment I was flying, and the next I
was choking.
I saw sloths in the trees, but.
But you can't be sure they were
exquisites, or that they had anything to
do with the vine in your way.
Magnificent finished.
Jambu gave Glory a mournful look.
It's all right, Jambu, she said.
I know you would have won in a fair
race.
She made sure her voice was loud enough
to carry to the crowd of watching rain
wings, magnificent hissed softly, and
snatched up the treetop race nut from the
low table, lashing her tail.
She dropped it in a hollowed out coconut
on her side of the arboretum.
Let's move on, Handsome said, clearing
his throat.
Perhaps the flower hunt next.
Tamarin stepped forward.
Her wings trembled, and her scales were
rippling with pale green again.
Glory wondered whether she could tell
that her emotions were on display.
Another question occurred to her.
Can you use camouflage?
She asked Tamarin.
I mean, since you can't see what you're
trying to match?
Yes, it works anyway.
Tamaron said.
Don't ask me exactly how.
She took a few deep breaths, closing her
eyes.
Dark green, dappled with sunlight and
shadows, spread across her whole body
until she matched the vines below her.
I can't choose what color I am, Cameron
explained.
So if you asked me to make my scales red
for instance, I couldn't do that, but if
I relax, they automatically switched to
whatever's around me.
Fascinating.
Glory said.
More important, Tameron didn't look quite
so terrified anymore.
Fruit bat shuffled forward, swinging her
bulky orchid necklace around so most of
it hung down her back.
An odd smell wafted forward with her, of
decaying leaves underneath something
sickly sweet.
It wasn't as bad as the smell in the
nightwing kingdom, but it wasn't pleasant
either.
So how does this contest work?
Glory asked.
And how can we be sure there's no
cheating this time?
She was gratified to see that Magnificent
couldn't keep her scales from turning red
making other dragons angry, was one skill
glory already knew she was good at.
She glanced over her shoulder at tsunami
who had her fierce face on.
She looked ready to charge into the
arboretum and take on all 5 queens
herself.
Ahem.
Handsome said hastily, clearing his
throat a few times.
Yes, the contest.
For this member of the team, the queen
has requested a flower hunt.
Therefore early this morning, I hid a
particular flower somewhere in this
arboretum.
The rare, majestic cinnamon orchid.
Not the more common yellow variant, but
the elusive red variety.
Ooh, went all the watching rain wings.
Whoever finds it 1st, naturally, will win
said handsome.
One flower?
Glory thought.
In this whole giant place.
It could be anywhere, and she can't see.
How can Tamarin even begin to look for
it?
Even if she could feel the difference
between flowers, how will she know
whether it's red or yellow?
For the 1st time, Glory thought maybe she
was going to lose this contest after
all.
Maybe she wouldn't be queen.
She narrowed her eyes at magnificent and
lashed her tail.
Fine.
I'll think of another way to rescue the
rain wings from the night kingdom if I
have to.
Handsome spread his wings.
You may begin.
Fruit Bat leaped into action.
Faster than glory would have expected
from looking at her.
Fruit bat started dashing around the
circle, poking her nose into every
crevice and pocket.
She scrabbled up drifted piles of leaves
and lifted bundles of vines.
She nudged aside dragon tails that were
draping over the edge of the platforms.
She pounced on every glimmer of orangey
red, startling quite a number of innocent
birds and beetles.
Meanwhile, Tamarin stood very still, right
where she was.
Her nostrils twitched.
Her wings went up and down as she
breathed deeply.
After a few moments of this, Glory said
um, shh, Kingachu said, she's busy.
Could she be busy in a more busy looking
way?
Glory asked.
Tamarin inhaled again and lifted her
snout.
Small feathers of flame flickered along
her ruff, shaped like the flower she was
looking for.
She can smell it?
Lori whispered to Kinkachu.
Is that what she's trying to do?
She will do it.
Kinkaju promised fiercely.
Her nose is amazing.
I believe you, Lori said, but there have
to be a 1000000 flowers within smelling
distance right now, not to mention all
these dragons and monkeys, and other
things that smell much stronger than any
one flower.
There's no way she'll find it.
You don't know Tamarind's nose, Kingichu
said.
Now shh.
Gloria sat back and crawled her tail
around her talons.
There wasn't anything she could do now
anyway.
She badly wanted to start tearing up the
arboretum, the way Fruit Bat was doing
but she wasn't allowed to help.
Is this what being queen would be like?
Issuing orders and then sitting around
waiting for dragons to carry them out?
She thought of the other queens she'd met
Queen Scarlet and Queen Coral preferred
to have their minions do their dirty work
but burn and blister both seemed rather
claws on.
Perhaps because they weren't really
queens yet, or because they'd learned
after years of war, that the only dragon
you could really trust was yourself.
Glory glanced at Sonny and Tsunami
again.
She did trust the other dragonettes, a
little, in different ways.
She trusted Sonny to at least try to do
whatever was brave and right, even if she
was too small to do it effectively.
Starflight had neither courage nor
fighting skills, but if glory ever needed
to figure out something, she'd trust
Starflight's brain in a second.
That's why she wanted to talk to him
about Scarlet before anyone else.
She could trust tsunami to fight, tooth
and claw.
Really in almost any situation, including
several where it would be quite
inappropriate.
And, of course, there was Clay, who would
do anything to save his friends.
She wished they were her team, instead of
these rain wings she barely knew.
As much as she liked Kinkachu, it was
agonizing to feel this powerless over her
own destiny.
I'm the one who wants to be queen, I
should be the only one who has to fight
for it.
Magnificent's eyes darted back and forth
between Tamarin and Fruit Bat.
When Tameron finally took a step forward
the queen let out a hiss, and Fruit Bat
whirled around to see what her competitor
was doing.
Tamarin, Gloria said quietly.
If you know where it is, move fast
because Fruit Bat is watching, and I
think she'll try to beat you to it.
The blind rain wing took another deep
breath.
Crouched, and launched herself into the
air.
She nearly overshot the platform she was
aiming for, but her tail brushed it, and
she swung back to land on it in a
graceful motion.
It was the start and finish racing
platform used by Jambu and Exquisite, the
one littered with bouquets of peach
colored, star shaped blossoms.
Fruit bat bolted after her.
Tamarin quickly bowed her head and
sniffed the bouquets, just as Fruit Bat
landed heavily beside her, Tamarin
snatched up one of the bundles, and
pulled off the sloth for a ribbon that
bound it together.
The pale pink flowers fell away, revealing
a flower hidden inside.
It was shaped like a cluster of dragon
claws, each glowing like a tongue of
fire.
Magnificent and fruit bat let out
matching cries of rage.
That sounds promising, Tamaron said with
a smile.
You did it!
Kinkaju shouted.
You found it.
She poked Glory with her tail, beaming
told you she could do it.
If rain wings had fire.
Glory was pretty sure magnificent would
have had smoke coming out of her ears and
nose.
Nicely done, Glory said, as Tamron landed
beside them again, clutching the flower
in her claws, I'm really impressed.
Glory sauntered over to the table and
took the flower hunt nut, with an arch
look at magnificent, she dropped it in
her own coconut bowl, one to one, 3 more
contests to go.
And then she'd be queen.
What should we do next?
Glory asked magnificent.
She was feeling a lot more confident
now.
How about the camouflage one?
Magnificent bared her teeth.
Sounds perfect.
Have you ever been in a camouflage
contest before?
Handsome asked glory.
Not precisely, Glory said, but I have had
to use my camouflage to avoid dragons who
want to kill me.
So if you're asking whether I can handle
the pressure, I'm going to go with yes.
Actually, I was wondering if you knew the
rules, Hansom said, hiding a smile.
But they're not complicated.
One of you hides first, somewhere within
eyesight of this spot, then the other
will search for you, and then you'll
switch roles.
I will judge who finds the other
fastest.
If it is too close to tell, we will try
again.
Got it, Glory said.
Do you remember, Hanson began, turning to
grandeur?
Glory wondered which of them was older.
They both seemed as ancient as the claws
of the clouds mountains.
Of course, I remember.
Grandeur snapped.
She drew herself up and hissed at the
gathered crowd until they were all quiet
listening.
I remember everything.
I remember when we actually needed our
camouflage to protect ourselves from
invading dragons.
It wasn't a game back then.
It was what we had to do to survive.
Enough boring stories.
Magnificent commanded, earning herself
another glare.
Grandeur, hush up until it's your
contest.
I'll hide first.
Handsome tied a long, fat leaf around
glory's eyes.
As darkness settled around her.
She thought that this must be what it was
like for Tamarind all the time.
She could remember only one story about a
blind dragon in the scrolls, and it was
from long ago, before the scorching.
A moment later, the blindfold was lifted
away.
The curious faces of 100s of rain wings
filled her vision.
You may begin, said the old dragon with a
nod.
Glory blinked and turned in a circle
searching for clues.
Magnificent had vanished very
thoroughly.
Her small crown of white flowers lay
abandoned on the vines.
There was no sign of her gold tipped
purple scales, and none of the hammocks
around the arena had a sudden unusual
bulge in them.
Where could she be?
Where would I hide if I were a
particularly forgetful, spectacularly
lazy rain wing?
She didn't think magnificent was the type
to climb trees, or hang by her tail if
there was somewhere she could lie down
comfortably instead.
And most of the platforms and walkways
were too crowded with dragons for her to
squeeze in their easily, which gave glory
an idea.
She turned to study the watching rain
wings.
Some of them might have seen where
magnificent hid, and all of them had been
playing this kind of hide and seek their
whole lives.
They must be scanning the area too, trying
to find her first.
She noticed that exquisite and fruit bat
were staring straight up at a nearby tree
swathed in fuzzy moss.
They were staring at it a little too hard
as if they were hoping glory would notice
that they were.
Fruit bat nudged grandeur, and the
stately old dragon gave her a look of
disgust.
Then Glory caught a couple of rain wings
glancing in the direction of a fruit
stand on the far side of the arena.
They narrowed their eyes at it, then
leaned in to whisper to each other.
Worth a look, Glory thought.
She flew across the arena to the fruit
stand.
It was a wooden platform, with low walls
that were built to also be tables, most
of them covered with mangoes, pineapples
the red sticky spheres, and the star
shaped green fruits.
Crowded bunches of bananas hung from the
branches overhead.
She swept her tail across the floor of
the platform, then studied the tables, but
she couldn't see any sign of a dragon
hiding anywhere.
She looked up and poked the dangling
banana bunches.
Finally, she jumped over one of the walls
and flew up above the bananas.
There was something a little odd about
the way some of them were hanging, as if
something heavy were lying on top of
them.
It was eerie.
All she could see were shadows and light
green leaves and bright yellow bananas
but when she reached out, her claws
brushed against dragon scales, and the
indignant hiss that came from them, told
her she'd found what she was looking
for.
Your majesty, Glory said, with a polite
bow.
Very impressive camouflage, she added
honestly.
Let's see what you can do.
Magnificent grumbled.
Her scales shifting back to purple.
They returned to the center of the arena
as the rain wings all applauded.
It took glory a moment to realize they
were applauding for her.
She hoped that meant she had found the
queen fairly quickly.
Now she just had to hide even better than
magnificent had.
Handsome stepped up to tie the blindfold
around magnificent's eyes.
Glory let her scales shift into the
greens of the vines below her.
She didn't want anyone to see where she
went. especially the other queens.
Her 1st idea had been to go straight up
and blend into the sky overhead, but to
stay aloft, she would have had to keep
her wings moving, and she was worried
that Magnificent might feel the breeze.
So instead, she headed for the tree
exquisite and fruit bat had been staring
at.
She swarmed up the side of it, feeling
the shaggy moss squish below her talons.
Her scales had changed instantly into the
dark brown and yellowish green of the
moss covered tree.
Once she thought she was high enough, she
twisted around so she could see
everything below her.
Then she flattened herself against the
trunk and concentrated, adding the shape
of a tiny blue tree frog on her back for
extra camouflage, which was a trick
mangrove had taught her.
Down below, she heard handsome tail
magnificent that she could start
looking.
The queen's eyes popped open, and she
turned immediately to the other queens.
Exquisite and fruit bat lifted their
wings in the fuddlement.
Grandeur yawned coldly.
Magnificent spun in a circle, peering at
everything.
She let out a small hiss of frustration
then gathered her wings.
Suddenly, she bared her fangs and charged
toward the edge of the circle where Sonny
was standing.
She wouldn't dare hurt my friends.
But glory felt herself flinch as Sunny
jumped back.
At the same moment, Silver leaped off
Sonny's back with a yelp of alarm, and
bolted toward the tree where Glory was
hiding.
Magnificent saw where the sloth was going
shot past her, and slammed into the tree
trunk, nearly jarring glory loose.
The queen scrambled up the tree so fast
she stepped on Glory's wings before
realizing she'd found her.
With a triumphant yell.
She backed up and poked glory in the
snout.
Found you.
Magnificent crowed.
Silver caught up and flung herself into
Glory's arms, shivering.
Glory swung onto a branch, so she could
hold the sloth to her chest and stroke
its fur.
Did you think that was funny?
Glory asked magnificent, scaring a
harmless sloth like that.
From the murmurs and shocked expressions
on the faces below them, she guessed this
wasn't a very popular way to treat one of
the rain wing pets.
She'll survive, magnificent said, and
here's the important part.
I won.
Glory looked down at handsome with a
sinking feeling.
He spread his talons in a, What can I
do?
gesture.
The Queen is correct, he said.
Magnificent wins this round.
Chapter 32.
Oh, look, Magnificent said cheerfully
pointing to the glint of sunlight on
wings flapping through the trees.
The fruit gatherers are coming back.
She flew back to the center of the
arboretum and snatched one of the nuts
off the mahogany table, 2 to one.
Wasn't that cheating?
Sonny called, as Glory glided back down
to her team.
Kinkaju had furious red stripes marching
along her scales, and Jambu was back to
blue gray again.
Glory wondered if her brother had more
than 2 moods.
That was totally cheating, tsunami
shouted.
You can't let her get away with that.
Boo, hiss.
Silence them, Magnificent said to Hanson
with a frown.
He spread his wings and cleared his
throat.
Nothing in the rules forbids what the
queen did, he announced.
She is the winner. officially.
If not in spirit.
Magnificent glared at him, while Mangrove
and Dazzling swooped down from the
trees.
Glory was too dazed to chime in.
The others might call it cheating, but as
far as she was concerned, Magnificent had
only found a trick to reveal Glory's
hiding place, the same way Glory had used
the rain wing audience for clues.
So glory had really lost.
She'd lost.
She couldn't pay attention to the sorting
and counting going on, as mangrove and
dazzling spilled fruits of all shapes and
sizes across the greenery.
Hanson picked each one up, muttered over
it for a moment, and set it in a pile.
If I were competing alone, it would be
over by now.
Glory realized.
She would have lost the throne in a
direct contest with magnificent.
If she won it now, it would be only
because the other rain wings made it
happen, Tamarin, who didn't know her at
all, Mangrove and Kinkaju.
If they could do it, Kinkaju's eyes were
fixed on mangrove's fruit pile, she
fidgeted with her tail and counted along
under her breath.
Handsome examined the last fruit, a dark
blue prickled ball that oozed bright
green juice when he poked it.
He nodded, and placed it on mangroves
pile.
Kinkajoo shot Glory a delighted look. 17
to 16, said handsome.
The winner is mangrove.
What?
Shrilled magnificent.
She whipped around to glare at Dazzling
who had yellow speckles around her mouth
and a trail of green splatters down her
chest.
You ate some of them?
I know there were 19 there when I. She
stopped abruptly.
Sorry, dazzling muttered.
I thought 16 would be enough.
Well, you thought wrong.
Magnificent growled.
Excuse me, said Handsome.
Did you say there were 19 there?
There was an awkward pause as the 2
queens glared at each other.
Magnificent flicked her tail and looked
down her nose at handsome.
Are you accusing me of something?
She asked coldly.
I am?
Kingaju blurted.
You collected fruits and stashed them
somewhere ahead of time.
Ludicrous, said the queen.
The red flickers along her wings vanished
abruptly.
And impossible to prove.
It occurred to glory that magnificent
might have chosen to be purple today, so
that no one would spot any shimmers of
guilt in her scales.
Clever, she thought, glancing down at her
own.
The yellow had faded a little, and small
gray clouds were gathering around her
shoulder blades and wing tips.
Doesn't matter anyway, Dazzling pointed
out to Kinkachu.
You won.
Kinkatu jabbed Glory with her tail, and
Glory snapped back into focus.
There was still a chance.
Now they were tied, and there was one
contest left.
It matters if you're planning to cheat
again, she said sharply.
That won't be necessary.
Wind rustled through the leaves as
grandeur slid majestically between glory
and magnificent.
Her bones creaked like ancient forests
and the silver cast of her scales made
her look as if she were reflecting
moonlight instead of sunlight.
She wasn't like the other queens.
In fact, she wasn't like any other dragon
in the village.
Glory thought grandeur might be the only
rain wing who actually looked, moved, and
sounded like a real queen.
She arched her neck and peered down at
Kinkaju.
I can crush this little creature easily
on my own.
We'll see, Kinkaju said bravely, but
anxious streaks of green flickered in her
rough.
This is asking too much of her.
Glory worried.
Kinkaju was barely half grandeur's size
with hardly any training.
The night wings had been so underwhelmed
by her venom, that they hadn't even
bothered binding her mouth.
How could she possibly win?
Handsome beckoned the 2 dragons into the
center of the arboretum?
Standard venom practice rules apply?
He said.
Take the utmost caution to hit no living
creature. will be testing distance and
targeting.
Who'd like to go first?
I, said grandeur.
She eyed handsome and his 2 helpers as
they rolled a long polished plank of wood
across the vines.
It was as wide as 5 talon prints and 4
times as long, with small measurement
marks all the way along it.
One end stopped at grandeur's front
talons.
She stretched her neck and jaw, while the
rain wings scurried out of the way
leaving the plank laid out in front of
her like a welcoming carpet.
Whenever your hansom started.
Grandeur's mouth snapped open, and a
spray of black venom shot out, the
droplets spattered on the wood near the
far end of the plank, sizzling and
burning small holes where they fell.
The watching dragons all ooed
admiringly.
I'm guessing that's pretty impressive
Glory said to Mangrove.
His sigh answered her question.
Grandeur stepped aside with a polite
gesture at Kinkaju.
The little dragonette stepped up
nervously, opened her mouth as wide as
she could, and shot a tiny jet of venom
at the plank.
It landed barely a quarter of the way
between her claws and grandeur's drops.
Glory's heart sank.
Mangrove dropped his head into his front
talons with a groan.
Kinkaju turned to glory with a
heartbroken expression.
There's still the targeting part.
Jambu said, hopefully.
He patted the little dragonette on the
back.
The helpers were already dragging out a
kind of easel, painted with 3 yellow and
white circles.
What if I fail?
Kinkachu said to Glory.
All those dragons.
It'll be my fault if we never see them
again.
It'll be my fault that you're not queen.
Stop that, Lori said, placing one talent
over kinkachoos.
I lost my own contest, remember?
It's my fault more than anyone's, but I
will be queen one day.
And in the meanwhile, She caught
Mangrove's eye to make sure he was
listening.
We'll get orchid and the other rain wings
back, no matter what it takes.
Maybe I won't have an army, but we'll
make a rescue mission out of my friends
and anyone else who's willing to go.
So don't think about that right now.
All I can ask is that you try your best.
And I know I don't even have to ask
because you're the kind of dragon who
always does.
That's true.
Kinkachu said.
I am that kind of dragon.
She squared her shoulders.
I will.
That's what I'm going to do.
Glory glanced up, and realized that
grandeur had been listening to.
The old queen turned around and casually
shot a spray of her venom at the painted
board.
It landed precisely in the center of the
1st circle.
Magnificent gave glory a triumphant
smile.
It would have been really nice to wipe
that smile off her face.
And one day, I will.
I will be queen of this tribe.
That's what I'm meant for.
I'm sure of it.
Kinkaju stepped up beside grandeur, opened
her mouth, and sprayed her venom at the
circles.
The drops splashed right on top of
grandeurs, and a hissing sound came from
the board as the wood melted a little
more.
The older rain wing made a sound of
approval and padded Kinkaju's head.
Then she tilted her head just a little
and shot a black jet directly into the
center of the 2nd circle.
Kingaju took a deep breath and did the
same.
More sizzling and smoking came from the
wood.
Don't get excited.
Glory told herself.
Although she couldn't help feeling
impressed with Kinkaju.
She knew for a fact that she wouldn't
have been able to aim that precisely, but
if the 2 dragons tied on this part of the
challenge, grandeur would still win
because of the distance part.
Practice a gracious in defeat face, and
then get ready to study like life depends
on it so I can try this again.
I wonder how long I have to wait between
challenges.
Grandeur opened her mouth, and then a
sloth tumbled out of the trees, landing
in front of the board.
Kingaju leaped to shove it out of the way
and time seemed to slow down, so glory
could watch, each drop of venom sail in
an unhurried arc to land, splash, splash
right, on Kingaju's wing.
Chapter 33.
All around the arboretum, rain wings
started screaming.
Kinkachu collapsed in a ball of scales
that went instantly white with pain
except for the 3 spots where black venom
was eating through her wing.
Glory rushed to her side and found
grandeur opposite her, grabbing Kingaju's
talons.
Grandeur's face was horrified.
Help her.
Glory yelled.
She remembered what Jambu had told her
about how a relative's venom would
counteract your own.
Who's related to you?
Get them over here.
I don't know.
Grandeur said hopelessly.
I haven't had any eggs in decades.
I haven't tried matching venom with
anyone in so long.
I don't think there's anyone related to
me anymore.
That's insane, Glory shouted.
Why can't you dragons keep track of these
things?
You must have had dragonettes at some
point, and they must have had dragonettes
too.
Maybe, but no one has.
Kinkaju shrieked, a high wailing sound of
agony.
Start trying.
Glory cried.
Try everyone.
Try me.
She grabbed the easel and spat a messy
puddle of venom on the corner.
The wood hissed and melted, as if it were
burning from the inside.
Grandeur didn't hesitate.
She sprayed her venom right on top of
glories.
And the melting stopped.
Glory didn't have time for the shocked
expression on grandeur's face.
She couldn't risk trying to aim neatly
for the same 3 spots where Grandeur's
venom had hit Kinkaju.
She might end up causing far more
damage.
Quickly, she ripped 3 leaves off the vine
below her, dipped them in the puddle of
her own venom, and stuck them to
Kinkaju's wounds.
The sizzling sound faded, and the black
acid stopped spreading.
You're all right.
You're going to be all right.
Glory said to Kinkachu, lifting the
dragonette's head in her talons.
She realized the little dragon had
fainted.
Also, grandeur was staring at her, as if
sloths were parading out of glory's
ears.
What, Glory said.
So I'm your granddaughter, or great
grandniece or something?
It's not like anyone around here really
cares, right?
I do, said grandeur.
Because it means that you are descended
from the original line of Rain Wing
Queens.
And so I am not the last one worthy of
the throne after all.
Glory blinked at her.
I didn't think anyone cared about royal
blood here.
Nobody but me, said grandeur.
We used to keep track of the royal eggs
but my daughters were useless, so we
merged our eggs with the tribes, hoping
to find successors who were queens in
spirit, if not blood.
There were a few who might have been
great if they'd ever tried for the
throne.
But the truth is, I've never found a
dragonette who both wanted to be queen
and deserved to be.
Until now, She stood up, and faced
magnificent, like an enormous storm
cloud.
I forfeit.
Kinkaju wins.
What?
Magnificent shrieked.
Did you hear that?
Glory said to Kingaju.
You won.
The dragonette's eyes fluttered open, and
she managed a smile.
That is.
Super cool, she whispered.
Tamarin came up behind them and slid her
wing under Kingaju's head, so glory could
stand up next to grandeur.
She felt dizzy with disbelief.
It's my throne anyway.
Grandeur said to Magnificent.
I have merely tolerated all of you on it
because I thought experience might
transform you into worthy queens.
She shot a disgusted look at dazzling
exquisite, and fruit bat.
That theory turned out to be quite
wrong.
You don't know anything about this dragon
magnificent complained, pointing at
glory.
I know she'll be a better queen than you
said grandeur.
She turned to the assembled tribe with a
sweeping gesture.
Behold, your new queen, queen glory of
the rain wings.
And they cheered.
Glory stepped back, dazzled, as what
looked like the whole tribe rose into the
air, beating their wings and singing out
joyfully.
The rainbow of different colors was swept
away on a tide of sunflower gold
excitement, and Glory thought to
herself.
Wow.
I'm a queen.
Queen Glory of the Rain Wings.
That'll be my name in the history
scrolls.
Not glory the mistake.
Or glory the lazy rain wing, or glory you
could never be as good as some nameless
sky wing who died 6 years ago.
I'm responsible for all these dragons
now.
We can rescue the missing rain wings, and
make sure no more dragonets ever get lost
again.
Starfly can help me teach them all how to
read and write.
I'll protect them.
I'll lead them.
I'll make them, us, a tribe we can be
proud of.
Glory, the queen who chose her own
destiny, saved her subjects, and turned
her tribe into the greatest dragons in
all of Pyria.
Speech!
Jambu demanded, barreling into her.
His scales were a pink so vibrant.
It almost hurt her eyes to look at him.
Don't you start.
Luckily, no one would hear me over all
this noise, Glory said, with a wave at
her jubilant subjects.
She gave her brother an affectionate
shove, and he wound his tail around hers
for a moment, and she didn't even mind.
As he bounded off to assault someone
else's eyes, she felt movement at her
wing and turned, thinking it was
Kinkachu.
But it was sunny.
Sunbeams danced on her gold scales as the
little sandwing beamed at her.
You did it, she said.
Not by myself, said Glory.
I needed these dragons to make it
happen.
She spread her wings to encompass Jambu
and Mangrove, but they were bouncing
around in excitement.
Tamaron was hugging Kinkaju, and even the
wounded dragonette was pale pink with
joy.
This is so unfair, tsunami said, landing
beside them.
She sighed dramatically.
This was supposed to be my story.
Stupid sea wings, already having a decent
queen.
Maybe you'll still be the sea wing queen
one day, Glory said.
And then I can give you tips on how to be
majestic and brilliant.
They grinned at each other.
This just proves what I've always said
tsunami observed.
Who needs a prophecy to tell you how to
make an awesome destiny?
True, Glory said.
Take that prophecy.
You're not about me?
Well, I'm not all about you either.
Sunny fluttered her wings like a settling
butterfly.
We still need you though, she said.
You're still one of us, and no one will
ever convince me otherwise.
Glory brushed Sonny's wing with hers.
Feeling a warmth that wasn't coming from
the sand wings scales.
The 1st thing we have to do is rescue the
rain wings from the night kingdom, she
said, which means turning these dragons
into an army as fast as possible.
Tsunami can help with that.
Yes, I can, tsunami said, flexing her
claws.
Well, actually, Sonny said, I was
thinking maybe there's another.
The sound of branches thrashing overhead
made glory spin around.
Clay came barreling through the trees
trailing broken twigs and wrestling loops
of vines out of his way.
He stared around wildly at the rejoicing
rain wings, spotted glory, and crashed
down in front of her.
Clay!
Sonny cried.
What is it?
What's wrong?
Horrible images popped into Glory's head
of her friend's hurt, of a night wing
army, marching through the tunnel to
invade the rainforest.
It's Starflight, Clay said.
He's disappeared.
He shot an anxious look at glory, and she
remembered the argument she'd had with
Starflight the last time she'd seen him.
Surely he hadn't...
Glory.
I'm sorry, said Clay.
But I think he's gone to warn the night
wings.
Epilogue.
I hate this place, Flame said, glowering
at the dark rock dust caught between his
claws. hate, hate, hate it.
I hate it more, Squid moaned.
He coughed gloomily.
My scales feel so dry, my talons hurt, and
I'm hungry.
I hate that big old stupid, horrible
night wing.
Viper hissed.
I can't believe my dad let him take me.
Squid edged to the mouth of the cave and
stared at the smoky sky, as if hoping
Nautilus would appear suddenly, winging
to his rescue.
Oh, stop, fate speaker said, flicking her
tail.
It's not that bad.
Actually, it really was that bad, but she
certainly wasn't going to admit it to
these four.
She had never, ever imagined that the
Knight Kingdom, her kingdom, would be so
dark and smelly, and that all the dragons
here would be so incredibly cranky.
It was as if being the most awesome
dragons in the world didn't even make
them happy at all.
But hey, she was home.
And Maro Sear said she was part of a
prophecy, which was even more awesome
than being a night wing.
So what was there to complain about
really?
I want to die.
Ochre groaned.
The mudwing dragonette had been lying on
the floor of the cave for practically the
entire day since they'd been dumped here
by Morrow's year.
I want you to die too, Flame
volunteered.
You smell ghastly.
Viper agreed.
I don't think I should have eaten that
dead thing.
Okra mumbled.
He paused, then added, Or all of your
dead things.
Well, I wasn't going to eat it, Squid
said snootily.
We are on an island.
I think someone should be able to bring
me a fresh fish, considering who my
father is, and the fact that I'm a
dragonette of destiny.
I mean really.
Fate speakers shifted on her talons
uncomfortably.
She hadn't really liked the look of what
the grumpy Nightwings had brought them to
eat either.
Why was everything so decayed and
horrible smelling?
Have a vision, she told herself.
That'll make you feel better.
She closed her eyes and scrunched up her
forehead and concentrated as hard as she
could.
I foresee.
She said, in a portentous tone.
No, shouted Viper, spare us, squid
cried.
Okra moaned.
Now, I want you both to die, said Flame.
Oh, shush, fate speaker said, with her
eyes still closed.
I'm using my powers.
Behold, I foresee, uh, Walrus, a walrus
in our future, an entire walrus for us to
eat.
Why are you torturing me?
Ogre wailed.
We hardly ever had walrus even when we
live next to the sea, Squid pointed out.
Despite the fact that you predicted we
would just about every week, Viper added
sourly.
My visions are not always precise, fate
speaker said breezily.
It does not say when this walrus will
arrive, only that it will, and then we
shall feast, and everything will be
wonderful again.
When has it ever been wonderful before?
Flame snarled.
Do us a favor and stop sharing your
stupid powers with us.
Viper snapped.
Grumpy, ungrateful lizards.
Fate speaker sat down in the mouth of the
cave and turned up her snout, ignoring
everyone.
If they couldn't appreciate the gifts she
bestowed upon them, well, then, fine.
She would just keep her visions to
herself, until she had another great one
anyway.
The night kingdom volcanoes stretched
below her. dark and craggy, and swarming
with black dragons.
There weren't nearly as many night wings
as she'd expected.
It felt more like the talons of peace
camp than a whole kingdom.
But the dragonettes hadn't exactly been
given a tour.
They hadn't even been taken to the big
fortress, which fate speaker assumed was
where the Queen lived.
Nor had they been introduced to the night
wing queen, or anyone, actually.
Maru Sier had stuffed them in this high
cave and stomped away again.
Fate speaker squinted down at the black
sand beach in the distance.
A cave was set into the cliff there, and
earlier, she'd seen several dragons swoop
into it.
Now they were coming out again, and they
had a night wing dragonette in their
talons.
He looked about the same age as fate
speaker, and he was unconscious.
His wings drooped, and his claws dragged
in the sand.
Her scales began to tingle in that way
that she was sure meant a sign from the
universe.
There was something important about that
dragonette.
I'm having another vision, she
announced.
The bones left over from Ogre's dinner
splatted on the ledge beside her.
She was lucky that Squid didn't have very
good aim.
I'm just letting you know that I'm not
telling you about it, she said, even
though I'm sure it's very significant.
The others ignored her.
Which they did way too often.
Well, it didn't matter.
She was home with her own kind now.
She had a destiny to follow.
And she was sure the unconscious
dragonette, who was now being carried
into the fortress, would be part of it.
This is Shannon McManus.
We hope that you have enjoyed this
production of Wings of Fire, Book 3, The
Hidden Kingdom, by 2ET Sutherland.
A Nightwing Guide to the Dragons of Pyria
read by 2ET Sutherland.
This audiobook was produced by Dion Audio
and directed by Sebastian Zetton.
Executive producer Paul R.
Gagney.
Print edition published by Scholastic
Press, an imprint of Scholastic Inc.
Text copyright 2013 by Tui T. Sutherland
production copyright 2016 by Scholastic
Inc.
All rights reserved.
Hi, this is Tooey Sutherland.
A Nightwing Guide to the Dragons of
Pyrea.
Sand wings.
Description.
Pale gold or white scales, the color of
desert sand, poisonous barbed tail, forked
black tongues.
Abilities can survive a long time without
water.
Poison enemies with the tips of their
tails like scorpions.
Bury themselves for camouflage in the
desert sand.
Breathe fire.
Queen.
Since the death of Queen Oasis, the tribe
is split between 3 rivals for the throne
sisters burn, blister, and blaze.
Alliances.
Byrne fights alongside Skywings and
Mudwings.
Blister is allied with the sea wings, and
Blaze has the support of most sand wings
as well as an alliance with the ice
wings.
Mudwings.
Description, thick armored brown scales
sometimes with amber and gold
underscales.
Large flat heads with nostrils on top of
the snout.
Abilities, can breathe fire if warm
enough.
Hold their breath for up to an hour, blend
into large mud puddles, usually very
strong.
Queen, queen moorhen.
Alliances, currently allied with Burn and
the Sky Wings in the Great War.
Sky Wings.
Description, red gold or orange scales
enormous wings.
Abilities, powerful fighters and fliers
can breathe fire.
Queen, Queen Scarlet.
Alliances, currently allied with Burn and
the Mudwings in the Great War.
Sea Wings.
Description, blue or green or aquamarine
scales, webs between their claws, gills
on their necks, glow in the dark stripes
on their tails, snouts, underbellies.
Abilities, can breathe underwater, see in
the dark, create huge waves with one
splash of their powerful tails.
Excellent swimmers.
Queen, Queen Coral.
Alliances, currently allied with blister
in the Great War.
Ice Wings.
Description, silvery scales like the moon
or pale blue like ice.
Ridged claws to grip the ice, forked blue
tongues, tails narrow to a whip thin
end.
Abilities can withstand subzero
temperatures and bright light.
Exhale a deadly, freezing breath.
Queen, Queen Glacier.
Alliances.
Currently allied with Blaze and most of
the sandwings in the Great War.
Rain wings.
Description.
Scales constantly shift colors, usually
bright like birds of paradise, prehensile
tales.
Abilities, can camouflage their scales to
blend into their surroundings.
Use their prehensile tails for climbing
no known natural weapons.
Queen, Queen dazzling.
Alliances, not involved in the Great
War.
Nightwings.
Description, purplish black scales and
scattered silver scales on the underside
of their wings, like a night sky full of
stars.
Forked black tongues.
Abilities, can breathe fire, disappear
into dark shadows, read minds, foretell
the future.
Queen, a closely guarded secret.
Alliances, too mysterious and powerful to
be part of the war.